[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
war zone two I'm like the biggest war
zone player that's my main thing so I'm
just super hyped to just hop on and see
the new map yeah seriously it is going
to be so exciting obviously being able
to get on the sticks try it out see how
you feel about it what are you expecting
from this new war zone because obviously
like you said you've been grinding
Warzone for a long time now but what do
you want to see what's of the changes
you want made I'm definitely wanting to
see like New Movement maybe because you
know slide casting like the biggest
thing in Warzone so maybe like a new
thing that Bridges the skill Gap and
adds like a new level to like grind it
out you know yeah I love that so do I
thank you so much appreciate it have the
best time enjoy yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
what are you most looking forward to
seeing here today I am looking forward
to seeing some incredible Modern Warfare
2 multiplayer gameplay I'm looking
forward to seeing something that's
familiar but new and challenging yeah a
little bit of throwback right are you
excited to kind of Replay an old classic
in a new iteration Modern Warfare 2 is
my absolute favorite Cod of all time
2009 that was my very first Call of Duty
that I ever owned I am so ready to
experience just that Nostalgia again
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
huge Creator but we also have three
incredible Pro players ex-pro player but
amazing Creator as well coming out
through here Modern Warfare 2. this is
huge for you guys and for the rest of
your career of course so going into your
new season what do you want out of this
big game because this is massive view
guys I'm a simple guy when it comes to
Call of Duty I just want to see the best
card of all time being played and I
personally think that MW2 will be the
best card of all time well you know what
I think it will be it will be you know
so he was saying earlier he wants like
nice and fast-paced I'm looking for the
opposite I want a nice slow place to
Pace game I can sit a little further
back watch over my teammates I'm 25 and
I'm proud of it and uh I think it's
gonna be the perfect mix of both some
good maps some good fun I get to beat on
him for another year and I get to
hopefully beat his team lost by one
round recently at the big one so
hopefully hopefully a good year ahead
anything you like to have yeah I'm just
looking for good maps I mean I want to
see uh just a different variety of maps
I think it'd be really cool and we could
switch it up between fast and slow I
just want to see some creativity in the
map so that's what I'm looking forward
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
I'm not excited for I think honestly
being able to see a lot of people who
played online together finally in the
same area after everything that's gone
on and being able to get back together
like that's going to be a really fun
time for people to be able to like see
each other across the way now there's a
lot happening there's a lot being
revealed you guys are getting that
inside scoop on it but we've got Warzone
2.8 we've got multiplayer so much going
on what is your game what's your game on
cards you know what you're looking
forward to so I'm a huge multiplayer
Search and Destroy fan so a little bit
different than most people here they
play mainly warzone
not that great at Warzone but Search and
Destroy quick skipping that's my thing
okay we'd love to hear that and what
about you also Search and Destroy that's
how we met so hardcore yeah all day
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
s
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
course here for Modern Warfare 2 so many
different things that you're going to be
able to test out here today what are you
looking forward to the most I'm most
looking forward to find out more
information about Warzone 2 and the
future of the franchise I think that war
zone has really helped adapt to a casual
audience whereas the CDL has been
growing the more competitive side of
things and I just want them to see them
you know be able to refine it come in
with Ricochet this time not have any of
the issues we did with your dance and
really be able to you know just start
hit the ground running this time as we
look ahead to war zone two do you have
any favorite memories on Warzone on war
zone one oh yeah I have some great ones
um the end of her dance was probably one
of my favorite things I streamed for I
did my first subathon it was seven days
straight and we we covered the whole
thing from the Easter eggs and all the
things that told us what was going to
happen to seeing the nuke actually
explode and I I don't know if anybody
keeps up with modern war zone but I had
been saying since for dance came out
that it was going to be blown up by a
nuke so to see it happen was just
euphoric for me
love I can't wait to see if your
predictions come true for this next game
as well thank you so much thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
obviously new iteration of the game
we're expecting so many different things
coming out to play here what do you
expect out of this new game what are you
looking forward to I'm looking forward
to the Call of Duty polished feel you
expect especially from Infinity Ward I
think that was my favorite part of
Modern Warfare 2019 which is how smooth
everything felt I love the field
upgrades I'm wondering if they
potentially added any more and at the
end of the day they've already teased
earlier today the brand new gunsmith 2.0
I want to see what type of crazy weapons
we can come up with I cannot wait to
just lay the smackdown on all the Call
of Duty League Pros that are here
they're all absolute noobs I'm looking
forwards today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right swag so good to have you guys
in the building of course we have Modern
Warfare 2 coming up you're gonna get a
chance to get on the sticks and play it
how are you feeling about this brand new
title really good man I mean MW2 the
name itself has so much hype around it
and it's just so exciting to play a game
Infinity war is my favorite company to
make the game so I'm super excited
amazing stuff so gents how are you guys
finished we've got Warzone 2.0 our first
event here so I mean we're really
excited
okay anything you'd like to add how are
you feeling I'm feeling good I'm super
excited this is a first like Call of
Duty
wise this is really new to us really
exciting uh I don't know what to expect
but I I just I'm just ready to play you
know I mean
any favorite memories from the original
Modern Warfare 2 that anyone wants to
share
uh I I I I remember
I remember the first nuke I ever got was
on the map s State and I was hype I was
like 13 13 years old silence ACR going
crazy
it could be a more recent memory
all right campaign boy I always came
playing I played campaign well I I do
know we're gonna have a kick-ass
campaign coming in so what what do you
expect out of a good campaign so if
you're a campaign guy what do you look
for I don't know I just played the
missions of fires I just want to fire
missions again I go live wasn't that the
one we have the Chrome be secretive or
something like that I always love the
like the sniper missions it was really
dope I love that we'll tell you what I'm
not gonna waste any more time go enjoy
it get on the sticks and uh we'll we'll
catch up with you later see how you feel
about it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Warzone 2.0 what are you expecting what
are your big expectations from this new
iteration of water
um I'm excited I'm excited to see the
map with Caldera there's a lot of like
elevation and I liked in verdance how it
was like a lot of buildings so I'm
hoping to see a lot of like buildings
for like building fights because I'm I'm
a close range player so that's what I'm
looking forward to
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all of us let's go get him
[Music]
listen up these guys on the ground
they are your brothers now yes sir
foreign
and welcome to Call of Duty next
I am Johanna Ferris the general manager
of Call of Duty and I am thrilled to
help kick off a truly significant moment
not only for the highly anticipated
upcoming release of Modern Warfare 2 but
a very significant moment for the future
of the entire Call of Duty franchise you
see over the last several years we've
experienced explosive and dynamic growth
and we've learned a ton along the way
and those learnings have fueled our
ambition to deliver a wholly new
elevated player Experience One focused
of course on delivering more fun and
Innovation but also state-of-the-art
Tech advancements built to support a
more connected Call of Duty Community
than ever before
so just know that what we shared today
across Modern Warfare 2 our brand new
Warzone 2.0 experience coming later this
fall and are designed to bring Warzone
to mobile for players on the go are all
certainly big news but it's just the
first chapter of the very bold long-term
Vision that we carry to take Call of
Duty to even higher Heights in the years
to come ultimately though we know that
you our players and fans around the
world will be the judge of all that and
it's why we are thrilled to be doing
this on the eve of our Modern Warfare 2
Beta And to be here live in person with
more than 200 of the biggest streamers
and creators in all of gaming they will
finally get their hands on the true star
of the show The gameplay itself so let's
get right into it it is my esteemed
pleasure to introduce alongside me
Patrick Kelly co-studio head of Infinity
Ward and the executive creative director
of Call of Duty Pat welcome
thank you Johanna
it's so exciting to be here with all of
you uh it's been such a journey to get
to this place
you know on the franchise I always get
asked by people or regularly get asked
by people what are the areas you focused
on improving or what are the areas you
innovated on
we worked on improving and innovating on
every area of the game I I it always
comes back to gameplay gameplay is King
but I I could go on and on
things like third person things like
what we've innovated in the space of
Battle Royale we've got an all-new mode
in DMZ that has large player counts
along with massive player counts of AI
and it goes on and on and on we've got
mobile connected with progression and
everything else across all of the games
and it just goes on and on
but you know what it all comes back to
one thing it comes back to fun
everything we do is in the service of
fun whether you're a hardcore player or
a casual player whether you are somebody
who likes to play with your friends or
you like to play alone wherever you play
it be it on Console or PC or mobile
however you play whether you're a camper
or a Slayer we've tried to think about
fun for you and hopefully today you're
going to see that and play that and uh
fun Is What You Come Away with
absolutely uh you know fun is definitely
what we're going to be heavily focused
on and I'm particularly excited about
some of the social features that are
coming as part of this launch things
like proximity chat and do Gulag twists
there's definitely going to be instances
where players will interact not only
with their own squads but may even have
to work together with other players an
unexpected and pretty fresh ways we've
already seen some hilarious interactions
in fact during play sessions and I can't
wait to see how these new ways to
connect evolve over time now Pat what
can you tell us about weapons oh wow
so we've completely innovated in the
area of connecting you the player to
your instance in the game making you
feel more in the game and I guess you
can think about it as starting out with
the camera the camera represents your
eyes right so connecting the camera to
your body we've done that with some
inverse kinematics and some physics and
other things like that we've connected
then the body to the hands on the gun
again with some sophisticated uh inverse
kinematics we've connected the gun with
the actual bullets coming out of it so
now when wherever that gun is pointed
however it's pointed the bullets are
coming out of it exactly from the barrel
there's no disconnect there and that's
before I even get into what we've done
with the new Gunsmithing and how you
build your weapons and the platforms Etc
but look I you're gonna play it and I
hope you'll love it like we do all right
well we've taken up enough time but
before they kick us off the stage can we
tell them about rage kids yes thank you
so we with the beginning of Modern
Warfare 2 and then shortly after that
war zone 2.0 and then very shortly after
that for the first time ever we're going
to release a raid in Call of Duty it's a
very different kind of gameplay it's
very intense we think it's very fun
um and we're super excited about it and
by the way there's one other thing I
want to talk about for all all of you
hardcore players out there I heard so
many of you talk about what what kinds
of gameplay challenges can you give us
Beyond just winning which anyway I won't
go off on that but we've got a whole
series of quests and gameplay challenges
that occur when you actually win in war
zone or you hit different Milestones
that you'll have an opportunity to do
and believe me when I say everyone in
the match will know when you're on them
and if you if you Prevail at them so
look forward to that
big things ahead and now before we kick
it over to Miles and team to carry the
day we are extremely excited to give you
the world premiere of The Modern Warfare
2 multiplayer trailer thanks again and
enjoy the show
itself all over the globe
we've never seen activity on this scale
before
they have a norming
we have each other the world is a
vampire
s
enemies above
drill charge
you're gonna be okay
[Applause]
gotcha
[Music]
do not let them cross the border
take him out
[Applause]
get ready James we have never seen a war
zone like this
[Music]
enemy healer
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta
we got info reports Hassan and the
cartel
terrorist cells all over the globe
we've never seen activity on this scale
before
[Music]
hopefully of each other the world is a
vampire
s
enemies above drill charge
you're gonna be okay
secure
[Applause]
[Music]
do not let them cross the border
[Music]
[Applause]
get ready James we have never seen a war
zone like this
[Music]
enemy healer
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
beta
and there we go Call of Duty fans the
trailer so nice we ran it twice it is
all there everything that makes this
franchise so so special we are
incredibly excited to be here today and
after that quite frankly how can you not
be my name is Miles Ross and I am so
excited to truly be here with a few of
the members of the infinity war team who
are bringing Modern Warfare 2 to life
guys we have 200 of our friends behind
us who are going to be playing and
streaming shortly but before that we
also have Stephanie snow director of
communications for Infinity Ward as well
as Joe Seeker over there Jeff Smith
multiplayer design directors here at
Infinity Ward guys first off
oh how are things evolving uh from
Modern Warfare 2019 I mean let's start
high level because there's a lot to get
through today guys you saw that trailer
let's go with the philosophy stuff let's
stay high level what went into the
creation of the game you said it
precisely there is so much this game has
just so much content it's got something
for everyone and it's really been the
result of three years of hard work
um at IW and our partners across all of
the Activision Studios and so much of
that work started with you guys at home
the community the fans our creators here
and that conversation and feedback from
2019 is really been a core piece of what
Modern Warfare 2 is and it's a dialogue
that we hope to uh you know continue
especially here today
well we've got so much in store with
this MP experience and um people like
Jeff and Joe here who I am honored to
work with and their experience on this
franchise we're in good hands
indeed okay so Jeff um well I don't know
where to start anymore uh let's uh let's
set up what Modern Warfare 2 multiplayer
is is all about uh let's stay high level
for now because there's a lot of details
friends juicy details sure I mean you
know when you come into making a sequel
it can be kind of tricky you know um
what do you keep from the previous game
uh what do you get rid of and where can
you add new things in and not mess up
this kind of nicely balanced ecosystem
that we had and so we came up with a few
uh methods one of them being player
behaviors and I say behaviors
um and not uh play Styles I think a lot
of people will say play Styles but that
can kind of change during a match but
behaviors are more ingrained in how
players play and we just put them into
three big groups we call them rushers
which are just aggressive players they
just want to find the action and go and
then we have Sentinels and these are
defensive players they want to just kind
of hold down a building maybe keep a
little OverWatch and then we have
stalkers which are reactive and they
kind of hang back and try to read the
field and read where spawns are and
really we just kind of use these as
filters to keep us honest with the
content that we're making so they're
making enough toys and equipment for
players to be successful playing our
game sounds like a lot of fun Stephanie
what are some of the new features coming
to multiplayer um some of the new stuff
that you're most excited to talk about
oh boy there are a ton of new features
to dive into with this game but um we
really pushed forward even the most
fundamental aspects of of what makes a
Call of Duty game with Modern Warfare 2
and it's been really amazing for me to
come on board this past year and see
these Innovations coming to life to hear
Jeff jump into you know breaking down
the 1v1 and personally for me uh water
or water I've seen the memes we love
water it's really hard to make in games
um but the Aquatic combat some of the
things you're able to do with vehicles
in the water I think that level of
immersion is really going to speak to
fans and has been something that I've
really enjoyed playing the last uh last
couple months aquatic combat Steph loves
to swim um Joe can we can we go into
some details about our water-based
adventures in MW2 yeah I mean last game
we really wanted to add water and we
knew we didn't have time right so in
verdance we froze the rivers and we made
the outskirts just to kill trigger in
this game as soon as we started Modern
Warfare 2 we leaned into water both
visually beautiful caustics there's
waves with white caps but we also the
gameplay side there's unique ballistics
underwater you only can use certain
weapons underwater your pistol is your
weapon underwater otherwise you can't
use your primary weapons but it's also a
nice cover or evasion mechanic if you're
getting shot at you can dive into the
water and as you get deeper it gets
murkier like the farther you are from
something you can't see it and so it's
been super fun for us to to dig into
water and really Flex on what water
could be in Call of Duty and you saw the
boats and the mine that floats and every
piece of equipment yeah I love it
filtered like how does it work through
water like we had to look at everything
in the game and say how does it work in
water what's the best version our
vehicles will just slowly submerge yeah
it really would instead of blinking out
yeah everything I have a lot of details
the behaviors are awesome oh my god well
I cannot wait to can't quite wait to
literally I dip my toes into those
Waters but guys let's not forget about
your ground in the air like I mean what
else is going to be coming to the
movement system Joe where we got well
you know last game we did Mount
um and we had slide and even though
we're a military shooter fluid movement
is super important to us so this game if
you saw in the trailer you can see here
on the video we have a new ledgehang
mechanic and that's essentially a high
mantle but instead of doing a high
mantle and throwing yourself up over
into combat you can now Peak if you have
a pistol you can pull that pistol out
and use that we also added a dive you
know last game we had the slide that
kept your gun up but we really wanted
players to have an option where if
they're getting shot at they don't know
where they're getting shot at they can
get down get out of fire but the other
really cool thing is it Dives just high
enough to let you get through a window
and so if you throw a grenade up into a
building Second Story often you'll see
players you know like rats leaving a
ship diving out through the windows and
uh it's just another it's another option
for players in in combat yeah and all of
these Dynamic movements mean you can
interact with vehicles specifically in a
very cool way I'm Gonna Save uh some of
that some of that gas for when we get to
war zone 2.0 but uh it's a really
exciting all right vehicle details to
come uh but now guys let's talk about
equipment obviously Call of Duty crazy
sandbox a lot of cool toys to play with
uh Joe what are some of the new Dynamite
new items that we're going to be
throwing at each other and equipping and
using in all sorts in the next game I
mean you saw some cool stuff from the
trailer you saw the drill charge you saw
the shark stick um one of the other
coins you saw is the inflatable decoy
and this is a mine that you can throw
out and it basically sits there and if
player gets close to it it auto deploys
and uh basically inflates like a car
airbag going off and it faces the person
that triggered it and so it's a great
distraction technique you can honestly
fire it off with a with a clacker if you
want to control when it goes off you can
throw it in water and here you just saw
the the DDOS we added all this equipment
into this game and the DDOS is our kind
of answer of like hey I'm going to
breach this building I want to go clean
house but I don't want to deal with all
the [ __ ] inside so I'm gonna hit the
DDOS boom it's going to shut down
everything I can move in yeah and clear
that room
um you saw the heartbeat sensor is back
it's got a new look but it also has a
battery as a balancing mechanic so you
can't use it indefinitely in war zone
um and there's I mean there's this is
the attack cam too yeah which to me is
um my personal favorite you can put out
a lot of them and even you can patch
into your teammates so you can it gets a
little crazy yeah kind of like a sticky
GoPro but will actually Mark your
enemies for um your team yeah so it's
it's I expect to see a lot of fun
there's so many so many toys and new
tools that were like we just want
players to get in and play with I think
there's something like 13 field upgrades
you know between Warzone and core MP and
it's it's pretty awesome oh my God until
they all get DDOS huh all this talk
about equipment uh it reminds me I mean
that's one element to look at now but
we've also got gunsmith brand new
gunsmith uh guys what can you tell me
about it and how will it change the way
that we you know level our weapons and
manage them I mean what's going on there
yeah so the new gunsmith allows players
to build out their weapons more smoothly
than ever before we we put out some
videos yesterday for the Intel drop I
hope people dig into those if you want a
better look at gunsmith 2.0 but we're
really looking at unprecedented
opportunities for weapon customization
in the new weapon platforming will
actually allow players to unlock
Universal attachments through cross
progression so we saw a lot of really
positive feedback from the community
yesterday this is sort of intended to
you know decrease the grind you're no
longer unlocking every single attachment
for every single weapon there will be
some shareitage attachments through
progression and I'm really excited to
see the streamers and the content
creators jump into this today I know I
know we all love the gun bench from 2019
so it's exciting
it does sound amazing uh so we've been
hearing a little bit about weapon
platforms and shared attachments is very
very cool stuff can you dive into those
details though Jeremy what can we expect
yeah I can add a little bit of what to
what Stephanie said um we had this
Vision last game with gunsmith and we
were like okay what if you could take an
assault rifle and you could make it in
SMG and that was our driving kind of
like motivator for that system and we
kind of hit that we you could you could
take it functionally through attachments
with the weapon named wooden change and
we couldn't change the receiver and
really that's the key thing this game is
you can go into gunsmith you can set up
an AK-47 assault rifle with a thermal
optic with a suppressor with a grip then
you say you know what I want to change
up the play style of this gun you can
swap out the receiver to the ak-74u make
it an SMG but you can keep that optic
that suppressor that grip they all come
with and to what Stephanie said we have
shared attachments Within These
platforms we have branching progression
you unlock those guns by playing with
other guns and then we have shared
attachments across all guns and it's all
to hit this vision of I'm building up an
arsenal of weapons and an arsenal of
attachments I'm sitting down on my gun
bench and I'm gonna make the perfect
weapon for me I think the made the
simplest way to think about it is is a
gun tree and each time uh you hit a
branch that's a receiver and they and
they grow out of that yeah yeah and
that's you know we wanted to ground that
in reality they were a functionally
receiver you know is is based in that
changing the weapon type and I think it
provides a really seamless experience
for players looking to build out the
perfect weapon for a multitude of play
Styles so you're going to be able to
jump into that platform and customize
however you want for you know
situational combat and um you're
actually going to see the fjx cinder
weapon vault in action today which is
the entirely unlocked Platform One the
M4 the mic for the weapon Vault
maintains its aesthetic properties
across all corresponding attachments so
we've heard you talk about the
frankenprint this is our answer it's an
extremely rare
um this is a huge you know project for
for our teams to design these but
um it is the Ultimate Weapon blueprint
and even better you can unlock the
entire Cinder weapon Vault with the
Vault edition of Modern Warfare 2.
Audible and beta available in the face
so we can rock with that thing all
weekend long okay so gunsmith looks
incredible uh okay I'm excited I cannot
wait to get into this one soon our
streamers are going to get into this one
soon as well but first guys we need to
hear about maps and modes we've got our
tools to play with equipment weapons
maps and modes though let's get into
this one uh let's get into uh the design
team you know the philosophy uh I
suppose behind building out Maps that's
what Jeff this is for you
um yeah you know right from the start we
knew we wanted to build a big another
big map not only for Battle Royale but
also for this other mode that we've been
working on for uh quite a long time
um I read about that on the internet ah
yes but you know when when you lay out
these big Maps it's kind of a collection
of all these little pois these points of
interest and um within each of these
we've really fine-tuned that they can
play core large-scale core modes like
ground war
um and a bunch of others really well
and so you know stepping back from this
large map and looking at how much open
World sandboxy gameplay that we have we
looked back at our 6v6 maps and really
tried to refine and make them a tighter
experience to contrast all this big
world
um kind of exploratory gameplay so the
maps uh for 6v6 in comparison to the
last game they're just um a little bit
more straightforward a little bit more
refined and I think fans will really
enjoy how quick they play that sounds a
lot of diversity in those Maps as well a
lot of visual variety some colorful maps
in there and they I think they feel
really clean guys you're moving me in
ways I didn't imagine to be moved today
excellent stuff
hi nice
we've got some of the maps that we are
going to be seeing in MW2 starting with
one uh we've got a real fun one here
guys this is one of the aforementioned
battle maps uh Team can you give me some
details on sarif Bay
so serif Bay is this little fishing Town
um in the south coast of our big map and
it we picked this because it has such a
great mix of gameplay uh it's right on a
harbor so we get to show off all our
boats and our new amphibious
um
APC
um and you know swimming as we've
already said
um but what you get inside the town is
this really intense Urban combat with
all these tight little Alleyways and uh
all this great rooftop combat and mixed
with our ledgehang you get these really
cool parkour Combat Action happening
yeah I love how you described the uh the
rooftops there on this map specifically
is like a separate ecosystem you can
kind of migrate that entire version go
up there and just hang out and fight
other snipers all right well that looks
fantastic Jeff okay so that's one of our
larger Maps uh what about some of the
6v6 maps I think we have uh we have some
footage of one of the new maps that
we're going to be seeing today uh named
Mercado Las Almas uh do you mind giving
us some details on this one sure
McCarter is um is a little Street Market
in a historic section in Mexico
um our story behind this is uh you know
the authorities have some Intel that
narcotics are being smuggled out of a
warehouse and they're going in trying to
find and seize them this map plays
really fast and a lot of action right
down that center lane
um the Mercado is a very dangerous uh
neck of the woods so watch out when
you're playing in the beta it plays fast
cannot wait really can't wait looks
fantastic and again uh interesting to
see uh you know how that ties into
campaigns and whatnot all sorts of fun
and games ahead of us looks amazing
battle maps core maps 6v6 all this looks
fantastic uh but let's go back to modes
so we've seen some maps uh what about
the modes being played on Battle maps so
we will have the return of ground War uh
but we've got a new large scale mode
that you've alluded to right let's talk
invasion
so invasion is it's a it's a big war map
it's like it's a big war TDM or we
affectionately call it the shipment of
ground war
um it's 20V 20 players but there's not
still 20 AI on each team uh AI are
coming in fast roping they're coming out
on medium Birds
um and it's this High action mode it's
super fun but it's also really chill the
announcer is not barking at you he's not
saying like hey get to be you know
they're taking C but you can kind of
play it how you want to play it you sit
up on a rooftop and snipe you can grab a
shotgun and go room clearing if you push
too far into the enemy's base AI will
come hunt you but we've also been really
conscious of where we put Ai and
multiplayer
um we didn't put Ai and kill streaks or
anything like that because we don't want
AI showing up in Search and Destroy we
don't want AI in Domination this mode
though however was built for AI and it's
a super fun mode can't wait for people
to try it kind of a funnier side you
know we took the name ground war from a
playlist in MW2 and that was just large
scale TDM and Dom and we kind of did the
Dom in the last game and now we're able
to add kind of the sandbox TDM and so
we're kind of completing the cycle of
that um that old playlist yeah this
large scale stuff looks amazing this
looks so so awesome man uh okay so what
about the new 6v6 modes just keep
dialing it in closer and closer Steph
what have we got yeah so we also have
two new 6v6 modes that you're going to
be seeing here displayed today
um and they will be in beta in prisoner
rescue and knockout prisoners okay let's
go into prison Rescue first joke
so prisoner rescue is an attack and
defend mode it's a round based mode The
Defenders have two prisoners they're
kind of spread out and they need to keep
hold of them the goal of the attackers
is get to those prisoners pick them up
and carry them to x-fill when you pick
them up you enter What's called the
wounded carry where they're up on your
shoulders and you can't use your primary
weapons instead you have to use a pistol
if you brought it or you're just stuck
with fists but the way that we give the
attackers an advantage once they grab
that prisoner is they get a radar sweep
for their team so they can call out
where the Defenders are
um and the objective icon over the
prisoner goes away as soon as they scoop
them up so now the Defenders have to
basically rotate back to the x-fill and
set up defensive positions and it's this
heart-pounding adrenaline pushing like
mode once you grab that prisoner and try
and get them out that Hero Run yeah
definitely uh you know s and big S D
energy in this mode
um which I resonates with me my time in
Esports so this is my personal favorite
of the new ones and also sort of the
Strategic revive lives that happen there
is a revive mechanic and so you are able
to to pick up your teammates and I've
seen some pretty pretty wild comebacks
in our play test so far
it was a lot of fun we got to play a
tiny but yesterday was amazing
incredibly fun and I know the community
is going to love diving into it over the
next week okay I can hardly believe that
there's actually a lot more content to
get through but there's one more thing I
have to bring up I have the honor of
officially announcing the third person
view is finally coming to Modern Warfare
2. what are the details behind this one
we've got a little teaser on stage from
patro but what are the details yeah you
saw a little hint of it in the trailer
too um it's it's been a pet project for
us right we've always wanted to do third
person and all while we're working on
all this other stuff we've been kind of
lifting up and for doing third person in
each mode and the cool thing is that
it's a modifier on our game right we can
just turn on third person in the beta
will be playing it in hardpoint but we
want to try it post launch in s d we
want to try it in VR
um and we have you know camera work the
camera collision's been reworked uh it
handles tight spaces there's a water
camera there's an interior camera you
can feel the weapon shake when you're
firing with it and it's just we've put a
lot of work into it and we're excited
for people to give it a try incredible I
can't wait to see what third person Cod
feels like in 20 22 sexy skins and
everything this is a lot of information
Steph like there's a ton here I tried to
warn you they were delivering a lot of
new features for you guys to try out
ahead of release
um and I said we were going to be bold
with this beta and we are but there's
even more to come at launch so this is
just a taste how is this just a taste
How can there be even more I mean we
haven't even got to Warzone okay okay so
what about uh this year's third mode so
I'm happy to say that special ops will
return as our third mode and we'll be
focused on two-player missions
asymmetrical in game design so think one
player on air support one player on the
ground and um I think the OG fans will
be really excited because we've looked
at you know some of the iconic Modern
Warfare missions like OverWatch and and
really tried to implement some of those
themes into the design so uh we'll be
talking more about special ops in the uh
in the months to come Steph you're
saying I should be be looking now for a
special ops partner sitting right next
to you yes you are indeed well I'm all
set then Stephanie I do believe we have
one more uh surprise for PlayStation
players out there what's that indeed we
do let's uh roll the clip
[Applause]
[Music]
empty-handed I was born
empty-handed
blade or bullet fist or both
spear stone for error these are merely
tools
I am the one to fear
take miles ISO fix your mic
PlayStation players will receive an
exclusive operator only Oni is a warrior
and gun for hire descended from
centuries-old Samurai Clan and torn
between country and family just like me
this is such an awesome looking operator
guys only is going to be playable on day
one for all who pre-order through the
PlayStation store plus he comes with a
high-level weapon blueprint playable in
multiplayer and Warzone 2.0 Steph badass
Oni is awesome I myself am a PlayStation
player and so I will be locking becoming
Oni main day one for this game um and
it's been really awesome to see our
narrative team building out his lore
really bringing this operator to life
with the creation of his backstory his
motives and I think um the art team
absolutely crushed it with the skin he
is so so cool looking all right so we
keep talking about all the uh the things
that you know we have to look forward to
but um we are missing quite a big one
here we're missing the start of the beta
so for anyone who wants to get an early
first hand look at Modern Warfare 2 and
trust me you definitely want to to it is
immediately available around the corner
for PlayStation players who pre-order
any version early access to the open
Beta starts tomorrow so make sure you
are preloading right now now also check
out your screens since here's exactly
when you can play the beta on your
platform of choice but don't forget
friends it's also definitely worth
noting that if you pre-order The Vault
edition of Modern Warfare 2 you get to
use the red team one for one operator
pack and the fjx cinder weapon vault in
the beta in addition to being able to
earn in-game rewards for playing all
sorts of cool swag and don't forget that
if you digitally pre-order model Fair 2
you also get up to a week early of
campaign access so it campaign a week
early alright folks I hope you enjoyed
that first look at Modern Warfare 2's
multiplayer don't forget you're going to
get to see it live and in action in a
few short minutes with our crazy set of
streamers here 200 plus here and Raider
Rock and Roll But first
we'll be right back to show off the
world premiere of Warzone 2.0 don't go
anywhere
Call of Duty next brought to you by
Mountain Dew official drink of Modern
Warfare 2.
Little Caesars a proud partner of Call
of Duty next and Modern Warfare 2.
hyperx official peripheral partner of
Call of Duty
play like a pro on the big screen with
144hz vrr and AMD freesync now on TCL 6
Series TVs
Prime gaming visit
gaming.amazon.com today and start
claiming your free content
200 creators here on site marching down
the Green carpet with one mission in
mind to be the first players to play
Call of Duty Modern Warfare 2.
and there is so much in this game there
is almost too much this is like one of
those days where I enter and my hopes
are so high and what are you looking
forward to most when it comes to war
zone two prisoner rescue I'm looking
forward to using that inflatable Soldier
decoy to mess a lot of players kill
streaks I think I'm honestly here just
to learn as much as I can to prep for
alternative optic because those guys are
very old now maybe some OG Maps coming
back a map that everyone can play
honestly give me a broken shotgun
what's your favorite game mode and
Mountain Dew flavor combo Search and
Destroy code red cop to the flag code
red if I'm going hard with the boys on a
long night at s d and I'm trying to get
some nasty in-game comms I'm drinking
Baja Blast all night terminal or high
rise easy terminal oh terminal most
people have terminal Nostalgia terminal
terminal 100 I just replayed that
recently and I realized that spawn
trapping is horrendous easy strike high
rise high-rise terminal what's your
favorite flavor of Mountain Dew I've
grown up on code red so it's still code
red for me honestly I like the basic one
just Mountain Dew itself dang I was
gonna pick code red too can I get a
second one all right Baja Blast
starting October 17th unlock dual Double
XP Cod points and also an exclusive
Mountain Dew skin in Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 when you buy specifically
marked Mountain Dew you think you're
getting me as you kidding me
[Music]
welcome back to Call of Duty next the
Mountain Dew Green carpet God damn it
was beautiful a lot of fun people out
there everyone having a good time and uh
some incredibly well-dressed people out
there and some definitely not sweaty
t-shirts are bound there we go welcome
back to Call of Duty next friends we
promised it was coming up and now the
wait is over it is time to talk about
Warzone 2.0 we got a glimpse of some
Warzone 2.0 in the multiplayer
multiplayer reveal trailer earlier today
and it does look awesome however we need
some true experts to help out back at
the desk here we have got Stephanie
Snowden Josie got his joining us but of
course welcome Draco horror game
director at Infinity Ward Joe how we
feeling we're ready to party here I mean
this is uh this is a lot we need to know
everything Warzone 2.0 Stephanie the
world cannot wait it it feels crazy for
me to be up here revealing war zone 2.0
I ended up at IW as a fan of the game
and so this moment is absolutely bananas
for me but Warzone 2.0 is everything
that we loved about the original war
zone right where it it's based on the
same experience that we all had that
that fund all of those moments and it's
a it's a return to Shared Tech Across
the Universe for Modern Warfare 2 and
that's going to create a really
streamlined player experience and um I
think the key innovations that we
discussed for multiplayer those all
exist across Warzone 2.0 as well so
we're we're bringing it back it's all
connected it's the same world and I
think the players are gonna love it oh
my good God real excited about this one
I got again there's a lot in this one
Jack uh where do we go from here so MW2
and wasn't to have been developed side
by side since the beginning right since
we started down this road and they're
part of the same universe like Stephanie
said they share the same mechanics the
same weaponry and even more than that
but the centerpiece of all this of
course is the new map that we've been
working on since 2020 with teams across
the group it brings together our
philosophies on map design it brings
together new technologies in order to do
it and lots and lots of artwork to make
it happen and we've learned so much from
players experiencing verdansk and
playing in verdanska the first three
years of Warzone and we're really
excited then for them to land in
al-mazra with their squad there's a wide
variety of points of interest for
players to explore in this map and we're
really looking forward to seeing
everybody in there oh here we go a brand
new map to explore and Traverse I cannot
wait Stephanie let's take a look that's
right miles welcome
to al-mazra this is our new map for
Warzone 2.0 it is a really interesting
mix of geography it is expansive desert
settings with a mix of industrial areas
towns a city and of course water it
looks way better on this screen than it
did on Twitter
but you're gonna find a lot of really
cool elevation Rocky Peaks cave
Subterranean spaces this map is
beautiful and it's actually the biggest
BR map that we've ever made and I am so
excited for all of our streamers here to
jump into almazwell later today it's
huge look at the size of that thing uh
okay so that was a big picture and it's
a great way to see it from a sort of
top-down layout but uh let's take a
better look at some of these points of
interest
so when we set out to create these
spaces the team Works to make it feel
like a real space right so that there's
infrastructure in between all the
different what we call points of
interest along the map and if you're
paying attention you might even see a
few that seem pretty familiar out there
as well
um and so as the team Works through
these they're trying to find some
variety on each point of interest to
make them then something that the
players will want to drop in and get the
particularity of that single point of
interest and find the place that they
want to drop and where they want to play
whether it be a high elevation
Observatory at the center of the map
whether it be the big city that's up the
top right and whether they want to
explore that or whether they want to
work in some of our pois where we have
water intersecting with with geometry
here so we have in this one that looks
familiar
and there's a river system that goes
through all of this so you'll be able to
catch in a bird and drive between the
different pois and here's one of our
favorites sour Village which is that's
my favorite collectively called sunken
town I mean I love to swim so you find
me there absolutely um I'm curious what
you guys think Jack and Joe on what the
hot Drop will be today right we've been
talking about this last couple days this
is our first time seeing other people
who are not us play Warzone 2.0 and so
I'm just very curious where you think
everyone's gonna immediately drop today
I I think some people are going to drop
to Observatory just to go go back to
home you know they're coming home it's
always nice you're moving through the
map and you kind of hit a spot and
you're like wait uh I've been here
about these flashbacks oh yeah there's a
lot of nuggets in there for some old uh
yeah I'll say Corey I think that's gonna
pop off I think people will land around
the edge so they stay in as long as
possible in this match but we have some
news for our edge of the map players
coming up all right guys well the map
looks absolutely gorgeous and I can't
wait to watch our streams here uh drop
in early in an alpha build later on
today okay so moving on to the gameplay
uh we've got this beautiful space to
play in how do all of these multiplayer
elements we've talked about a little bit
earlier how do they fit into Warzone 200
know I mean the super simple answer is
all the stuff we talked about in
multiplayer the stuff you saw in the
multiplayer trailer that's all in
Warzone right it's all integrated so
that tactical camera Works in Warzone
that Decoy mind works in lawyers on like
it's all that's been built from the
ground up for both
the slide the dive the water like
more swimming yeah
this is a great taste of some of the
Water Combat I can't wait to go full
Captain Miller you know Apocalypse Now
coming out of the war and knife in
people I mean this just looks yeah the
rendering team made some work so you
come out you're looking all wet yeah you
see Acoustics on the bottom yep I I'm
not even sure what caustics are I have
no idea but it sounds great and it looks
incredible you can see the armored
Patrol boat coming by there with its two
turrets it's there's some cool stuff so
I'm glad you brought up vehicles uh so
have you touched on vehicles a little
bit earlier what can we talk about uh
you know we see boats we've seen tanks
we've seen all sorts of track what we
got so we've implemented a new physics
and handling model for the vehicles so
some vehicles are heavier some will
slide more have more traction or less
traction and as you're driving them
around and you're encountering them and
other squads are playing with them you
can choose to shoot off the tires to
kind of impact their handling you can
have them they react to explosive
differently based on their weight so if
you're in a heavy armored 4x4 and get
hit by an RPG it's going to kind of
Bounce a little bit but not quite take
the hit as a small sedan you can also
choose with your squad to be rolling
into a POI and somebody jumps out on the
roof somebody leans out the window and
suddenly you got yourself a lot of
Firepower driving into the POI of course
that vehicle needs to survive for quite
some time in the map before keep using
it to go from point to point and
vehicles will run out of gas or at least
most of them will will run out of gas
and then you can bring them to a gas
station to fill them up if your tire has
been blown up you can get out and repair
it or you can bring it to a gas station
to get repaired as well and of course
we've got you know water Vehicles we've
got a small boat we've got the boat that
Joe mentioned with the target at the
back so you can have that little moment
cruising up the river with your whole
Squad ready to rumble so yeah there is
so much love that's gone into these
videos forgot the coolest vehicle the
coolest vehicle massive helicopter that
you can fly around that's a big platform
with three doors and people player you
can move a whole Squad through the map
what wreak havoc it is so cool oh my God
I mean the fact that you can lean out of
the window you know yeah grab your
teammates Pile in a vehicle actually you
know engage in battle from the window
leaning out unless somebody blew off
your door that one that does complicate
things get PTSD from uh Joe killing me
many times in our play test well I hope
the gas prices in our Mars are okay I
thought there's a lot going on in
Warzone 2.0 and uh my head is quite
frankly spinning uh what are the massive
changes um have we got in store because
it feels like there's a there's so much
has changed is it still a gulag do we
still have circles is it still gas I
know there are guns but do we shoot them
what's happening
or do you want to jump into first oh
except we've made some pretty sweeping
changes I think to the high level
components of of Warzone 2.0 to continue
providing players with both a dynamic
and rewarding VR experience but Warzone
2.0 you're going to hear it over and
over again today it's about fun this is
about playing with your friends having
fun you know Friends new and old maybe
you're making them in game and I think
one particular feature that I cannot
wait to see the streamers engage with
will be our prox chat yes so it's coming
it will be in war zone and I I there is
going to be some amazing clips
but um
I think Joe can uh tell us a little bit
more about looting and me and more is
that 2.0 I'm listening to them yes
um you know in looting in Warzone 2.0 we
still have the humming crates you know
you can still travel around and listen
for those who still have the loose Loot
on the ground but we wanted to add a
layer of learnability and and logic to
our looting right so if you if you're
outside if you're a little kid you fall
down you hurt your knee and your mom's
gonna go inside go to the medicine
cabinet and get you something to a
Band-Aid Neosporin whatever so that's
our looting if you're you need health
items you can hit a bathroom in a
building and there'll be a medicine
cabinet you can open it up
um if you want to get Loadout items
um there are these hidden caches
throughout in between the pois that are
in ground and you can memorize where
they are because they're always there so
you can kind of start to develop these
paths through the map of how you Loot
and there's this logic applied to
looting you know you can find toolboxes
that'll have grenades and things in them
um and you find these other crates that
are kind of like it's as if the the
military that occupied this space came
through and dropped off military items
those crates are always there so you can
always have this reliable layer to
looting incredible this sounds really
exciting we go on a road trip through
our mother and quite literally like have
a route we plan hit the gas station yeah
yeah pick up snacks pick up ammo and all
sorts Okay cool so what about Circle
mechanics I mean this is obviously a
huge component of br's joke yeah I mean
the circle's been a staple of br's it's
been really hard to move away from it so
we kind of talked about what could we do
to mix things up with the circle so
we've got this new mechanic where the
circle can actually split almost like a
cell split into two three or even four
circles and then those circles kind of
close down and what it does is it
segregates teams and you have these
micro battles in those circles and a
certain point you're like okay we've
cleared out our Circle we think we're
good and then those circles merge they
come back together and you know you have
this very directed Fight of like as the
circle's moving you're like gearing up
in buildings you're like here we go it's
about to kick off and as soon as those
circles hit you have that final fight so
it's another kind of like twist in the
gameplay that we feel like is a cool
world event that would happen like the
circle splitting we need to do X crazy
get in the car we're going now go all
right so
bottom circles playing uh what about the
gulag is that still around I mean
there's so much change man I mean I'm
ready for it but sure what do we got the
gulag you know we've been experimenting
with we've tried some crazy things
but the the current version of the gulag
that we we have running right now we're
exciting people to play is you're not in
there alone you actually have this
temporary alliance with another opponent
in the map and you guys you have to work
together and if you can defeat the other
team you can get out and after that you
guys are enemies again but for that
moment it's like all right we need each
other let's do this you use the
proximity chat to talk to each other and
the other thing we've been playing
around with is you may see a little bit
of an AI presence in the gulag so you
kind of you have to be on your toes like
you're working with an enemy there might
be an AI here you're picking up weapons
um we're excited for people to try it
yeah we're gonna get feedback today too
and and like Joe said we've been through
some pretty wild iterations of the gulag
which I will not reveal here but uh
there's there's a lot in store
if there certainly is a lot in store um
Jack I have heard of A New Concept
coming to Warzone 2.0 called strongholds
that will include AI that may impact how
players get their weapons Etc uh can you
clue me into what that's all about and
if it's even true absolutely um so
strongholds are reinforced buildings
that they are that the AI is occupying
inside Al mazura in BR and the players
can choose whether or not they want to
engage with them and assault them to get
core rewards including free Loadout
items which is one of the new ways that
we're adding for players to get their
hands on their best weapon we've worked
really hard to bring AI into at scale
into war zone two and you're going to
encounter them in multiple modes in
different way in BR specifically they're
in these strongholds and if you get to a
stronghold you can find the location of
a black side which is going to have even
cooler stuff in it and you can fight
your way from one to the next but in
other modes you're going to find the AI
occupying large portions of the map and
just kind of protecting different pois
in different ways unreal Okay so we've
all heard the rumors that Warzone 2.0 is
going to have some very very interesting
new modes uh would you care to confirm
or deny Stephanie Snowden it's finally
time I have read about some new modes on
the internet recently but one of the
most exciting things about Warzone 2.0
is confirmation that an all-new sandbox
experience is coming at launch I am
happy to announce DMZ Call of Duty's
extraction mode will arrive with Warzone
2.0 AT launch later this year I played
DMZ for the very first time on my first
day at IW and to this day playing it
non-stop the possibilities with this
game mode below my mind so DMZ I can
also confirm the DMZ is real We're not
gonna go into depth on it today because
we do have to keep some stuff in reserve
what I can tell you though is we've
created a rich sandbox where you can
Define your own win condition you
infiltrate al-mazra you accomplish your
goals and then you decide to extract
when the time is right it is played
across the whole map and the AI is
occupying large sections of the map and
they are lethal opponents and they do
command your respect you have to watch
out for them you have to work with your
team they Patrol areas they occupy
strongholds and they'll reinforce based
on players actions
and then on top of all this you can
choose which Mission you want to
accomplish or you can chase after a
variety of activities in the world and
you can play this differently depending
on your play style you can go loud like
I always do you can go quiet or you can
hunt other players or avoid them
entirely or you could just decide hey
I'm going to explore the secrets of Al
mazara and see what's there loot up
x-fill it's it's totally up to player
choice there and um I'm really excited
about the full scale of what we're
delivering for this chapter and we want
players to have an amazing experience in
war zone 2.0 we've been listening to the
conversations in the community
specifically around small Maps Ricochet
anti-cheat ranked play and Beyond and
trust me although we're touching on some
of the core updates to the overall
Warzone 2.0 experience today and mostly
focusing on BR there will be more news
to share over the coming months this is
only the beginning for Warzone 2.0 okay
I need Warzone 2.0 and DMZ in my life
ASAP Stephanie Wynn Warzone 2.0 will be
free to play for everyone on November
16th with the start of season one across
Modern Warfare 2 mark your calendars
that's about two weeks uh after
after Modern Warfare 2 launches
um and we had a 125 million players in
the original war zone and I cannot wait
to see all of you and hopefully more of
you in almazara for this experience
and you will have a chance to see a
wasn't two Battle Royale Alpha play test
happening right here behind us very very
soon yeah the streamers are hot to trot
they're raring to go uh we will see all
of you in an almaza November 16th but
don't go anywhere just yet stick around
because when we come back you'll see
just what Warzone looks like when it's
built up from the ground for mobile
you're not going to want to miss this I
promise then after that we have live
gameplay coming at us with all of our
friends set up across the each and every
Modern Warfare 2 multiplayer we've got
Warzone 2.0 without Royale we've got
Warzone mobile it's all Happening Here
ladies and gentlemen don't go too far
Call of Duty next brought to you by the
GMC Hummer EV pickup the world's first
all-electric Super Truck
Intel built for the next generation of
gaming
Squad up sudo with Xfinity rewards get
early access to Modern Warfare 2's open
beta
Jack Links Squad up with Sasquatch Jack
Links is good with it
Eureka ergonomic leading designer in
gaming furniture and proud partner of
Modern Warfare 2.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
what a jam-packed day we've had here so
far we got war zone 2.0 and Modern
Warfare 2 already good to go but finally
we're hitting something new here coming
into Mobile we got Warzone mobile 2 here
for you it's me beef mommy and I
couldn't be more excited to be here with
none other than Chris Plummer and Chris
what do you have for us today
that's right today we are proud to
introduce Call of Duty Warzone mobile
this is the real thing and it's on your
phone for the first time ever you can
drop in the Call of Duty war zone from
wherever life takes you let me quickly
point out the gameplay you're seeing
today is still Alpha so it's only going
to get better
and for Warzone fans you will recognize
this drop sequence right away I mean
honestly it just gives me so much
Nostalgia but wait a minute Chris is
that the legendary verdesk
you know this is where Warzone gameplay
was born and we're bringing the
legendary for dance map to mobile for
the very first time from its Hallmark
Vistas
and these dense urban areas they're just
so much fun to play in Wide Open Fields
ready for battle an intimate Close
Quarters combat environments there's so
much Variety in verdance it's famous for
good reason teaming with fan favorite
locations like Boneyard
and Superstore
even TV station well I'm getting classic
Call of Duty war zone flashbacks here
can you tell us more about the gameplay
or you know what maybe just give me your
phone real quick maybe I can see for
myself no you know the team has a
passion for delivering the most
authentic Call of Duty experience
possible for mobile devices from the way
you aim and move to the weapon handling
and the control responsiveness all these
critical little details combined to make
Call of Duty Warzone mobile feel Best in
Class we've made sure that the physics
the feedback the sights and sounds all
those essential little touches are
smooth and accurate it's about creating
an experience that's so true to form you
can imagine feeling that dirt
compressing under the soles of your
boots with every move or imagine those
tiny shock waves of recoil moving
through your entire body with every shot
and Warzone mobile these are the kind of
details that we care about that make the
combat feel airtight and authentic that
makes me really emotional Chris and you
know it sounds like everyone's paying
attention to detail and it's finally
paying off now when I think of Call of
Duty Warzone I think about strategy
absolutely there's a lot more going on
than pure gun plays for example when
you're out there exploring a map and
evading the gas Circle collapse you can
try to sneak up on another player and
pull off the finishing move it's like
ultimate bragging rights and if you're
feeling more strategic you and your
squad taking complete contracts use that
cash and buy stations there's a ton of
variety there
including lots of different abilities
like bring it back or falling Squad made
now that contract economy it adds a ton
of depth and strategy through risk and
reward I really like that you brought
that up because if you're talking about
risk and reward I think about the kill
streaks I think about the gulag are they
going to be there too
yes everything you come to expect from
Warzone is going to be there especially
kill streaks this means you can deploy
your big stick of choice like you know a
Precision airstrike you might be able to
wipe out an entire Squad with it so not
so fortunate for them but they're not
necessarily down for the count either
because we have the gulag so here
players can fight for a second chance
so when you go down you get the fight
101 with another down player and you can
earn your way back into battle
this is how Warzone mobile plays out on
a truly massive scale unlike anything
we've ever played on mobile before
this reason we're pushing way past the
envelope on high player counts to make
sure each match is jam-packed with our
signature style of combat so we are
supporting up to 120 Live players in the
single match wait wait wait hold on did
you just say
120 players or do you mean Bots because
it seems like in Battle Royale games on
mobile they're usually loaded up with
boring Bots
well we believe it's critically
important and a lot more fun to play
with real live Human opponents and
that's our Focus so for anyone who's
tired of playing with nothing but Bots
we hear you we're talking up to 120 real
players ready to hunt you down with real
human skill and real human emotions that
is Call of Duty Warzone mobile and we
and we're you in the crowd everyone's
excited and absolutely it is huge and I
don't think there's a game on mobile
that can top that in terms of Real
Player count of course but how are you
able to even pull that off
we can support Real Player accounts that
dramatically higher scale than we've
ever seen in other Battle Royale games
on mobile because Warzone mobile is
running on Advanced unified Call of Duty
technology this is the same shared Tech
behind the console and PC versions of
Warzone 2.0 it gives us a ton of
advantages like these incredibly High
player counts authentic Call of Duty
combat and gameplay systems and it opens
the door to a much more connected
experience across all platforms
So when you say more connected does that
mean that Warzone mobile will share
content and features that will be in the
console and PC version of Warzone 2.0
exactly delivering a deeply connected
experience it's been a strategic pillar
from the beginning of development now we
know that your time is precious and your
investment in plane is now recognized
across Modern Warfare 2 war zone 2.0 and
Warzone mobile so wherever you're
playing Call of Duty it is time well
spent including on mobile even your
friends list and chat or shared across
platforms so you can stay in touch with
your friends whether they're playing on
Console or PC or mobile wherever they
choose to play I mean that is so
exciting I totally get that now one of
the coolest benefits of having this kind
of connectivity is that Call of Duty
Warzone mobile is loaded up with the
same authentic Call of Duty weapons and
operators you'll recognize for Modern
Warfare 2 and Warzone 2.0 and whatever
you get from the battle pass you will
see it on Console or PC it'll also be
there on your mobile device too and the
other way around works as well
I really love to hear that and as a
matter of fact
some of the same weapons and operators
being shown earlier today in Call of
Duty war zone 2.0 are you aiming to make
it exactly the same on all platforms you
know that's a great question the team's
incredibly excited about how deeply
connected and authentic experiences and
Call of Duty Warzone mobile and will
continue to adapt the best content and
features and Innovations create across
the franchise but at the same time we
recognize that mobile is a very unique
platform mobile has its own flavor
advantages and player expectations
sounds like the game will be tied into
the Call of Duty franchise pretty nicely
and will there be mobile specific events
or content that is unique to Warzone
mobile
yes Above All Else the team is committed
to ensuring Warzone mobile is a
world-class mobile first experience
right down to its core
controls are a huge part of it it just
needs to feel natural on the device
intuitive and you know native to the
platform
a lot of it comes down to tuning and
this is why we are supporting
synchronous cross play between IOS and
Android platforms exclusively on mobile
and we're avoiding the imbalance that
comes with cross planes between mobile
devices and consoles or mobile to PC
this allows our teams to deliver the
best possible mobile gameplay experience
with a unified feel and by doing this we
don't need to compromise the tuning for
any platform this ensures a Level
Playing Field and more fun for everyone
now keeping those controls balanced for
all player types it's super important so
whether you're the hardest of hardcore
mobile Pros or maybe you're a console
first player that's sneaking in an extra
master in your lunch break even brand
new players to the franchise you need a
little help getting into the flow of the
game we are committed to providing the
most robust control options anywhere for
a pick up and play experience that's
accessible to all of our players I love
that accessibility and that means all my
friends can get in on the action for a
change but how do they sign up well it's
time to get your mobile devices ready
because I'm super excited to announce
that starting right now you can
pre-register for your free download in
the Google Play Store
signing up means that you can be among
the first to play when a game launches
next year we look forward to seeing
everyone in Call of Duty Warzone mobile
with that being said hey we got a Ferg
on the horn and I think he's literally
the first one to pre-reg Ferg
hey guys Berg here and I am thrilled to
be one of the first to pre-register for
Call of Duty Warzone mobile and now you
can too scan the QR code at the bottom
of the screen to be among the first to
draw tell your friends because the more
pre-registrations we drive the more
rewards we can earn like special weapons
vinyls and ambulance plus if we reach
the top Milestone of 25 million
pre-registers we're going to unlock a
super cool secret reward you're not
going to want to miss what are you
waiting for sign up using the QR code
below
we are back it's miles here joined by
Maven alligator name of Studio oh guys
the adults have left us alone on the
desk and now it's our time to have some
fun I don't know about you guys but uh
okay it's been a pretty little day so
far yeah where do we even start I mean
dude mobile bro it's a new era of Call
of Duty Mouse I've been addicted to Call
of Duty for over a decade you're telling
me I could be in the airport playing
Warzone now packing for dance that's lit
also El mazara looks absolutely
incredible oh it's insane all right
there's no shortage of crazy stuff come
my way Ali I mean lay it on me
multiplayer for wolves for Modern
Warfare two insane it's incredible we
actually got to load up with some of the
Players yesterday you know a little bit
of a pre-test and loading into gunsmith
2.0 was actually so aesthetically
pleasing and I think everybody at home
once they also get their hands on it
they're going to love it just as much as
we do here truly uh Maven my good my
good friend you've played more Warzone
than most people on the Northern
eight hours a day for years it feels
like it just seems fresh man the map
like everything about it triple circles
uh the Water the boats I mean I was like
kind of the proximity in my king for a
while there but they see some other
vehicles trying to blow them up instead
of booby traps and now you're telling me
I could do them and not only land but
also the sea I'm with it it's gonna be
something man we really have seen a lot
so far today yeah we've seen what was on
mobile course multiplayer there and a
bit of War Zone 2.0 cannot wait but guys
it's time to get to business let's now
get into the command center
this is it welcome ladies and gentlemen
to the command center presented by
Xfinity rewards we're going to be
rolling the show through all day today
Xfinity customers they can start playing
Modern Warfare 2 sooner with Xfinity
rewards visit xfinity.com rewards to get
your code for early access to the open
Beta it's free and it's easy to join
guys I mean every time I sit down I take
a breather I'm like there's so much but
first and foremost before we get into
this one so many streamers here we need
to give you a big shout out to Intel
who's powering all of the streaming PCS
here today massive shout out to those
guys Clint there are two PCS on every
desk explained I I couldn't believe it
cloaksi is here like the fact that he
actually made the trip out I figured
they have to have something special the
fact you have a dedicated PC to the
streaming side and to the gameplay side
and it's set up for this many people
Intel thank you ridiculous incredible
it's ridiculous uh we're actually almost
ready to get into the gameplay guys I
mean Ali you teased it a little yeah you
played a little we put a little yeah we
played a time whatever accent too dude
I'm getting mocked here
my bloody desk we uh we got to play a
tiny bit yesterday yeah it's pretty fun
but uh now we get to watch 200 streamers
uh some of the world's finest quite
literally from almost every part of the
planet coming together here in this
crazy top secret location what can we
expect It's Gonna Get Loud it's going to
get incredibly loud yesterday it was
loud and I believe like not even
everybody had shown up yet so now that
we have a full building of all of these
creators all of these PCS I'm expecting
people to get up and start screaming
miles it's going to be insane courage
from like headphones on he can be heard
from space oh oh yeah no 100 like Bobby
Poff he's not a sub train or something
Lord knows what that's gonna sound like
but boys
dingy here as well but like I just I I
think this is a testament to how pumped
up everyone gets about Call of Duty
every year like the fact that there are
this many big name streamers in
attendance we're gonna see some
incredible gameplay go through the
various modes I mean this is going to be
uh there's no real treat it really is I
mean you've been around a long time in
the Call of Duty World in this venue
right now and we've got streamers and
players from from you know but all
across North America or you know South
America we've got to play all over
Europe Japan Australia
players everywhere what is how do you
describe the vibe in the room right now
I mean it's just incredible there's a
bunch of homies who love Call of Duty
all in one room getting ready to grind
you know I was talking to them earlier I
was walking around doing around saying
what up to everybody they're going hard
right like I was talking to some of the
wars on guys repos he's like I'm here to
fry Zuma's ready to go so I'm interested
to see them with these new weapons and
the gunsmith what they come up with
especially our new game I was like
prisoner it's gonna be lit listen as
much as they're here for their love of
Call of Duty they're also here because
they want that Banger clip like
everybody wants it you you know you're
trying to go out and fry some of these
big names get a clip out on social your
YouTube whatever it's going to be so
yeah I'm sure people are going hard in
the paint or falling to their desks at
their temp I'm sure we're gonna have a
couple of those we'll go a little bit of
that later on I think we're actually
ready to hop into gameplay Dr Lupo are
one of our first here and uh he's
already down and out but we are playing
I believe this is hardpoint and mercado
nameless yeah you know I didn't get to
play this map yesterday but one thing I
want to point out what this game is it's
a lot more vibrant than some of the
Empire games that we've had in the past
there's so many more colors and that's
something that I always enjoy especially
with Call of Duties is when it's more
vibrant and you can see more on the map
I think sometimes you go dab to Dev and
yeah it's like you have like your more
realism like your Grays and brows some
will have a little bit more color but
this map in particular yeah the second
we saw like the fly through this yeah it
just looks gorgeous it really does and
I'm not that I had any concerns about
the visual side of it because they're
knocking out of the park every year but
it's just aesthetically pleasing it is
it's very very pretty that is of course
Dr Lupo uh you can you can watch him
stream this live every single member of
of the of the crazy I don't have a name
for it the stream pit here uh Todd next
all of them live on their own channels
and unreal man yeah it's unreal I mean
all these guys are going hard you can
see he's locked in uh talk a little bit
about the game and the movement though
when I first hopped on yesterday the
movement felt so much different than
Call of Duty's in the past you know it's
not that slide cancel you gotta complete
your slide the dive mechanic it plays
out so much different uh when you're
going into a gunfight you can dive out
of a window miles it was a lot of fun we
were getting into the mix were you ready
to get into the mix I also I'm gonna
tell this now on air in front of God
knows how many people but last night
ninja wasn't in the venue I played on
his setup I wasn't quite here yet and I
found there is an in-game like whisper
feature so I was sending messages to
other creators as ninja talking
horrendous like horrendous horrendous
trash talk very good-natured friends of
mine you know but I'd be kind of weird
to get that from Ninja right yeah did
you know you did that he has no idea
I walked past him today and I was like
good morning dude how you doing he's
like hey man
he's not a word I actually I actually
gone to a game against you specifically
I was I was on I believe Nate shots to
me account I don't believe that he's
here today but I was I was getting
disrespectful with some people on the
map and I believe that you were in my
last game and the second I killed you
you left
that wasn't me that was Ninja a quitter
miles that was Ninja over to courage now
he's having a a good time
and uh you know
listen he is as much as he's like a fun
good loving like everyone takes a Jack
and it's just like this great nature guy
he is one of those competitive human
beings like he gets pissed bro
passion raging passion and look it's me
on the right hand side
and I will have to say with to test to
what ant was talking about earlier about
the game mechanics something else that I
noticed that I don't feel like I fell in
other Call of Duty games is how kind of
realistic the movement with your gun is
if that makes sense like there's
obviously always going to be recoil your
attachment's always going to mess with
that but when you peek corners and stuff
the way your gun moves with you is very
very realistic and I think that's going
to be something a lot of these players
are going to notice and have to get used
to very quickly you saw a taste there of
uh when you're spectating a player you
get that kind of like over the shoulder
like tactical camera view and it just
adds this insane level of like it's like
realism but like it just looks so
exciting and watching when you're you
know enjoying like you know maybe seeing
your teammates player whatnot it just
looks so cool it's a nice new feature
here in the game uh and sorry this is
the new knockout mode I don't think you
you might know I haven't seen this one
I mostly I was watching some of the guys
play I just wanted to kind of live react
and enjoy it yeah there's so much new
stuff like I've just been looking
forward to seeing what's going to be on
the table but let's see if Jack can
actually stepped up this time no no not
gonna happen just getting destroyed I'm
sorry Superior positioning Jack you are
awful
oh is that too hard
okay he's doing the classics
it was something else there was
something else it wasn't it wasn't oh
changes to gunsmith and now having five
attachments and not having your foot is
yeah so you know I saw the Romans on
Twitter and stuff like that uh I think
it's amazing though I mean when we
jumped into modern warfare in 2019 when
they introduced the gunsmith there was a
lot to take in but now everybody's
familiar with it especially grinding
Warzone switching up those attachments
and it's just a better version it's just
a better version of that right like the
gun moves around with you as you're in
there you can switch out all these
different attachments and you know for
the classic weapon that you have like
you can change it up turn uh M4 into an
SMG that's that's really cool oh this is
that was nearly a snap it was nearly six
one of the uh you know the all-time
greats and the competitive one of the
maybe maybe I'm not the yeah yeah I
don't know why I said it that way yeah
they're like the all the time yes he's
the greatest but there we go swag now
getting involved as well and to your
point of analy about gunsmith I mean
it's at this point in time I was just
quite hard to recognize but that is a
part of the M4 platform right now that's
his primary weapon yeah I mean it's
awesome like you can switch it up like
you can make it into a sniper I think is
what I heard well right so it's going to
be crazy even with the AK turning 70 for
you just make some crazy different
loadouts you know some of these guys Jay
God's gonna have so much fun with that
nine and a half hour long attachment
video from Jay God oh God you know he's
so excited about that and I want to
actually I want to talk about the map
Aesthetics for a moment and like the
layout is the rooftops like the new
ledge how you can jump and then you can
hang off the side of the ledge that's a
new thing that you can add into this
game you can jump from rooftop to
Rooftop and like you can jump further
than you think and I found that out very
quickly like I would get to an edge at
rooftop and I was like I wonder if I can
make this jump
you can make the jump you can make it
across like the map if there's tall
buildings you can make it across the map
without ever having a touch in the
ground and I think for snipers that is
going to be their absolute playground
speaking of snipers homage now who's
having a great time here uh I mean we've
seen a lot Clint of the weapons so far
but surely a sniper well I I heard pamaj
too like I I stepped up I think it's
when he was first walking and he was
welcome and then rational to people and
he was like I'm going hard bro oh yeah
he's like I'm going hard I
can get my head
and this is uh this knockout game is not
going very well for the red team right
now but Marshall's team obviously
winning this one again secure the grab
the money back hold on to that bad boy
oh I forgot friends here at COD next
it's all going on mobile gaming we've
got all of it going on really a
celebration of everything that is Call
of Duty and even courage and he may have
just sworn do you see the the glove or
something yeah they're professionals
true professionals wait do I I probably
need to get this all right I've been
playing some cod mobile Diablo immortal
like I've been riding more mobile games
I have my iPad and I'm loving it do I
need to get a little thumbs I think you
should yeah sometimes it gets a little
bit slippery I need Thumb sleeves what
are they called
thumb sleeve you're in the right place
there is an army of uh that's actually
an issue it's like it's a little bit
slippy you know
so they're playing some hardpoint here
and you know obviously us coming from
these four side of things we love
hardpointing miles you're talking about
this morning when there's a hardpoint
and there's some elevation above it you
can dive into it turn around land on
your belly and yeah absolutely prize so
you know there are some movement
Mechanics for those few speed demons out
there if you want to make some plays
yeah this is what talks about you know
the way slide works now and of course
the dolphin dive is back I think it's
we're not officially pulling into the
dolphin.com the dive itself I mean it's
a really fun mechanic it's uh it's fast
we get to see some gameplay with it uh
I've actually been walking around
talking to some of the sort of the CDL
Pros we're like hey guys try to stop
sliding try to dive a bit more come on
Butters show us the dive show us the
slide now we're looking for out the
window just dive out the window send it
and all the windows are built to be
diveable through like that's the way the
game is that's what Joe was going to say
it right like they're seeing so much and
play Tesla and he goes into a window
like everyone sends it out so you think
like all the exciting moments you're
going to have oh here we go butt is
going to be sniped in there that's the
so we have the hurricane she's running
over cool that's gonna be one of the M4
platforms and the snipe in the other
side look there we go testing things out
trying to trying to find the sneaky
today I couldn't I was trying to see if
I could break the slide
you know what I'm noticing on this map
that I actually like a lot not as many
doors not as many doors I think he's in
general is the overall Vibe uh I mean
most of the maps we've seen so far quite
small very fast paced again Jeff talking
about that you've got a very distinct
feel so it's like the battle map is very
large way more intense action of course
there's like evasion stuff the 6v6 is a
totally different flavor I mean that
obviously and excites us maybe it should
most oh I mean we love it right like
we're we're here to see people go hard
uh try to win be competitive and uh oh
okay I don't think we're seeing a lot of
elevation on some of these Maps too the
snipers are gonna be in heaven yeah it's
uh Max two stories I believe I I could
be completely wrong there but I hit it
hit it also look out look at that little
stock did you guys use a sniper
yesterday yeah right no I didn't I used
it for a whole beautiful stock I've ever
seen I think we were in the same game
too yeah I was in the back sniper I
can't wait for the sort of like anime
skins for that my cute little stocks uh
of course we can put skins on individual
attachments now when it comes to making
some very
also something we haven't talked about
yet is the way the perks work I actually
oh I love I love the purchase because it
reminds me of back in the day the
Specialists when you as you get kills
you get more perks as time goes on
you're gonna have two bass perks you can
pick whatever you want as time goes on
you get another one goes on you're gonna
get an ultimate perk as well so it's
actually a it's completely new uh
they've redone it and it's gonna be
sweet well the reason I think I haven't
I haven't really played it yet to deal
with it too much to see like
how vastly different it makes the
gameplay but I know for a lot of us when
you're playing like the multiplayer
experience I feel like you get a couple
perks you like and you just sort of pick
those they're your go-to you don't
really think about it right like you
figure that out in the first couple of
days or weeks of playing the game those
are your perks now it's like I feel like
there's more decision making that goes
into it which I personally think is
exciting now
I don't know what I'm going to be
running
it doesn't feel like they were saying
what was it the different type of
classes they were trying to you have
your rusher kind of your more stealth
type player your Sentinel like they want
to even if it's not like class based per
se like they want to kind of funnel it
with that behind the purses right I
think that's pretty dope but you can
also make your own so you can create it
pick your own two perks your next one
and your ultimate so you can you know
figure out what you want and uh it's
just nice having like a rewarded game
especially when you're frying it really
does you know change when you start off
with the base too yeah you unlock one
off to you know a period of time it
kills you have points yeah game
progresses slowly so no matter how
you're playing you're going to get your
perks eventually but obviously higher
scoring game you're gonna get more and
it's just really interesting again and
the perks are almost tiered and again
Jeff and Joe will come to the best later
on talk about way more detail but the
idea that like yeah the first two perks
they're fine they sort of help out the
gameplay that mid-tier perk way more
impactful yeah and that final perk like
a kind of like the super perk yeah
that's not gonna turn you into Captain
America but it is going to make you way
more effective
take and Jeff and Joe's Thunder Symphony
was just on screen so I mean the wagon
on that boy what there it is
two million views on Tick Tock something
like that it's impressive stuff that's
what you're watching and your free time
quick yes it might be it might be okay
I'm watching them it's Brooke's Tick
Tock you know she's very creative this
is a Search and Destroy a Call of Duty
classic if you're on fun 18. this looks
cool this is one of the maps that we saw
in an Intel drop not too long ago oh
let's go uh this is symphony spectating
Ash Sanders and you know of course we're
talking about like three lane Maps this
is one of those maps that felt like a
very good hybrid three-lane map that
does really really well when it comes to
Game Mode like their Search and Destroy
like you have a traditional outer lanes
and they have their hidden corners and
they have their ways and then that
middle is just pure chaos it's kind of
like a little bit of like it reminds me
of like a paintball range with all the
walls in the corners that there are so I
this is probably one of my favorite maps
that we are playing right now in the
beta testing and as you can see
everybody is having so much fun on it I
mean four and five everybody's doing is
the best game Aiden has 14 kills I just
saw the kill board he's on the other
team Mason just realized he's on the
stream though he's ready to get nasty
and he's fully loaded look at the bottom
he's got all his perks he he's packed up
quite literally come on Mason show me
something special
he is flying wow
oh no that's the fennec I was loving
that one yesterday oh I think that's the
OG well I turned people in a super close
range but pornhoff just gave him the
first news
nice try Mason we still love you
hurricane it's such a different look
like when we're spectating these players
and having gunfight stuff like the way
the player animations are the sound
effects like the game has just been like
is everything we liked about mw19 or the
stuff that was already there existing
and they've just yeah they've just been
I mean it's Salt Bay right on top just
just hammering away sweet seasoning up
to bottom there well and it was a close
game and now it's done he looked very
silky and then he was just evaporated I
gotta say the Bunny Hop Is Back and
Forth oh man the Bunny Hop is clean we
know
baby we got myth on the screen here
let's use an M4 I think again looking at
these weapons you know it's an M4 but
the configuration he has I was using the
bigger site uh the Double uh you know so
I forget the name of it I like the extra
zoom and of course killstream excuse
myself back a lot of fan favorites Clint
I mean everything you would expect from
a model
ah metal connect able to hit it he's
vibing right now but it's crazy like
yeah yeah bottom right yeah
in in-game settings
options you know just create that sort
of visual okay you want the game to be
as appealing as possible for you maybe
you don't they're going to be so big to
obscure the view maybe one of those
settings
there's a lot of settings in this game
I'm gonna get lost in that for the
entire first day probably because once
campaign hits I'll spend about three and
a half hours missing the settings and
then getting that first mission well I
see courage on a five streak that pop up
at the top of the Serena might have
courage might be popping off oh well he
just died
oh come on swag swag styled hit it
[Music]
yeah this sub looks like it's it's down
here also all the sounds and everything
when you level up guns oh yeah
everything is there I mean I wish
everyone could experience just this
environment though like as much as we're
enjoy the gameplay how cool it's been
because like a lot of a lot of these
content creators like they're friends or
they're familiar with each other they
play games online but like it's not
often you get them all in one place like
this and it has just been a Vibe seeing
everybody going up some meeting for the
first time like I know I spent Isaac we
have interacted so many times on social
I've never met him in person did we hug
him for a solid 30 seconds it was
beautiful
and it just shows like how hyped people
get for Call of Duty I was like I can't
believe I still get his amped for Call
of Duty after over 10 years I don't
think many things like bring everybody
together like this it is special
the Bayer starts tomorrow in case you've
been living under a rock or if you've
just joined the stream yeah
too there's no in between
user interface has been completely
changed as well Dead Silence available
in that lower right hand side just a lot
more sort of clean changes across the
menu system which you might not have
seen here on the on the main uh called
Next stream but individual streamers
seeing them going through weapon load
I've seen The Operators there so many
cool changes a lot more of a streamlined
experience it's sexy that's that's not a
lot of ways to describe it I love that
especially like when you click Start you
go and you look at your Loadout you
switch weapons it looks good you can see
everything it's just right in front of
your face you know exactly what's there
uh digestible and that's what you need
such a fast-paced game like Call of Duty
digestible I'm super enjoyed that like
it doesn't obscure too much of the
in-game screen so if I'm hitting pause
I'm checking stuff out I still have some
kind of like situational awareness
running game yeah yeah and I will say in
terms of balance of like ARs and SMGs of
course this is all of our like our first
Peaks into it but they've looked pretty
balanced so far like the SMGs have been
absolutely disgusting up close whether
the air gets first shot or not now at
long range the SMGs haven't been ripping
as well The Recoil gets insane at that
sort of range so I feel like it looks
like the gun balance as well regardless
of your attachments and what
configuration you end up coming with is
fairly much I love that because I mean
it just feels like sometimes it turns
into this one gun that can do everything
yeah right and I I think everyone
appreciates a little bit of variety
literally what this game is because you
could change your gun up to whatever you
want right so well in a way yeah but
like I think Tally's Point like there
seems to be a little more separation
between yeah like I haven't seen the
do-it-all gun just yet yeah I mean we
saw Aiden of course on the Mountain Dew
Green carpet like I want a broken
shotgun and I'm sure he can make it but
broken will find out what that really
means uh of course that's the game
develops he wants you he wants a sonoff
that kills people across map that makes
a move real fast I mean hey who knows
gunsmith is crazy 2.0 even crazy well I
mean we'll see if he can do it wow I
mean no matter how much work has gone
into this uh we've got the nerds in the
building and this is where if anyone's
gonna test some stuff find some you know
weird combination that yeah turns a
shotgun into a sniper this is the crew
that's going to probably scratch the
surface oh yeah you've touched it for 20
minutes what people are gonna do with
this gun that's just not enough not
enough no idea what these guys are gonna
come up with foreign
[Music]
Stromboli we love them little boots on
the building it's got the M4 he's gonna
run this class setup from now until the
next two years
it can be great to mess around with guns
oh Chris crowd I don't listen I'm not
sure what's going on here Chris has been
uh growing some sort of beard that's
happening for the first time that's
United he's usually very baby face now
he's gonna go for some sort of
supermodel type thing or maybe like
being a a rapper singer he's a handsome
he really is he really is a tiny little
bit of a user interface there if you
hold a circle wherever you are so
crouchman is when you're on a ladder you
can boss slide down it so uh that's
gonna get spicy
oh he's on it he's on his feet powder
he's on his feet coach the goats
oh man we will be playing all day
friends all day
ironside's here kind of clean well I
think this is great too for a lot of uh
I mean people like you saw Zenni you
know you saw Crowder for those who don't
know yeah they work on the CDL side you
know they're really in the midst of
stuff during the season they don't get
to come to stuff like this that often
and see all these content creators I I
imagine they're in heaven I've seen some
of the tweets just having a blast meet a
lot of different people so as far as
streaks goes we haven't seen a whole lot
obviously cruise missiles there County
UAV a classic veto is going to be back
uh you know everything I mean the
Juggernaut is I think it's the final one
and it looks crazy and whoever that AFK
play with get it get it you are live at
pod next uh but yeah there's a ton of
cool stuff and I mean we're seeing
Wilson's in there I love that okay I
have a lot of fun Chopper Gunners back
there's I mean it's called Uh I think
it's called air support now but it's uh
it's an easy one third you know what I'm
talking about there's a chopper Gunner
here as well oh yeah yeah we're gonna be
seeing it all yeah miles like if we play
against each other later today when we
get the free play I'm getting shot I
think I'm actually locked on this desk
all day I would love to play more after
shooting we could play more yeah I think
we uh once that once the curtains go
down
can you hear the chain yeah
they can wheel me in the chair but it's
hard to get down the stairs here we go
run man how are we doing now what a shot
he got two not over the headset he
killed Nick marks
so this is the uh your support where
you're saying yeah this is it's it's
kind of like kind of a lucky story
or it's a custom one wait a minute
longer range maybe but that looks like
the fennec yeah that's the Phenix that
boy don't recoil what all right bread
man's already found a winner
oh my God no it does recruit but it like
doesn't but he's holding that thing down
though all right he's a mouse obviously
recoil long range you can imagine but it
doesn't seem like there's a lot he's
just locked him down yeah cameraman get
in there real close show me the hands
yeah this is this is a lot of fun we saw
a top down of this on socials recently
but yeah it came in the hands you hear
how that sounds so sad that sounds that
sounds scary though you hear that that
better be on my team
I mean he is one of the better Avers
I've seen though like a lot of the
tournament stuff we were talking about
mouse and keyboard players like he is
absolutely nuts with it
so not surprised to see him uh finding
some wins in the long range battles but
I gotta see his recoil control
what do you guys think about all these
Maps so far what's your what's your
what's been your guys favorite tomorrow
honestly yeah it doesn't look like he's
pulling down a whole lot
I honestly there was this is Museum a
nice big Central Area essentially three
lanes I mean this is a second story
we're about to go up there now this is
where Batman is it's nice man we've got
some decent lines of sight snipers are
gonna have a lot of fun here we played
hardpoint on this map we played prisoner
rescue courage and I clutched up big
time last night like a 2v5 all right the
prisoner on my back I was sprinting I
can hear Jack picking up three four
kills let's go baby screaming I'd be
that guy on the team too I I'd be
carrying yeah it was it was great it was
really great we had a lot of fun there's
a lot of cool you know the opening
breaks and stuff like that he's on a
15th streak by the way excuse me he's
literally annihilating the lobby oh yeah
let's stick with him he's on 15 in a row
another Cruise coming in bang this is
the el gato replay of this dancing
oh he gets two again just ripping him
it's the same two people no sorry this
guy oh it's a replay oh he's it I've got
to say sorry he was on 15 in a row I
thought he got another one I thought he
wrapped his streaks
it's all good oh yeah I basically I
basically just pulled a symphony dude
when he was cast in the pre-game Lobby
oh and it wasn't good I thought he
earned another one
well last thing I saw was 15th Street I
was fired up oh so it's M4 his just
sounds crazy I think it's the dubbing an
audio it might be a stream by the way
it's history that boys ripping metal uh
so okay kind of cool to see there on the
bottom side of the screen for a moment
there how the perk system works he's
already at his second tier of perks uh
which I think was spotter 19 kills let's
go Fred man and of course he's working
his way towards that final perk here in
this uh yeah it's not that crazy I
thought he wrapped streaks now is it
he's annihilating everyone 20. he's
farming yeah he's literally farming so
many Kill Broadway
wait do you guys see the moment though
that I was talking about like how when
you're moving like your whole body like
it's different than other Call of Duty
games it's very hard to put into words
but once you get your hands on this game
like you can tell everything moves with
you like usually the gun's fairly
sedationary but like everything is
moving with you at all times and you can
see it so that's yeah for more of the
hardcore players yeah there's going out
there and they're like jiggle peeking
your hips yeah like everything's good so
it's a little bit different when you
play the 3p mode you get a better
understanding of like how that looks and
you'll see that a little bit later today
because like the physics of the
character physics yeah character has
been reimagined so it's different yeah
throwing those shoulders you got to be a
little careful everyone's like Shakira
out there throwing the hips around
they're gonna be very I mean it's the
anime
I don't doubt that but you've got to
look how smooth the animations can be
and so much fun so far
oh is this what it looks like to be on
the other side of the bread man
we're going to get up there
oh I think that was breadman yeah
she's got that thing locked down there
get him just go back in there
I mean this is this is going on the
timeline for sure Red Man's got clips
for days
I mean destroy's calling the streaks to
the SAE above what have we got here
imagine loading in like trying to check
everything out run some different guns
and brand matches up top yeah he just
like dialed it I don't think you sent a
word
hit it ah ads not quick enough there two
posted up on the bridge just shut them
down but he has the pistol on Miles
remember we were playing with it we
turned into a fully auto sub yesterday
yeah
so of course gunsmith is ridiculous you
can turn your sidearm into something
pretty mean and then of course the ledge
height mechanic I'm hanging on ledge
Clint you were singing the Spider-Man
song earlier hey man if Spider-Man
carried a a Glock yeah maybe
it is crazy to see like how much damage
you can do with that thing and and just
I mean it's something that we have to
learn now it's Call of Duty players I
have to now look at funny Ledges and see
where players are yeah I was also trying
out some of the Builder Bridge yesterday
for the you know short amount of time
that I did have I tried the camera one
it was so interesting just like throw it
down go ahead and recorder you can see
when they're pushing their Tunes you
hold your own flank yeah you got your
own choke points that's great and again
another thing oh
ah oh Isaac he did he got both of them
there of course Isaac one of our streams
coming in from uh from Europe made the
long trip across yeah I was wondering
how many people we had here
International I've casted over him in a
bunch of War Zone tournaments he's made
some deep runs guy's a monster but as
he's just trying to hit some Snipes and
try some of the different weapons uh
bradman's uh kind of been an island
hello Bobby there we go another shot
gonna hit back
I'm already really liking the sounds of
these guns I'm liking those crosshairs
look like this is something I cannot
wait to go oh hello breadman just got a
three piece and then Isaac followed up
with the fourth in the feed that was
very satisfying
oh yeah they are just tearing them apart
it feels like
what's that field upgrade he has there I
can't tell from him yeah that could be
the portable radar oh that might be yeah
so that little bad boy uh kind of gives
you sort of a local sort of UAV but the
radius isn't obviously great but yeah
hey man in a pinch I'll take it dude
look at that boy here just hit like
right on the pail of the window so the
first shot didn't hit second one that'll
go through I was using this yesterday
it's a powerful shot
oh he's got it boy somebody saved him oh
my God it was bread man oh my God Nick
marks was trying to assassinate Isaac
all right get us out of there over the
crowd here's the fennec
you run so quick of this thing
you know I mean look how different this
POV seems where it's like the sniper POV
yeah like yeah
oh wow okay Sean Jay what's wrong
Verizon again this is that sort of idea
about the different uh maybe not play
Styles we kind of like player attributes
here what you're going for I'm you know
Crowder is obviously he's way more
aggressive you know he might be hitting
flanks soon but
the way he's kicked himself out whoa
he's in the mix
I think something that you could learn a
lot that all these creators are going to
learn very quickly is there a lot more
pass on the map than you know about like
on this one specifically behind Crowder
there's an underground passageway where
one of the flags are and like I didn't
even know you could go down there like I
had to wrap the entire building before I
figured out how to get underground so
there's a lot more angles and a lot more
passageways than I think a lot of these
creators are expecting and that's why
we're gonna see possibly a lot more
assassinations possibly a lot more
cruddy corners and people just popping
out of literally nowhere
[Applause]
Friday was locked in
and that is the power of the fennec that
player didn't stand a chance yeah he's
in the perfect area to use this weapon
it's like going out getting pigs yeah
strange combat
it's a lot of fun to use this one man I
was just a majority of the games I mean
they're not doing a great job in game
they've got the lead for now but again
classic Dom capture the flags
uavs and all sorts of pillsburys coming
up no one's uh I don't think it would go
too crazy with any of the killstream
choices we did see Krim six with a veto
earlier again classic yep uh I wonder if
we're gonna see any more today
try different weapons I mean as much as
I say that we know how a lot of these
people are they're going for crazy Clips
they want to drop bombs they want to
have high kill games so some are going
to find stuff they like little
accommodation they feel comfortable with
and they're gonna send it but Crowder
yeah he's in the mix right now movement
I mean he seems pretty comfortable so
far just
little hop Chows yeah the Bunny Hop
freebies just hopping around you can
even hit fire this one of these picking
up a ton of kills he's he's loving this
class setup he switched it up from last
time so one of the big things I mean
before the show started I walked around
and talked to as many of the streamers
as I possibly could I was just like you
know you've had a tiny bit of time in
the game how you feeling about this and
almost every single one of them said I'm
really struggling not to slide
everywhere they've been so useful doing
that you get used to it from nw19 all
the way through the war zone when you
know we're on Caldera it's not the same
it's not the same I can say that just
from all the wars that I played like it
it's gonna take like my hand just the
muscle memory of it like I'm just so
I've been side canceling now for years
across the map it's just gonna take a
little to get used to 100 but I do think
my hands are going to be very happy
though that I'm not having to do that
constantly across the map yeah if you
try to slide around now you might might
even be slower than just sprinting
honestly yeah again it's how he uses the
dive is a really great mechanical
shaping the slide gets you in a
different positions obviously I like to
leave with my head you know the the ball
at the bald head so I think the diving
things would be good for me just like a
bowling ball you know miles just sending
under a door sitting it through a window
maybe diving into someone you think I
can knock somebody out that way or if
there's an attachment here you yeah like
it's not like a unicorn yeah bayonet on
my head okay that sounds sick though
honestly if the devs are listening let's
think about that a little bit a bayonet
dive oh my God I want that immediately
I'm thinking like uh you know I've got
this idea of like you know he's got a
big spin on his head yeah
absolutely Isaac oh quick SWOT again
that is his side up that's his pistol
can the range on that bad boy he's gonna
do all that crazy but you know it's
gonna rip when it is snipers are so
satisfying you can feel the sound how
deep it is it's amazing it feels like
there's no drag in the sniper when you
were using an ant they'd have to leave a
shot at all or wasn't it it felt like an
invasion like I had to leave my
childhood but that could just be because
I'm wrestling
and I was trying to shoot across the map
that's uh but you can get some feeds man
like I got a couple collapse of this gun
super powerful
sniping his back friends
still fast and fine again
we thought Brad was popping off destroys
up there fry it he's got double the
score of everybody in the lobby
all right all right
look at this
oh man through the door with a pistol a
lot of Windows on that map as well a lot
of glass above those door frames I found
on uh you know keeping the teasers that
I put like opening breaks and stuff a
lot of sweet and eight spots already uh
yeah I can't wait I cannot wait a little
peek at the menu here now as well of
course well Isaac gets ready to get into
his next game so much
so much in Modern Warfare 2. uh we're
almost actually ready to keep the
shoulder roll keep the show running Jess
you're down there with Zuma tell us how
Tommy's doing miles that's right I am
right here with Zuma Tommy proper Auto
himself so I mean you have now had your
first taste of Modern Warfare 2 hero Cod
next what did you think oh it's
incredible the game feels super smooth
the Gunplay is awesome I like the time
to kill and the maps are dope a lot of
Close Quarter uh uh gunfights and uh you
know I'd be having a blast man the
chat's loving it as well they're loving
it so there's so much to talk about you
know new modes new maps changes to the
gunsmith but what really stands out to
you like what are you excited about I'm
really excited just to get the
competition going I mean I'm excited for
the CDO and I heard them talking about
ranked play so you know I'm really
excited for that um it Warzone 2 looked
incredible as well I was talking to
repost we're gonna be the war zone Duo
this year so I'll be bouncing around
between the both but I'm just excited
for something new you know a new game
and it's been a lot of fun to play and
there's so many amazing creators here
um and just thank you to everybody and
thank you to Call of Duty for the
opportunity beer it's awesome and then
you know real quick with Modern Warfare
2 on the horizon what does the year
ahead look like for you man just a lot
of shows man a lot of flanks a lot of
streams I mean the content's gonna be
pushing all year so excited man zoom off
he's gonna take over and we're gonna
have uh we're gonna have some fun man
we're gonna have some fun all right well
thank you so much that is all from me
for now I believe I'm handing it off to
my dear friend Lottie
thank you so much Jess and it is so good
to be here my name is Lottie first time
on the desk first time of course being
this incredible Arena I have a lot of uh
wonderful folks on this desk but it is
now time to chat about an epic giveaway
from our friends at Jack Links each Jack
Link supply drop includes a brand new
copy of Modern Warfare on the platform
of your choice delicious Jack Link's
limited edition products and brand new
epic in-game items that I promise you'll
be dying to get your hands on so check
this out on how to enter
looking for an epic way to celebrate the
launch of Modern Warfare 2 Jack Link has
got you covered giving you the chance to
win the ultimate Modern Warfare 2 supply
drop keep an eye out during the
broadcast for the Jack Link Sasquatch to
appear on screen if you see it grab your
phone and scan the QR code following the
prompts to qualify for entries tune in
to Call of Duty next Squad up with
Sasquatch and level up for the ultimate
viewing experience courtesy of Jack
Links terms and conditions apply
foreign
folks to keep your eyes peeled to spot
the Sasquatch on the screen throughout
the show scan that QR code and enter all
your information for a chance to win but
it is my absolute honor and pleasure to
be on the death of course alongside
Maven but we also have Jeff and Joe on
here to talk all things in Modern
Warfare 2 of course I'm multiplayer
design directors here and we're just
going to get a bit Nerdy To be honest
you know we're going to look at a
gameplay I am so excited to talk about
it but maybe I've got to ask you what do
you want to dive into first we have the
two guys that are going to answer a
question well first up by the way you
guys killed in the opening yourself you
know it started real smooth I'm sure
nerves are going a little bit but it was
it was awesome to see but I know we're
gonna have gameplay it's gonna going to
be popping up we're gonna chat through
stuff but I think one thing I kind of
want to chat through is just there's
been a lot of significant changes you
guys are always looking to how to kind
of tweak the wheel a little bit can we
chat through kind of the perk change and
where your head was at with regards to
that because it's it's a big change it's
interesting yeah you know uh perks
haven't really been touched for a long
time in the series
um and I guess by Nature they're passive
and so
um most of the time we found people just
uh you know find the three that they
like and that's it they kind of forget
about this I said that earlier that's me
yeah I find a few I like and like that's
my class there we go we just wanted to
come up with a system that was a little
bit more engaging and so we we grouped
them into three different categories
um you get two to start with and then
you pick a third and then you pick a
fourth and they're uh they're rewarded
as you play
um you really like how they per uh they
um yeah yeah yeah I mean an announcer
comes up tells you what perk you got it
kind of re-engages you with what's
available right and they're earned
through time and score So eventually
you'll get them and you're not gonna
you're not gonna it doesn't reset on
death
um it allowed us to to kind of like
create a couple more powerful perks and
put them at the end because you're not
going to have the whole match and
there's some interesting depth there
where you can say Okay uavs are really
powerful early match like there's
different things you can do or you're
kind of like if you're one of those
players who really wants to Noodle
you're like okay I know these aren't in
play yet well I like I I guess listen
it's very different but I I'm also a big
like RPG guy so I like the process of
like unlocking things and earning things
it's just like at the core of who I am
so I dig that just like
the progression over the course of one
single map I think is very cool yeah it
just feels good it feels good it feels
good reminded what you have yeah yeah no
no 100 oh and I guess we didn't touch on
actually is the packages right from like
we're talking a lot about the theory
crafting Yeah Yeah Yeah we actually have
these defined packages so early on you
just say you know I want to this place
out I just grab this package and go and
then later on when you're like okay I
like that but I want to nude a little
bit you can hop in and create your own
packages you know that that kind of um
it really people can see that through
the default loadouts
um and we've packaged in based on those
kind of player behaviors we were talking
about earlier we've we've usually ship
six or five default layouts but we have
six with this one okay we found two for
each behavior and so
um those perk packages are already in
there
um and it's something different in this
game we actually allow you to attach a
field upgrade within that
um within each Loadout and so it's a
little bit more micromanagy but it felt
to us that you're you're kind of more
creating your class and your character
for you know in that
um so people in the in the beta should
really try out those default loadouts
because we put a lot of time into how
those um play well I'm curious in like
play testing did you see like a I'm sure
everyone has a way to view themselves as
a player like maybe us start is more of
like a sentinel type did you see like as
people got more comfortable with the
game like if evolution towards maybe a
faster Pace or what did you notice when
play testing these different types of
things yeah I mean I think overall most
of our players are rushers
you're not you're not wrong it depends
on the circles you run but um you know
there there are these other players and
and we wanted to just make sure that you
know we're supporting all of them
um and so you know some of the field
upgrades can be more
um Sentinel and trying to hold down
positions
um but that's why we added in the DDOS
like we said to kind of just say I've
had enough I want to pause all this
stuff and make it go away yeah um but we
also leaned into creating game modes
that can um facilitate this kind of
Siege gameplay but now we talk about the
rushing players right but we also want
to talk about the pacing the movement
you know what it looks like how it feels
to be in game and when I got a chance to
get on the sticks yesterday something I
noticed is it is a little bit slower
paced right we're going to be sprinting
around not sliding rounds and I think
another thing I want to talk about is
the dolphin Dives I've been diving down
the escalators getting prone looking at
hard points trying to figure out can I
see bomb site bra like you know it's
pretty incredible with the movement and
how it feels and what was it like making
that what were the decisions behind that
pushing forward because the feel of the
game is huge yeah I think I think
fluidity and I mentioned it previously
is like really really important right
but we did make some small tweaks right
like slide has a little bit more of a
hang up so the people aren't just
sliding around the map so that they're
actually moving through spaces checking
corners and and kind of like pacing
themselves but the general movement of
guns should be almost exactly the same
and Jeff and I regularly check in we're
like okay how are we how are we doing
like let's look at last game let's look
at this game and we try and be
consistent in that regard but there have
been these small tweaks and the dive is
one of those tweaks the ledgehang is one
of those tweaks
um and those will change how people move
through a space right you won't throw
yourself over a wall you'll peek that
wall first yeah I love the leg tanks
because that you know just testing out
yesterday being able to kind of ledge
hang and really use it as Intel as well
I think when it comes to multiplayering
and competitive side that's kind of
where I'm at here is being able in SMD
just being able to know where people are
give that Intel to your team peek get
back down again making sure you're not
getting your Dome ripped off by a sniper
of course uh major stuff here but and
exciting that the fact that you can get
your secondary weapon out and start to
put a bit of damage in and help out
there so in terms of ledgehank where did
that come from what was the idea behind
it you know why is it so special to have
it in the game
um to be honest it came out of uh face
planting too many times
parachuting in yeah just missing that
ledge and you're like nope that's
frustrating let's fix that we've all
been there like here whether you've been
playing Wars I don't think you're trying
to like hop and grab it and you're just
like it's like you want to hit the
button to like activate the pull-up but
then yeah you hit your shoot and you're
like falling down it can be so
frustrating yeah so I mean really that's
where it came from but yeah it was it
was also the high mantle too right like
late when we were developing Modern
Warfare and then you know war zone
started to come out we had these walls
and things we ended up turning up the
mantle height in war zone okay and it's
it didn't feel as polished but it
allowed people to get over walls they
otherwise couldn't and but like I said
before you kind of commit and now you're
like throw yourself over a wall and get
shot as you make that transition so the
high mantle is definitely like get up
you can peek or you can just double tap
it and pull yourself over if you're in a
hurry
um it just adds that that extra layer of
like I can be a little bit smarter about
how I move through the space that's like
that's a good note that um you know we
make all of the equipment all of the
movement and all of these things for
scalability and we have to kind of check
ourselves that everything we put here is
going to show up in Warzone well now
you've got this like metaverse of like
there's so much
like I was saying earlier right like not
hard man I'm sure it's like how do you
add different things in and and make
sure it all stays in check and not mess
up this ecosystem well it feels like I
guess for me when I view it what has
been the one thing at least for me that
really separates Call of Duty from a lot
of other
Shooters it's like it does feel so fluid
but like there's
a limit to that too you don't need to be
an amoeba like it's just like floating
through the map like you want to be some
realism to it but like how can you add
that realism and the ability to I mean
think about I don't know 10 years ago
what you're able to do with just like
interacting with the map of what it's
come to now I mean it's insane how much
it's changed we had to argue to get
sprinting into uh I think it was Cod
four I'm sure I'm sure we didn't have
that and so like just the evolution of
where yeah it's come a long ways I
played the very first one so yeah yeah
it's been pretty pretty special and
something else is a bit special as well
as the fact that we have all these
content creators behind us we have an
Elgato Replay for you guys especially
Memphis on Prison rescue just gonna
check this one out and see exactly what
went down here and this recipe is going
to be really exciting one of course
because you have to get that objective
done you need to go rescue the prisoner
and carrying them out is going to be
huge because that icon does disappear
you know how did it work with this
prisoner being able to put them in the
game at knowing that somebody's gonna
have to run this prisoner back and
extract them and having that defense to
be set up later on and acts completely
and utterly change the game go to that
defensive code what was the color
makings behind that so it was it was
actually kind of a hard mode to make and
we went through all these different
iterations and we had these problems
where we're like hey the modes around
rescuing these prisoners but people they
weren't able to right we're like hey do
this heroic thing and rounds just kept
ending in elimination because it was so
hard and that's why we added the the um
the radar Suite that you get when you
get the prisoner and that's why we took
the icon away when you picked the
prisoner up because we were going
through and we used to have we tried
with one prisoner we tried with two
right next to each other we tried all
these different iterations and it took a
while before we everything kind of
clicked and you often when you're making
game modes you don't really know like
some of them pretty quickly are like oh
there it is yeah but this one took a lot
of work a lot of finessing and and then
we finally got it to where there is this
balance and we're seeing more hero
moments and that replay we saw he
actually I think of that one but I was
what we were talking earlier I saw him
actually pick up the prisoner and take
it all the way to extract and have that
run and that's what we wanted that Hero
Run yeah
I'm just thinking about like how crazy
it's gotten like I I don't envy you guys
at all I mean I do you have great jobs
but like the fact that you have to think
about like everything within this
sandbox like from when you're trying to
make a new mode like how is some new
movement or anything going to affect
Warzone how's it going to affect
groundwater basically like
I think at every game you have that at
the end of the previous one you're like
okay how do we squeeze more blood from
the stone yeah right right and it's like
but then you start iterating and trying
different things and and you do kind of
like all of a sudden it's ballooned and
you're like oh no we have to cut stuff
we have too much yeah I mean Jeff Joe
this is a pretty hard question but just
to kind of wrap things up here you know
I think when when you talk about Call of
Duty when you listen to feedback from
players and different Generations they
always talk about that nostalgic feeling
that they get when they get on the game
what is it about Modern Warfare 2 this
time around this title in particular do
you think that is going to bring
Generations back years to come and say
look modern well Modern Warfare 2 excuse
me was my game and this is why I want to
play it year and year out
yeah you know Nostalgia is a weird thing
and I know from from working on past
games and people speaking so highly
underneath different things and it's and
um it's kind of where you're at in your
world and your friends and things like
that and so for us we can't really
control that but we we try to lay out
um kind of I don't know for the lack of
a better term like you're kind of laying
out a nice meal and you're hoping that
everyone enjoys it and and
um from all the systemic play with all
of our equipment and and all these
different interactive systems we're just
hoping that fans find new and crazy ways
um to play the game
um I don't know what about you you just
want to be fun right yeah because of
stall so you gotta probably tune some of
it out like some stuff that's tough yeah
you don't know what's going on right you
don't know and I think one of our
strengths is though is that we I run
into people all the time and they're
like I'm an SMD player yeah I'm a war
zone player I'm a blender player like
you know like I I love TDM that's my I
just play that and so it's interesting
that we're we're fortunate to be able to
make all these different offerings so
that people can come into our game like
I love big war vehicular combat I'm
going to ground more right and so I
think that's a an advantage that we have
that people can find their place the
thing they love bring their friends in
and then years to come they're like I
remember that that was awesome yeah a
bunch of different experiences for sure
and I gotta say the fact that we haven't
even really scratched the surface yet
you know we're here at the reveal we're
seeing it for the first time there's so
many questions that we have as well I
want to know what some of the challenges
have been for you guys to develop this
game to really get it to the point that
it is now where you are comfortable to
show it to the world and reveal it you
know what some of the hardships been
along the way in this ride
you know I think the big kind of
elephant in the room is just you know a
lot of this was made from people's homes
you know
um you're looking at people's art and
and work that you know people in their
Home Spaces are is their living room
wild they're wild I work out of a shed
in my backyard
um some there's people in their mom's
basement I bet it's a cool shed though
not really
but you know but the the fact that we
can get this done through you know
millions of Zoom meetings and millions
of kind of um and keeping everybody up
to date and so many different Studios
not just ours um you know all these
different Activision Studios to kind of
keep on on point and and and make sure
that everything is you know good and
great it's it's uh it's been tricky yeah
I think it's I mean that's I think it's
a great segue to like we have a really
talented team and we're up here
representing that team whether it's the
multiplayer Team the engineering team
the animation yeah our team and they're
all specialists in what they do the
Fidelity on our view model animations
the guns everything the art and Maps the
design our Geo designers they make these
66 type Maps they make these huge
groundwater maps and they put it all
together into this massive big map and
everything needs to sing it's all I mean
all we can do is thank them and do our
best to represent them I'm kind of
curious were there any like positives
for me from a creative standpoint with
like the fact everyone's in the office
and like everyone was kind of like away
like I almost feel like maybe that would
lead to some interesting ideas like when
everyone's really not in a room and like
maybe one idea kind of takes precedent
like everyone's just kind of isolated a
little bit more I just wonder if there
was any like creative advantages there
yeah I think a lot of I think a lot of
people were worried that
um kind of like productivity would go
down by living at home but
um people we just found that everyone
was so passionate about you know making
this game that they could either play a
game or their PCS sitting there and they
could make the game better and if
they're you know consistently working
way too you know too much and we're like
hey oh calm down we're good let's get
you know
um so I think that is a little bit of
the fun what I heard in some cases like
productivity actually like went up which
you wouldn't expect and like now people
are down scaling offices so I was kind
of curious if yeah you just had like a
lot of I know Superstars kind of show up
and pop out some really amazing stuff
yeah it's It's tricky because you know
um we've just now been coming back in
and getting kind of that kind of
community in the office and that has
been um a great way of kind of
solidifying the game and getting people
back in and and feeling the you don't
get the big Hoots and hollers when
you're at home right yeah we get people
in the office who get them in the big
pit and we're all playing gold star yeah
you get that feedback loop of like I
made good stuff and someone's happy yeah
look drawing back the current a little
bit because when I think of how to
handle a brand new game a brand new
title bringing all these exciting
factors to it I'm thinking of like
Bare Bones you know in your shed maybe
with a white boards you know just
writing things on just brainstorming
what is that process like you know
building the blocks building the
foundation behind this brand new game
putting those ideas down on paper how
does it work for your team
well that's a big question
I mean one one aspect we used was
um we tried to kind of break everything
down as simply as possible and that
really is just like a one-on-one
interaction yeah you know like if you
imagine how many times a one-on-one
interaction happens in a multiplayer or
in single player and like what what does
that look like you know they could just
shoot each other but you know it's it's
what what is in your Loadout what's in
my Loadout it's almost like it's like a
card game Or I I use my flash and you
use your smoke and yeah right and so
like we really worked on how many
permutations and how that can play out
and so we figured if if we can get that
to come and and play out in a lot of
different ways we can make a really
deeply replayable game and which should
you know make everyone really happy at
the end of the day yeah it seems like
everyone's having a blast so far I mean
this just this in general
it's got to uh It's gotta be pretty
special to see just this many kante Cruz
here gas up and join the game I mean
it's been absolutely incredible honestly
Jeff Joe thank you so much for being
here giving us all the insights letting
us know down a little bit ask all the
questions that we're dying to know uh
but I'll tell you what it is about time
right now to head on over to the main
stage to talk a little bit more about
Cod mobile we've got beef Mommy and Matt
Lewis over there let's take it over to
them and see what they have in store
all right all right thank you so much
Lottie and welcome back to the command
center presented by Xfinity rewards and
it's time to finally drop into some Epic
War Zone mobile gameplay and joining me
here are none other than Matt Lewis I've
been so excited to bring you into this
stage he is the vice president of
product management for mobile
thank you so much I am super excited to
be here today we just have some awesome
awesome gameplay we have some cool new
surprises for you so I'm just really
looking forward to sharing this moment
with you and with just the entire Call
of Duty Community I'm so excited I'm
just ready to get into action and
obviously things are just heating up
over here and it really is impressive
what you've been able to pull off here
and watching someone play it looks great
it feels great it's running it's as if
it's running off a console to be honest
it's true how did you guys make this
from the ground up yeah it's it's it's a
great question so one of our game
pillars was what we call relentlessly
war zone I don't give it this way there
are a set of emotions and an overall
gameplay quality something that's felt
when you play warzone
and for us you know that's something
it's a product of these proprietary
combat and movement systems the verdansk
map
tons of vehicles and some unique war
zone mechanics things like the gulag and
in-game Loadout drop
so you put all these together in a pot
mix them around put some magic powder in
there and boom warzone
so games they can try to match this
recipe and they can spend a decade you
know iterating and testing and trying
this and that but they're just not able
to quite get there so for us being on
the same technology it means we don't
have to Tinker nearly as much it's just
an incredible Advantage for us so how
was the team able to do it and just
really pull off everything that you've
had here so far with tons of coffee yeah
no wonder why we don't have any more
coffee here backstage exactly that's the
truth all the coffee in the world is how
we were able to do it no you know one of
the things that I just love about this
project it's it's a really it's a really
great mix of talent and experience
um and for us that concoction was what
allowed us to have this kind of great
end product uh so for us you know
they're they're four major Studios who
are working on Warzone mobile
Activision Shanghai beanox digital
Legends and solid state Studios so our
philosophy it's been to mix together
really amazing Call of Duty console and
PC developers with some of the best
mobile developers in the business
because that's what we want you know an
authentic adrenaline pumping war zone
but something that is ultimately in this
made for mobile amazing super polished
mobile experience it's been so much fun
watching all these streamers today and
this game looks like a really great time
what is the best way for our viewers at
home to guarantee they will be the first
to drop in and play Call of Duty Warzone
mobile it's a great question it's a
great question so for us
pre-registration is going to start today
we'll have a little bit more on that
later we're super super super excited
and if you're on Google Play if you log
on to the Google Play Store right now
you'll be able to to um to start to
pre-register if you're on other
platforms please keep an eye out on all
the social channels uh we have the
social channels live now so follow
comment all that all that all that kind
of good stuff and we're coming soon on
the Apple App Store for pre-order
um we have some incredible rewards I'm
going to talk about those maybe in a few
minutes but maybe for now kick it over
check out some gameplay
oh yeah I can't wait to go and
pre-register for myself I'm just so
excited but that brings an end to our
coverage of Call of Duty war zone mobile
and honestly it's been such an amazing
great time here but obviously before we
do end all of these we're gonna try to
see what kind of fun all these streamers
are bringing it up over here because we
are taking up on the screen right now I
mean this ends with us just trying to
introduce the game but obviously every
one of us we want to see the gameplay we
want to see everything that's happened
here and obviously I am with the best
person to talk about everything that is
happening here on your screen right now
oh man so when I'm looking at this
gameplay right now for me one of the
things I love about Warzone is that
vehicle play the vehicle play the
movement and the combat systems all tied
together I'm a thumb player I can't do
the claw myself so when I see other
thumb players in particular on the
vehicles
it's a soft spot for me just feel great
yeah I mean I feel like a lot of the
players right now even if you're not on
mobile you just see this map and you go
like you go back way back to 2020 and
you're just seeing this mapper dance it
just you're basically having a little
bit of a throwback from when you used to
play this map and you get to play it
here on mobile and so I feel like it's
just so exciting to finally see this map
back into life and really we're just
ready to play I know yes we're on Alpha
right now but I played the game
yesterday it feels amazing 100 I think
you nailed it I think the team is really
really happy with where we are if we
think of the development process we
typically think about four stages and
we're in the second stage right now
where we're live to some amount of
people in our Alpha and we're going to
be entering a beta shortly uh so for
people who are interested in getting
their hands on the game the best way to
do that to pre-register now follower
follow all of the channels on social
there'll be some great updates there and
we just have loads of improvements load
prizes too we just have some super cool
stuff coming in new features BB
play gunsmith is looking absolutely
incredible I think players who are
familiar with it they're just not going
to believe what we have coming up with
soon and as you can see over here we
definitely have streamers that you're
very aware of already just logging in
checking out Warzone mobile and it looks
and feels amazing as you can see on your
top left screen we were talking about
this beforehand right one of the pois
that we really love to talk about is
Boneyard because for me in my experience
at Boneyard it's great it has so many
chests you definitely can get a lot of
money but the moment that you drop in
you already know there's a bounty on
your head most likely me too Boneyard
for me is my favorite I'm a player I
like to equip two things I was like two
primaries for myself a shotgun is a must
and I like my shotgun and my sniper
people make fun of me for it but that's
what I love Boneyard allows me to do
both those things I tend to like to hide
out myself in some of those little
airplane shells wait for unsuspecting
people to come in and you know sometimes
I'm lucky in some sometimes I'm not but
that's me Boneyard all the way the fun
thing for me
for me I've been noticing Bobby talk
about this a little bit earlier is you
know being able to go back into some of
those points of interest that you like
in particular ones that were former MP
maps and previous Call of Duties it's
just one of the things that makes
Warzone awesome uh I know people were
talking earlier like oh my God
Superstore Superstore Superstore
oh yeah speaking of Superstore I mean I
like dropping in there because I feel
like I'm going on a shopping spree it's
grocery shopping all the weapons that
you need on the ground they're over
there you know but the thing is it's in
the center of everything you're in the
middle of everything so if you want to
go and just go away into safety you're
going to have such a hard time because
you're worrying about people up top
airports right there Boneyard is right
there as well so I feel like for me like
since we're seeing Boneyard right now
it's kind of like a sick little spot
because it's right off to the side but
you still get really good loot as well
totally well said and for me one of the
things I love about verdansk as a player
is there are these mix of different
ranges you have really close quarter
inside combat things like Superstore got
some long distance sniper areas some
people I know like to go on top a dam
and try to pick off some enemies and
then you have things that are great for
AR you know that mix that mix of ranges
so it really is kind of like you know
Choose Your Own Adventure how do you how
do you want to have that kind of
gameplay
well talking about the gameplay that we
have right now we definitely want to
have a little bit of a look in into the
different streamers that we have because
obviously you can see here the duo got
Hawks we got Bobby plays and they're
definitely really known in the scene
especially when it comes to mobile and
so it's really exciting to finally see
these guys enjoy the game because we've
been talking about this for such a long
time and I really asked Bobby are you
going to be here in this event I saw
your invite I wanted one as well but
obviously I sneaked into the Cod next
event it was finally here finally able
to finally you know see the alpha but
hey since we're here
taking a look at what's going to happen
here on the right side of your screen
you're taking a look at the the map and
it's like it's exactly what we saw in
Warzone totally and it's getting to one
of those end crunch periods this is my
favorite the circle started to close not
yet final Circle but it's definitely
that time you got to be a little bit
strategic and smart about your choices
there is a penalty if you get a little
bit too aggressive
and now speaking of being aggressive
it's like we were talking about it it's
really a matter of where you drop
because obviously the tier 5 loot zones
the tier 4 loot zones you'll always have
that risk but obviously the reward is a
little bit more High I mean especially
if you're going to be dropping at the
very ends of the map at the very end
sections of it where yes you might not
have better loot but you might have a
better time not really looking for those
kills but the best thing here is you
need to find that middle ground in every
BR game that you have it for here cash
is King you need to buy out go and find
a way to buy your Fallen teammates so
we've already talked about it before or
maybe even meet them in the gulag later
on I'm really hoping to see a gulag
feature over here I want to see it me
too and looking at the mini map here
there were just quite a few red dots
around something tells me we're going to
see the gulag pretty soon
now we're talking about the weapons that
they have over here obviously it's
something that we've seen already the
fennec I feel like it's going to be a
really good gun and speaking of there
you go gets one so that's a really good
start rip so horrible though we can see
Bobby Blaze I mean it's just like Bobby
plays has been such a tremendous name
here in the mobile scene and now he
needs to get out because he's going to
be in big trouble especially going out
here with no cover whatsoever I don't
know uh he's living dangerously I don't
know I don't know Bobby I'm worried for
you man yeah Bobby and Hawks they need
to find a way to you know just get some
cover there you go finds one gets the
kill that's gonna be really good for
them so far so again so far so good and
I'm really looking forward to kind of
just talking to the guys later on after
this gameplay right I feel like they
have a lot to say Me too super curious
to hear also curious to hear how this
how this interaction here ends I want to
go back to one thing you're saying
earlier with the loadouts one of the
things for me that I just absolutely
love about Warzone is being able to have
this little in-game economy and the
street choices that happen as a result
sometimes I want to get my own Loadout
sometimes now I'm all about buying a new
score streak leveling up helping my
squad that way there's a really nice
element of strategic choice and it's
ones that we know players and Warzone
1.0 on console and PC they just
absolutely loved and you know in Mobile
there's really nothing quite like it so
just just can't wait for players to get
their hands on that oh most definitely
because I had my hands on it yesterday
I'm not very good at it and that's why
I'm being a shot Caster I'm just kidding
but really just playing the game and
playing War Zone in general it feels as
if you're playing the same thing on
console and PC and so that's such a huge
deal especially since you're putting it
in such a tiny device Tiny But powerful
device and to have the same thing here
not only that it has its unique aspects
as well I think we've already mentioned
it before mobile yes even though you
already have it Warzone is here it has
its unique features Big Time and when we
started making the game we listed out
all these options we could make
something that was totally not connected
it was its own mobile experience no
connective tissue to Call of Duty
console or PC and on the other end of
the spectrum we could do an exact Port
something that felt exactly the same
um had you know same experience same
same economy same everything else what
we decided in the end was you know there
are there are there are different
principles that we want to achieve we
want to make sure on the core game so
here the moment-to-moment gameplay it
feels just as good as Call of Duty
console because really for us that's the
best shooter in the world we want to
make sure that we're rendering that
properly on mobile we just think there's
nothing better at the same time
for mobile players there's certain
customizations that are really important
sometimes on the event side or we call
internally the live Ops side but also
just on the controls so we want to make
sure we're taking those Best of Both
Worlds and adding them together into an
experience that just feels like nothing
else on mobile we think we're on the
right track yeah I'm speaking on the
right track no from YouTube getting
these kills already and it's our first
time seeing him right now so again where
he's at is it it's going to be a prime
spot because it's not going to be too
crowded as you can see here but you can
also get really good loot so that is
definitely one thing that you want to
have and now for him priming all of
these I can see the movement is very
much like Warzone I feel like for me
that was one of the bigger questions
it's like what's the movement going to
be like and you can see here it's good
he's done he's already kind of felt the
game pretty right to the fact that he
can get a lot of these kills and so how
was it like trying to transform into the
movement coming in from war zone going
in here to Warzone mobile that's a great
point we thought movement that's one of
those things movement and really the
whole combat experience it's something
that we just felt like we don't want to
mess with it too much it's so special
it's what makes Call of Duty Call of
Duty so for us it's about rendering that
in the right kind of way and again not
totally there but man we're pretty happy
with where we are at this Alpha stage in
the development process
excited to see every one of these
streamers just ballot it out especially
at the very late game where you get to
see the circle just kind of closing in
but obviously we only have a set amount
of time and that brings an end to what
we saw when it comes to the gameplay of
Call of Duty war zone mobile and it was
been really fun really exciting to see
all the streamers playing the game and
we still have way more aligned up for
you but with that being said let's bring
in Xavier for a special sideline update
yeah what's going on WWE Superstar
Xavier Woods AKA Austin Creed here with
the only
the man the Legend
Live I'm here with Austin Creed oh
having a good time good to see you man
good to see you how you been I've been
great good good been having such a good
time so far man it's crazy well I love
to see you now first things first we've
all been at home for a long time and now
we get to come out to come to an event
like this you get to see all your buds
play Call of Duty with all of them how
does it feel being at this event right
now honestly there's like a 13 year old
little boy like inside of me the 13 year
old version of me that's like freaking
the [ __ ] out sorry I don't know if
that's allowed or not but uh my bad I'll
I won't do it again but like I am losing
my cool like I think it's awesome to
think about the fact that like I'm at a
Call of Duty event and one of this scale
for a game that's this big well uh since
you got to play the game with a bunch of
people so far what's your favorite thing
oh my favorite thing an individual thing
um I think so far what I've come to
really like is I feel like they took
what everything that I loved about
Modern Warfare
and elevated it to the point where like
the visuals the gun play the feel of
everything is just really polish and
tune and that's well part of what I
really really loved about Modern Warfare
nice nice now you're gonna get into some
Battle Royale later today is there
anybody here that you are excited to
find and take out on the battlefield
give me Symphonies Pidgeotto ass you
know what I mean
I wanna I I wanna I wanna I wanna take
him out because you know he's known as
the cheater the war zone kid and he's my
good friend of mine so I feel like it'd
be legendary if I was able to just smoke
him in the new Modern Warfare 2
war zone you know well there we go there
we go we're gonna be watching we're
gonna see if you get it all right
appreciate you guys listening back to
you Lottie
great job guys
that was great that was so fun
inside how hyped up he is like I love it
yeah I mean everybody is I feel the
exact same way yeah everybody's in one
room here for one reason it's to play
and be excited about the new game man
you could hear it like the passion in
here everybody's loving it all the new
game modes and we got one on the screen
right now like we've had 3p in Call of
Duty before but not quite like this yeah
it's been pretty amazing and yesterday
just being able to play seeing your own
back as well has been a while of course
I gotta say it felt pretty damn good and
when you got used to it as well Ali like
yeah started frying and I know you fry
oh I was having an I was having
incredible time yesterday I was on other
streamers set up so I made sure to
change my clan tag to cxt so everybody
knew who was absolutely world starring
them on the map but I will say the
energy in here compared to like a
competitive event it's just it's intense
in a totally different way it's intense
in the fact that every everybody is just
so excited and everybody is just having
pure fun and Bliss loading into a new
game figuring things out like the energy
is just on a different level it really
isn't a difference this looks sick it
does yeah what I what I like about this
Clint is in 3p uh you know three peas
the corners get that Advantage but when
you aim in I was yeah it feels really
natural it looks really nice yeah I was
worried about how seamless would be from
like going from 3p to aiming in but it's
perfect you're centering kills on point
if that's uh how you play the game and
try to keep your you know red dot in the
middle you can play like that right so
it's really nice man it works well the I
the only time I'd really mess with it
too much for me in the was the what the
Cobb mobile BR like the first generation
of it like that kind of that 3p to first
person that was the first time I really
had messed with it much and it it felt
great so it's really cool to see them
try to Double Down
create a game out here yeah and you can
also looks really seamless like you said
you can also kind of see how your
character moves remember what we were
talking about earlier Ali where it was
like the camera the movement like it
feels different it's reimagined like
when you're jiggle peeking you see the
hips the head move everything yeah you
can really see that in the 3p that's
what uh you know when I had that
realization I was playing in that
earlier I was like okay I might have to
play these angles a bit differently and
you know if you're a little bit more of
a tactical player uh like to get that
information this is going to be what you
want to play and I don't know if this
goes for everybody but this is the first
time I I played a third person like this
where you actually went into your site
still like that you weren't still in
third person when you went to ads so
that was very interesting transition for
me and I was curious at how it would
work with a controller because I use a
controller personally I feel like mouse
and keyboard players are a little bit
more accustomed to stuff like that so I
was wondering how that would translate
but liking it was saying like it just
felt natural like it felt normal and it
was actually really really fun to play
because your fov like you see everything
and like you play and you peek Corners
like totally different than in your
first person mode well the one thing I
really Elite like is like one thing I'll
struggle with sometimes like you get
this really cool operator or something
right like a battle pass comes out like
this really dope operator and you don't
really have to see that much it's more
about your gum when you're in the first
person yeah but with this like if you
get something dope or some of the
different emotes you can do like you
scared you get to see what you look like
I think going back to quickly your point
that Ali about getting used to kind of
the zoom and then into the ads as well
it does take a second to get used to for
sure how would you handle that though
because I think you know traditional
Call of Duty games you know straight up
first person you know you can snap
really quickly right you're ads you can
put perks on to make sure that ABS is as
fast as possible this takes a little bit
of time so are you pre-aiming when
you're going around like what are you
doing to try and kind of combat that
well I'll tell you right off the bat
when we first loaded into it yesterday
and got a little bit of a taste I
thought it was a [ __ ] like I thought you
weren't supposed to be able to eat yet I
was like oh my gosh no way like oh
they're gonna be playing tomorrow and
this is gonna be happening but that it
was it was meant to happen it was such a
smooth mechanic and talking about
getting used to it I was pre aiming
quite a bit but as you got used to it
the hip fire on a lot of these weapons
is actually incredibly accurate so if
anything you're gonna find yourself hip
firing a lot more than adsing when
you're playing this game mode again my
leaning towards the mouse Cuba players
who are more used to not I think you're
centering it's just you're centering
considering I like a lot I've played
tournaments 3p on call yeah we had it
back in the day like I've been grinded
3p Call of Duty it's actually a lot of
fun we used to have search and short
tournaments all the time I think these
guys are having a lot of fun with it I
mean you can see like it's a completely
different play style where did you come
from hit you surprised yeah he's not
happy with that for sure but it's
absolutely incredible another thing you
get a different kind of fov feel for the
map as well yeah you see things in a
different kind of scope and bigger
picture here I'm kind of curious to see
what things look like in terms of like
hanging from Ledges from third person
and how that kind of works like they put
in so much work into the game like IW I
see you you want us to see everything
yeah that's kind of what three PS4 like
Clint that's a really good point like
with your operator like I want to see
that Swagger well I miss like it was a
simple thing but back in back in
blackout like in the first iteration of
the VR you had like these emotes that
you could do like a hula hoop or
something that would go off to third
person and I kind of missed that going
forward because I like to see if I get
this really cool operator I want to see
it more but like to your point seeing
the character animations and stuff like
they just look God like like it looks it
does look so so good it looks so good
and not to mention the sneak peeks that
we've got from like the Vault and from
what operators are gonna be coming off
of beta like they they look incredible
but they look so so freaking good so to
that point I am very very excited to see
once the game releases the type of
operators we're going to get heading
forward I need vacation Maven that's
what I called it yeah it's like a
Hawaiian shirt with a bald guy with like
a little bit of uh uh Sante lotion on
his nose and I always call it a vacation
Maven I'm gonna need that back I'm not
gonna lie I might have to whip out my
PlayStation again because that only skin
like he was yeah
I'm fine that would look into a person
yeah like insane that skin was doing the
walk and everything oh my gosh in both
hands like I want to reenact that live
in game it'd be absolutely incredible I
mean this is already looking so much fun
I remember playing this yesterday I got
in a Lobby a lobby with Aiden and uh
yeah that was really rough I was
actually playing on cloaksi's uh station
and I've definitely given him a bad name
he said that uh yeah Aiden had a
personal Vendetta I did I mean this guy
he was he really doesn't like me he
really doesn't
um but you know it was it was so he
doesn't like cloves
he's probably like who is this poppy
coaxy for sure uh but pretty exceptional
stuff and we can see a lot of the the
ABS here look at Tommy's face right now
like he's just got this he had this
little like little smirking smile on his
face like you could just tell people are
having fun and that's what this is all
about it's awesome oh Tommy was having
fun he was sitting there capturing C
just like jumping up and down with this
camera sort of angled downstairs he's
like oh yeah he's like I played this
before he said having fun man absolutely
frying it wouldn't be a Nick cam if his
face wasn't it yeah like when I went I
walked through all these setups I saw
the cameras were in the right spot how
is it still only half his face like he
moved it he had to have He adjusted the
classic thing looks is it's the full
heads the eyebrows in the forehead going
strong always uh you probably talked
about this a little bit but just while
it's on screens I gotta say the
Aesthetics of this game looks so good
and and in terms of third person as well
being able to see it all encapsulated as
well as your of course skin and your
operator that you're looking at all
right all right and so is the gameplay
here from Nick mutts yeah it really is
we're not sweet the color the color I'm
loving but he's got the gunny on point
right now and it works absolutely
forehead Cam and all just Friar and he's
already there in up the lobby he was
pushing up and he was turning left but
he had his camera angled behind him saw
that jumped backwards and absolutely so
you know Nick I mean he's got a history
of third person so how are you guys
feeling about the angles we're seeing
Nick do it a little bit here and just
kind of shimming and making sure he can
see what is behind the corner how he
feeling about that for third person I
mean he's a cut about the rest when it
comes to this like he's super used to it
he's won championships on 3p so uh he's
he's having a blast I mean he's played a
lot of Call of Duty as well so it's like
the best he is yeah but no I I think
there is definitely uh there's a
learning curve to it if you haven't
really played it yeah he has a lot of
experience with this type of camera this
type of Gunplay and I I think you're
seeing that absolutely right now this
this is the use movement with the Crouch
of the block he's a little disappointed
because the nade that takes him out but
he was tearing the lobby apart yeah it
makes it look way too easy I'm not gonna
lie he makes me feel like he looks a lot
more natural right yeah he does even
even some of the povs we went to I think
you could tell they've been playing a
little bit but his looks a bit different
without question
oh
it's gonna be a rough one
he's not happy about that absolutely
insane stuff though it looks absolutely
incredible as well
yeah he's fine he's absolutely fine
that's your teammate that's your
teammate that's what I always struggle
with when I'm playing something for the
first time Alia yeah no I did that
yesterday I'm shooting at teammates
locking on TVs all the time when it's
like new maps like new game I don't know
I always you guys need to dial it in
what do you mean listen especially if
you're not in comms either like you
don't know the routes on the map yet
like if you run into something you don't
see that name
I'm pretty confident if you put the time
in yeah what's up you would have had a
better professional career than Anne
yeah like I don't even think I'd have
them for the time and honestly
bro I can't understand you guys
I used to always mess with them I
skipped College
like ants in trouble we're gonna take a
look at a replay now uh Nick was
absolutely popping off in 3p uh we know
he's got the experience with us check
out the Elgato replay yeah this guy
obviously has been here before but of
course on a new game here Modern Warfare
too looking amazing I'm pretty sure this
part he does snap off I thought that
might have been the part where he died I
was gonna say surely not but just really
really seamless gameplay from Nick Merks
and it's something to expect from him
for the future the fact that he's
getting it down already brand new game
brand new maps I mean it's pretty clean
isn't it yeah he was trying and he
wasn't even using right hand Advantage
sir
that's where I always struggle with is
that toggle between shoulders like
it I mean it's very natural when you
play more but like At first I'm not very
I just end up like looking over one
shoulder basically
yeah I just mean I always look at the
right side it's so tough left side I
always get gunned oh my god oh I'm
saying he got a couple hits
is that a shotgun
uh
looks like a shotgun the shotgun looked
disgusting I was watching Tim use it
earlier
shotguns that's crazy yeah I probably
need one to be honest
I probably need one for sure what do you
guys think of the perks as well
obviously the perk actually talks about
that with the devs earlier on the desk
and we saw that pop up a few times now
on the screen but obviously having to
earn the perks and and kind of produce
the goods and secure those as you're
playing it's pretty cool too yeah we'll
see uh what people play around when it
comes to you know the perk setups you
can create your own but they also have
different like classes you can be a
support player Clinton was mentioning it
earlier uh you know it could be a
sentinel Josie I was talking about that
so uh there's different categories I
think most people will just like create
their own run uh some of the historics
that we have EOD which is back
paddle-hearted you can stay away from
stuns nades uh and then dead silence is
a field upgrade I know everybody's
always talking about it's bedtime's in
the game well yes it is it's a field
upgrade so you can still have that while
you pick your additional perks and as
the game goes on you'll get more so
you're just gonna feel like a super
soldier stuff yeah it's interesting it's
just it's different we're gonna see how
it plays out but it seems I just like
the concept of talking and earning
things I do so
it's satisfying we get kills yeah it
goes on you get an extra perk like we've
had like something similar before back
in Ghost with the specialist and you
felt unreal as you started to unlock
some of the other perks so I'm excited
to see how these guys play around with
them all right all right Papa I know
father of two here he comes dominating
the lobby
I love seeing a sub in his hand I mean
this is this is probably one of the
better Pony views we're gonna get as
he's just looking to be a menace right
now he's the 74u yeah version of the AK
yeah he is oh yes oh dude oh my goodness
oh my goodness I forget is these guys
grind they're gonna start unlocking more
weapons so yeah yeah we haven't seen
this yet we've seen Fenix we've seen uh
the hurricane that was this hurricane we
have not seen the 74u on the stream oh
there you kind of get to see the the
don't have to die from uh the third
person POV which I still think that's
what I'm appreciating the most about
this is just seeing some of the
animations from the 3p it just yeah I
don't know it's a different Beast nice
to see I just want to see somebody
dolphin diving third person down an
escalator I'm still with that you can
turn around midnight yeah 360. yeah so
like people are going to be getting
torqued on just yeah definitely off for
sure I mean the 360 down in Escalade is
going to be pretty nasty yeah Grim app
it's got some Turf speaking of I I want
to know how you guys feel so far about
competitive play I mean we've got some
incredible Pros or x-pros on our screens
as well I mean you know so far so good
how are you feeling about the pacing how
these guys are playing great these guys
are playing great uh but I think uh you
know the main things are like going into
it from a competitive aspect is like the
map switch which the maps are pretty
good yeah Auto looks great and we've
only seen them yeah it's like impossible
for you to say yeah just kind of spend
more time on the maps feels good like
for me when I sit down like the first
thing that I look at is like the Gunplay
how does it feel yeah and it felt great
like the movement feels good you got
some uh you know extra mechanics you get
good gun play and movement it's like
everything else is kind of it will be
all right if it's fun to play yeah so I
I think so far like it's w see and I'm
on the other end of that Spectrum I'll
look at the maps right away like I'll go
through my attachment and like all right
I'll try this one out but really when I
first load into the game right away I'm
looking at the map layout that's kind of
like my forte and I will say the Mexican
Village that map I love that map and
like a competitive aspect it gave me a
little bit of like a three lane as well
as the paintball map that had uh the
middle section of chaos I was talking
about how there was the underground
passageways it's giving again like a
three-lane hybrid so with the maps that
we are given to play with on this Alpha
test I am looking forward to the game
release I'm looking forward because for
competitive side of things at least my
personal opinion things are looking
right so amazing stuff I love to hear
that and I'll tell you what I love to
hear from some other people in this
amazing Arena we've seen a ton of action
so far of course our third person mode
as well but it's time to toss it on down
right now to Gina darling and Stephanie
to give us an update on how things are
on the floor and what is going on over
there hi Stephanie and welcome back now
listen we've heard it teased a couple
times today raids are coming to Call of
Duty now would you mind like the people
at home know what they can expect for
this new experience in Modern Warfare 2.
thank you Gina it's so exciting I feel
like I have been able to announce so
much cool stuff today so this is sort of
the cherry on top of the Sunday for an
awesome stack of all of the Call of Duty
content that's coming your way this year
but raids in all new experience
different gameplay than we've ever
really brought to fans and and this mode
is ultimately all about communication
and coordination the things that you
expect from a raid we're actually going
to be looking at episodic missions all
of them sort of a couple hours in length
starting with season one and the launch
of Modern Warfare 2 and then having that
narrative which will actually you know
play in with the campaign continue to
play out across every chapter
exciting oh I'm so hyped for this now
can we get a little bit more detail on
the gameplay itself
yeah so we're looking at three person
teams and like I said this is all sort
of a mix of combat of narrative and
puzzles so those sort of core mechanics
of what we love know and love from from
raids are coming to Call of Duty and
that style and like I said I think the
way that the narrative will continue to
evolve seasonally across each encounter
in each mission
stoked for everybody to get a chance to
see these now listen as a long time Call
of Duty player lined up during midnight
so many times and still stop at the Best
Buy shout out to the mom and pop shops
too uh and still streaming Call of Duty
to this day this gets me so hyped so
please let me know how and when can we
dive into raids right so this is going
to come with the launch of season one so
same dates you're looking at for war
zone 2.0 this will be November 16th
season one kicks off for Modern Warfare
2 and um I think it's going to be
somewhere in the middle of season one
actually so
awesome you heard it guys thank you so
much and let's go back to the desk
thank you so much Gina and Stephanie and
I'm really excited about everything that
is coming in I just feel like the more
the day goes on the more we're getting
the the more reveals are coming I mean
there is so much to unpack here isn't it
it's just listen we I've been a part of
a ton of these launch events or
premieres and you know we've shown uh
usually it's been like a multiplayer
reveal or maybe we'll show off like a
campaign or something never I don't know
how to describe it other than like it
feels like we're in this sort of like
meta verse yeah with with Warzone mobile
with Warzone 2 with multiplayer coming
from Modern Warfare two it's just
everything it's just giant sandbox of so
much cool Call of Duty [ __ ] that I love
it yeah absolutely I mean you know it
really is an experience I feel like
Modern Warfare 2 is bringing absolutely
everything to the table or on the other
side of things there is something for
everyone right I mean we're getting DMZ
we've got ground war coming on our
screen in just a
moment's face off I mean third person
the list is absolutely endless so the
fact that there's so many Call of Duty
fans that love something specific about
Cod they have something to sink their
teeth into here alley and it's yeah it's
incredible it's a good looking man it's
like an amusement park no you're good I
I need you to let you shoot your shot I
got distracted I'm so sorry
I I hope he sees it later I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry for yesterday painting your
name and I was just saying it's like an
amusement park of Call of Duty right
there's just so much going on and like
we haven't even scratched the surface of
it like there's still so much to be
played we're heading into ground war
we're gonna see tanks we're gonna see
the vehicles like so much water this is
that's what I've been wanting to see is
the boats wow so they're going out
they're going fishing they're going out
they got the full Squad in there it
looks like I would not want to run into
these guys uh we played some Invasion oh
it's Stone Mountain I'm not surprised
I'm not shocked to see that dude he's
he's ready to get tactical with the
ships these guys got okay I was gonna
say he's running around with a pistol
got that before in hand Zuma here so you
know he's twisted
nah he's having a blast it's been
amazing to see Tommy uh it will Zumba
success in recent months but yeah he's
got the gun he's still it's cool to see
him out here competing playing having
some fun but
I this is like what kind of like a
middle ground between like your your war
zone and your multiplayer experience for
those of you that haven't like messed
around ground war it's just giant
sandbox you're gonna see it all
very very different from your 6v6 type
Maps that's for sure yeah so with a
little bit of an eject objective in this
one uh different than Invasion oh that's
a bathroom whatever
and everyone's in here just trying to
like you just come in here you pull out
a sniper pull an AR SMG drive all the
vehicles like full experience of Call of
Duty can be had here around more yeah
that is very very true actually it
really does kind of remind me of wars
and I don't know whether that's just
because Aiden's on my screen or whether
it's just because obviously this is a
massive map but it really is almost like
a little bit of a warm-up and a little
taste it into what Warzone is and it's
yeah the fact that you can get that in
Modern Warfare 2 you can kind of come
out of multiplayer Chuck on ground war
and just get straight into things here
as well which oh God go on that would
have been so sick we want to see a
sniper shot right from the top there
well I was kind of curious if he was
trying
dead shots yeah let's see a swim let's
see some swimming I mean this is the
breaststroke the breaststroke the sniper
it was just the skull oh yeah no yeah
wow he is swimming fast I think compared
to Michael Phelps uh due to my long arms
and very athletic legs
he's either I wasn't sure if he was
drowning or getting beamed oh
that could be a little bit of both hold
it fine
I love how the movement with Aiden like
you can tell he's playing it like
Warzone like when we were first watching
him like his busting doors open looking
for looking at the ground looking for
high ground and so I think that's like
it's so interesting to differentiate the
play Styles between all the players and
creators that we have here
yeah it's very interesting and you can
see right now he's just obviously
selecting his Loadout here and it's
something we also got into earlier on
but ground wall what kind of Loadout do
you want obviously it's very different
from multiplayer it's so much bigger you
know over what you're thinking you gotta
have like you gotta have an AR with it
you saw he just put a bigger he just hit
himself with a forehead with that name I
believe oh oh it happens to the bass
ever said it happens to the best of us
not me but it happened I love that you
can select your smile as well uh but
yeah uh you're gonna run You're Gonna
Want like a sniper and Overkill oh
yeah this this boom uh selection is huge
by the way that is such an interesting
yeah cool kind of push there into ground
war listen this is what I'm doing all
day if I'm not in the back sniping
groundwater like I'm in a tank hey look
how funny this guy's just driving around
just blasting people
nothing but Vibes what song do you think
he's got playing in the tank that is a
good question
yeah I would say it was like AC DC
usually in the trailers I feel like
there's there's usually some some
oh he's trying to Rock It wait Drive the
tank in the water I want to see what
happens I would love to see that please
what what's the one is it the ATV that's
like can do both it's like amphibious
right
I believe they talked about I think it
might be able to show it there are some
Vehicles
some James Bond stuff they said they
sink slow no
I want to see a tank sink slow I know
it's kind of cool
diving and by the way is it it's kind of
cool to see people
and just like they're in the desert when
you come out a game you see the view
like this it just blows my mind that
they were able to set this up yeah yeah
just those grinding yeah they're pretty
in a ground or queuing up it's been
absolutely amazing all day man you could
hear he's getting loud passionate
they're ready man oh yeah there's been a
fair amount of trash off just I mean a
lot of these guys know each other
they're in the in the same Lobby he's
just screaming
on a giant belly
oh I was looking away back behind us I
didn't even see it it was still mounting
a giant helicopter like three other
players
here we go yeah it's kind of curious how
much You Gotta Lose yeah that's what I'm
saying I was playing I know I literally
was like how and I was leading my
channel
maybe it's no lead I think it's one of
those things like just different sniper
he's kind of used to it dude what's he
gonna feel for you here we go yeah well
up close and like you know medium range
I was trying to say from range it just
felt it felt harder
it's gonna take some time to get used to
take a little bit I mean I'm kind of all
for that I'm kind of hoping at least
just from the amount of like Warzone I
played I know I know we're in
groundwater right now but like you're
really long range stuff I'm hoping with
a reduction in attachments like this oh
yeah what are you talking on here this
looks awesome yeah what sort of sniper
purchase this is like a chopper gun this
looks lit
and you can oh wow you can really walk
around geez that's so cool that's
actually really cool what if the back is
open I need you to hit it oh God I have
the commentary get out two one
two of them did it though look noisy oh
but I hope like with the reduction in
the attachments it's a little bit harder
like you know we've gotten so used to
being able to just beam someone at 200
meters yeah if there's a little bit more
of a challenge to it yeah a little bit
more of a skill factor coming in oh
someone saved his life guardian angel
I think I really do feel like the way
that you know this game plays so far the
pacing everything about it honestly the
skill Gap I feel like is there I feel
like we're gonna see that a lot all
right the guys thigh is no longer there
just ripped off of the 50 cal all right
he was just moving with the sniper in
his hand by the way like really quick
Speed Demon so he changed the attachment
for sure
oh oh hey Clark what's up buddy
I mean number one fan
I ordered your merch and I wear your
shirt every other day
they've got some pizzas in the
background so they're delivering your
hand delivering pizzas oh are they okay
because I'm looking forward to that wow
whatever my next break is I'm throwing
back an entire I hope they're getting
napkins yeah I'm not gonna lie get
having pizza watching some gameplay on
this desk right now is a Vibe yeah I
mean when I see right now is I see Call
of Duty I see a bunch of strippers I see
Mountain Dews I mean it's just literally
opening nothing brings me back to being
18 right now we're waiting in line for
the game go home like I'm taking school
off tomorrow like sorry I can't go
grandma
I'm sick yeah
gotta put that temperature at the
moments are on the radiator make sure
that's the highest it can be
oh there it is
ah hit Parker
wow oh he is just flying wow he said I'm
getting this one it is Pam
kamashi Bond oh
oh dude he's gonna rip in there he's
been doing this for a while oh
he got one though from the channel
he's so happy
oh I can see it now Clinton all the 360
Snipes off of that Chopper oh yeah and
the montages like it's gonna it's like
what you know those moves they do offer
like the diving board like in the
Olympics right yeah triple calcium
40 back flip into a snipe yep okay look
the dev said that they wanted fun and
that sounds pretty dumb oh my God just
happened there
was that bread
I don't know I think it was bread no no
I might need a replay
oh we got a demon Lobby it's all pitbull
in here
Jack's getting popped I saw miles
actually getting pretty Diffy in a Lobby
against Biffle oh yes he was told that's
who we needed a 1v1 before
Oh there's the pizza that looks glorious
of course Jack
oh my mouth is literally watering just
thinking about pizza
go ask Jack for some I could eat it
every meal I'll be honest with you I
really could oh is he bring it he's
bringing the sniper out yeah he switched
to him he was like you know what let's
do it if you can't beat him join him
I want to know who's winning right now
unfortunately I think I think it's cam
is oh oh they are winning there I can
see just the top of the 45-49 winning
there we go
I need a loser's point of view now to
see this car I've not used this guy this
looks like okay oh I'm confused is
somebody actually driving though I
thought it was like I thought it was a
spawn Chopper
I don't know but courage is hello hey
how are we doing sir looking very dapper
collecting swans is just sick I'm not
gonna get you stuff I just like the uh
you know in older games you know you
pick your spot yeah sort of appear there
but now like the whatever you call it
like the
but I like that a lot thank you a lot
for saving my brain it was struggling
because it eats Pizza mine struggles on
the reg yeah yeah so don't worry uh yeah
no I think it is really really cool uh
to see that I think it just suits
Grandma honestly it really does do
ground one I think in terms of objective
work you can have a huge map here and
you have to cover so many different
areas the fact that you can uh choose
your spawn spot is pretty sick I love it
I I think myth hybrided his pistol to
like an SMG whenever he switches to that
look at it because that was the auto
right there's a there's an auto version
of yeah pistol and he has it on but he
has like a stalker nice he's got it
pretty low loaded up you see attachments
oh yeah you can really make it your own
yeah
you can make an hour into an SMG I mean
we've been saying it just do a lot with
the pistol pistol
maybe that same SMG pistol into an AR
who knows so I've just looked at the
kill feed and Sim symphony is on the
other team so perfect that's exactly why
I need to sniper that'll bring me a
whole lot of Happiness oh that's a tank
that was Optics like that getting
plucked I want to see that drill charge
being thrown on the ground and a tank
running out of here we saw it in the
trailer behind you it's the one like
through the roof no like there's one you
put on the ground well yeah you do it
through the wall as well I think it'll
just I really want to see the uh okay oh
he's popping off now floating nade I
want to see so bad the floating uh mine
oh there's a lot of red arrows over
there yeah wow that looks so beautiful
that's a whole map yeah
in color as well it looks great
Curry's missile up he's calling
everything in
doesn't see anyone there we go
bigger inside unfortunately not able to
hit it but the fact is myth take it over
the lobby snipe looking hot
I mean we've seen everything so far in
this we've seen vehicle combat Ariel
crazy gunfights in buildings cloak was
just chilling inside of a tower
everybody your specific taste to Call of
Duty you can find in ground war
yeah it's a little bit of everything
just fun it's just fun you can look a
lot of the settings right now you know
because it's never their fault it's a
settings problem so I think we're on the
hunt for what's wrong right now I love
going through this it's just my favorite
thing in the world just making sure
everything's exactly how I need it and
you never thought it could be a thumbs
no oh no no I just really like tinkering
with it oh yeah but do I blame it when I
have failures yes I do a lot of it yeah
it's really my fault oh dude to be
honest I understand that
got a lot of red up there right now wait
so you can spawn in a vehicle you see
that that's dope yeah yeah it says full
so I guess he's waiting for somebody to
be board that's sweet what noticing
right somebody somebody get knocked out
of it yeah I wonder if you can spawn in
a chopper in the helicopter I I believe
we're gonna be tossing to the floor soon
I'll tell you I'm gonna see if in the
three minutes I'm off camera if I can
eat an entire Pizza I'm gonna try to I
would like to know if you could bring me
some yeah I'm gonna try and find it
that's fine
this is Bully out here these guys are
all grinding we're gonna get to see some
war zone later today it's gonna be epic
I'll tell you what folks we're just
about done here with watching this
groundwater gameplay we're gonna toss it
on down to the main stage to find out
who Jess has gone who she's gonna be
talking to you just up to you
thank you so much Lottie yeah I'm
actually here with one of my favorite
streamers swisham and how are you
enjoying yourself here at COD next I
mean you're here among 200 of your
fellow streamers playing what I can only
imagine is your favorite game how does
that feel
um honestly the experience so far it's
been amazing like I honestly I kind of
put into words like the feeling to be
here right now playing MW2 and getting
all the first looks like
and you can't have anything better you
know
um so far like I'm loving it like I feel
like a little kid on Christmas like
everything like the aspect of all you
know everything in the game right now
with multiplayer it feels so good so
smooth
um I just want to keep playing this I
don't want to go back to Caldera right
now well we've had a little taste now of
you know 66 ground war different Maps
different modes kind of what's your main
takeaway here from this game
um honestly I'm loving third person
right now it's like honestly I didn't
know if I was gonna like it or not
because you know we've never had third
person you know with the past pod but um
honestly I'm living in a lot and I love
the maps everything you know is really
good right now and it's feeling you know
smooth all right and final question I
mean what is next for you and your
streaming your content
um MW2 grind that's all I'm looking
forward to can't wait that makes perfect
sense well thank you so much and uh best
of luck have fun out there Lottie babe
back on over to you
thank you so much Jess and you can see
right now there is so much happening
behind us all the creators you see the
ring lights for days uh so much Modern
Warfare 2 being played but my name is
long I'm on the desk I'm drawn by Maven
uh but I also do have two very special
people to talk about Modern Warfare 2
and what it took to make it look so damn
glorious we've got Mark and Joel joining
us and guys I mean Studio animation
director and we've got studio art
director here I gotta say first and
foremost this game is stunning like it
is absolutely beautiful the colors are
incredible yes I just want to dive in
IRL to be perfectly honest it's not just
Brown it's not just it has some color I
promise I didn't joke about that already
multiple times today but no seriously
it's like it's there's been a lot of
like Ryan Brown sometimes there are many
Hues we got our huge art out I looked
that in there it looks vibrant I'm
loving it it's just it just feel it
feels good when you're out there slaying
it looks absolutely incredible I'm so
excited to dive deeper into that but
Folks at home if you didn't already know
we've got an epic giveaway for my
friends at jacklings and each Jack Link
supply drop includes a brand new copy of
Modern Warfare on the platform of your
choice delicious Jack Link's limited
edition products brand new epic in-game
items from Jack Links so if you want to
find out more check this out
looking for an epic way to celebrate the
launch of Modern Warfare 2 Jack Links
has got you covered giving you the
chance to win the ultimate Modern
Warfare 2 supply drop keep an eye out
during the broadcast for the Jack Link
Sasquatch to appear on screen if you see
it grab your phone and scan the QR code
following the prompts to qualify for
entries tune in to Call of Duty next
Squad up with Sasquatch and level up for
the ultimate viewing experience courtesy
of Jack Links terms and conditions apply
foreign
scratch on the screen throughout the
show scan that QR code and enter all
your information for a chance to win and
trust me you certainly want to but back
to it though of course Modern Warfare 2
is when I'm good as a Sasquatch though
right it's hard to low cap Sasquatch to
be honest people might honestly get that
confused with you yeah yeah I'll be
really good is that there is that
problem I'm so sorry you can throw the
razors out
I'll tell you what isn't a problem is
the color palette on this game is
absolutely stunning you know I looked at
Mercado earlier on and I was just flawed
by how good it looks what does it take
to make a map you know how from scratch
you're looking at the color schemes
you're looking at what you want to put
in the details it's very finely detailed
and I think that makes people really
want to dive into the game and start
grinding it well I think like it's it's
important to create an immersive
environment go out and capture reality
but you know at the end of the day it's
all the details and what's funny about
making stuff like this is it's about
what you leave out
you know the real world doesn't isn't
completely cluttered all the time it's
very you know kind of uh understated and
things like that so uh kind of holding
people back sometimes because they want
to keep going and you know uh especially
in a game Space you know that's
unfortunately paying attention and then
AI putting AI in there and having a
living world member I mean that's just
insane the AI part is something that
blows my mind I think it really brings
such an incredible aspect of that
realism you know that realistic effect
that you guys are trying to achieve here
in Modern Warfare 2 and in COD games in
general what does it take to make that
happen oh my
um well it takes a lot of like just
research and a reference that we use
like all of us are mad uh action movie
fans and
cartoon anime and all that stuff that's
the Action Sign yeah but when you have
to have that authenticity where we we
deal with our uh our military advisors
uh all different branches of the
military
um we ask them questions all the time
we're always asking hey would you do it
like this or would you do it like that
um they most of the time they'll say
yeah no I wouldn't do it like that
that's that's Hollywood yeah but but
they know that it's an entertainment
product so they they definitely you know
are in it to win it always giving us the
advice that we need plus uh the extra
you know pointers in here and there then
we bring them into the mocap stage yeah
uh get them suited up you know a lot of
them never never been in anything like
that you know they're in spandex you
know with the dots and stuff big tough
guys you know
um so but when that once they get going
I mean it it's amazing when you see a
lot of the movements that they do you
know it's like wow man that's all oh
that's gonna look good in the game yeah
uh so yeah it's just a lot of like
effort and and uh and Magic that goes
into it more can I go back on this all
the time it's
what you're looking for also is in the
performance is the human mistakes yeah
you know when people get scared when AI
gets scared how do they react when a
soldier like you know sometimes these
all these Consultants do things
perfectly right right and they they
rehearse it it's muscle memory but you
want those moments where they're making
mistakes and they don't imperfection
perfectly imperfections yeah well I feel
like the hard part at least from the
outside looking in is just like finding
that fine line between realism and the
fun because yeah I play games so I'm not
gonna call it any other games but like
they try to have like a sometimes like a
realistic weighted movement to it that
to me is just not as fun like I want
more Arcadia sometimes because that's
just we're playing a game at the end of
the day it's a fine line it's got to be
very tricky you can't go too overboard
and you know WrestleMania or anything
like that and you can't go to you know
uh I don't know whatever it's contrast
we see that I mean with the only skin we
saw earlier the way that you know the
guy was walking the operate we having
that fun that's exciting
[Music]
two operators like Oni and having these
exclusive skins that you're able to put
on and it changes the whole character
that you are embodying in the game and
that's that's where the fun aspect comes
in but you do have people who want to
stay true they want that realistic
absolutely kind of approaching feel to
the game and I think the balance is
really difficult but something so far
we've seen is that you guys have done
that so so well where does the decision
making of the AI coming I know the
intuitive creative part of the AI is so
important to you guys and having them
making those decisions and and become
actually a vital aspect of in-game play
how does that work well that's a balance
between uh the programmers and the
animators we want them to do everything
yeah have them run around but then
they're cooking a meal you know Jeff and
Joe were like I don't know we don't need
it like that you know can you guys
switch it this way so there's a lot of
balance between design code and
animation the art so how many times do
we go back and forth on Silhouettes and
right because you need you want the AI
to
like be identifiable right in that when
you mix it up you know you need to guess
it's a little difficult you know but
it's a balance between those that Triad
of of design code and animation where we
we have our vision in our head and we
just have to come come together and
compromise yeah well how much how much I
guess
I feel like adding like the third person
kind of put a spotlight on you from an
animation standpoint because we've all
seen like when you're in first person
you don't see a lot of animations you do
but like when you're fighting somebody
online like every now and then the
animation can be janky due to whatever
yeah yeah you're playing on the internet
but like when you have like the 3p like
you Ray it is a spotlight directly on
the animations of the character the the
animation department and and programming
went to town right and and it's so
awesome to see it like uh uh our
animation director uh at the studio it
was Ferris I was just talking to him
today about it um but it's uh it's
really awesome so I was just sitting
down here on the on the floor watching
it a few minutes ago I was like wow man
that's it looks so good
and all the stuff that goes on without
the way that you mantle on things that
you know you've got a nice uh system
where the the feet are falling on the
terrain the proper way on staircases and
things just it it's it's uh I don't know
it's just awesome it makes the
characters look great
I see someone else doing it yeah that
makes you feel even more there's a power
fantasy scene I'm seeing it happen
that's all I can think about in the 3p
part was like they just the character
animations they look so they they
knocked it out of the park that's
awesome hey I gotta ask you just that
you know a personal nerdy question for
me but I love finishing moves I think
they're so sick how does that get
created you know what's the magic behind
finishing moves they actually played out
live do you guys have to do it we do wow
so cool we we don't do them ourselves it
wasn't me in in the suit uh we go get uh
stunt stunt people and then uh we kind
of map it out first draw sketches you
know like hey maybe it's like do like
this do like that we get them on stage
and then we kind of like just go through
it together you know to kind of uh just
bring that that action in that field
that same thing that you just felt yes
we did it last project this time we like
we need to update so yeah violence and
aggression
gonna put pressure on both of you if
this isn't in yet so listen this is
going back to we were talking about the
fact that
one thing that's tough with first person
is when you get Cooperators right you
don't you don't see them as much and
like finishing moves is one where you do
but like going back this is back like
blackout but like when you would do
there were different like emotes you
could use where you would like dance and
you'd have the hula hoop and stuff like
that so you'd kind of sear up there more
you could show off you could do a lot of
taunting type things is that in that or
can you add it for me
I feel like we we get that we get that
out with
a wide like a big breath of finishing
moves yeah I think that's where you you
really get to see a case that yeah
you weren't asking if we have emotes
right well no no I guess I guess more
like I'm trying to think back there was
one where I could do like a hula hoop or
like goofy kind of stuff you could do to
like show off and I just like I guess I
like to see my operator push them more
for sure and you guys have put so much
work into the animation I want to see my
guy dance you know I want to get down
and nasty it's an evolving system you
get to see what happens right now we're
so focused on this is a big game oh yeah
if I look tired it's well if I don't
look tired it's because the makeup
artists here are really good right but
yeah there's a lot going on but yeah
we've got a long oh yeah there's a lot
of Road left in front of us too keep me
in mind that I want a bald character
that can can move a little bit all right
easy that's why if we need to get me
we've got you if we need to get me in
I'm gonna call it dancing motion
captions
I can definitely attest that you don't
want to get him in
yeah that could be a little bit of an
error there it could be it might be the
goofiest one we've seen so far and I'm
done I'm kind of down for the goofy part
of it that's for sure bro I think that's
what you guys could have to
look it's my job to balance the desk out
here and I got to talk about something
very very exciting and Mark I want to
know a little bit more about the shoe
surgeon what have you been cooking up
for us here hey shout out to Super Shoe
surgeon
um we all at a lot of us at the at the
organization we're shoe head right so
this thing is
um but we're really excited to uh work
with a huge name in the sticker World
which is the shoe surgeon they made two
incredible shoes for us uh based off of
the uh uh the brand of Modern Warfare
okay two uh with uh oh look at that look
at that wow so uh this is actually all
unique uh for these two shoes one of
them is for the Modern Warfare brand the
other one is for almazara the the big
map uh yeah and it's uh a lot of desert
tones it just is really really really
awesome it's iconic iconic greens and
all that you know inspired by you know
from our mods were in all the materials
these look awesome and I also think I
need to get some tattoos and they both
have uh Gilly snap-ons too like like you
know some people don't even know yeah
like you don't know nothing about these
you're gonna put your Ensemble together
right like that when you go out on the
town right ghillie suit together clip
them on there and you're set to go I
love it I love it but if you want to be
one of the six lucky people uh to win a
pair uh maybe maybe five because you
know I might get one you know you know
uh you need to uh follow Call of Duty
okay uh then you need to tweet uh uh
hashtag codnex and hashtag sweepstakes
or you can scan the the QR code there
and uh enter the win it's as easy as
that folks absolutely incredible I gotta
say I really want to cop that desert
color pair I went I want the the bottom
oh I like that the iconic green yeah I'm
wearing it today I've got to say it
would pretty it looked pretty good with
what I'm wearing right now did you see
Joanna's pants though I did I mean who
didn't I mean absolutely icons
everywhere
including on the stage though it's right
now time to toss down to beef Mommy and
see what she's cooking up right down
there with the content creators
wow I'm ready to have another slice of
that action here in Warzone mobile did
you like that yeah Little Caesars right
here we're ready for another round of
gameplay here amazing amazing amazing
amazing ready for another slice of
action me too me too so yeah you know
only in Call of Duty war zone mobile can
you have the type of intense you know up
to 120 player real action so let's get
back on in and see what we have going on
today
well you can already see it it's after
the turns of what we've seen here so far
because so far it's been absolutely
crazy it's been Warzone 2.0 it's been
Modern Warfare 2 and now we're going
back in here we're going back to mobile
and now I'm pretty sure a lot of you
guys at home are really interested to
see what is happening with our streamers
that we have here today and if you don't
have it yet comment down below what were
your favorite moments here yet again
because we've had so many things
happening already
incredible incredible
now and you know one of the things that
we wanted to uh wanted to make sure we
do is go over let's talk to some of the
talent talk to some of our friends see
what's going on why don't we head over
there and another incredible round of
War Zone Battle Royale comes to this and
now it feels like such a great time and
now we're I'm really excited to go and
move around especially with my little
box I wonder if all of our streamers
playing today wants a slice of this
pizza because obviously we've been
eating this the whole day that's the
reason why we have so much energy and
not only that it's absolutely delicious
but we are heading on over to our
streamers right now I think we're going
to take a look at Hawk's Nest and Bobby
plays we're taking a look at what
they're doing right now and it looks
like here in the action let's see if
they kind of want to slice but obviously
they are very busy when it comes to the
gameplay right now see you can see the
calms they're just so into it right now
the focus Bobby and Hawks they don't
even know what's going on or outside
them they have a camera they have a
pizza box oh maybe if they smell the
pizza they'll want some huh would you
like a slice are you hungry yeah
actually very hungry maybe we can help
them out later on with a slice of pizza
we can be your personal Pizza holder but
we're moving on right now here to Bobby
I kind of want to ask him so far you're
just walking inside you're chilling so
where are you guys right now and what's
happening so far
oh there's a guy right ahead of us I'm
gonna go ahead and die to him wait no I
killed him we're chilling you know we're
just dominating we obliterated Godly
earlier and he didn't really stand a
chance Noah managed Town campus wait
there's yeah there's multiple people
multiple directions oh my God I'm
probably dead I'm I'm concussed I'm uh
okay we're gonna get back to you later
on you guys Focus over there I don't
want y'all tonight just because of us oh
and speaking of Bobby's gonna be headed
on into the gulag but you know what it's
okay it's fun I love these gameplays
happening right now so so far how are
you feeling right now Matt like you're
seeing all the gameplay it's been crazy
here so far
great question you know feeling really
good feeling really good we still have
so much longer to go in terms of
development for right now you know we
know people are loving the game we know
people are excited to get in there and
more than anything else at this point we
want to make sure the moment-to-moment
action is just good for us right now
moment-to-moment action and you know the
other thing that's worth touching on a
little bit is cross progression really
breaking down what that means a little
bit absolutely that cross progression if
you are at home if you're playing war
zone 2.0 if you're playing Modern
Warfare 2 that progression that you have
over there it can transfer over into
Warzone mobile where if you want to
grind for the battle pass you can do so
at the tip of your fingers yeah that's
right if you have things going down at
home you can definitely bring it down
into wherever you are if you're on the
car you can grind for it so again so
many new things and for me I think it's
such a revolutionary thing for this to
happen yeah exactly you know we were
talking the other day around like well
what does that mean if I'm a player
cross progression how does that benefit
me and there are there really are a
handful of experiences we think are just
made better by cross progression so I
want to talk about those just for a
little bit the first one is let's say
I'm playing for you know a couple days
we have some new functional weapons that
are unlocked if I'm playing on Console
or PC or mobile and have a long session
maybe I you know do pretty well then I
unlock that functional weapon that time
investment that you just made that now
carries over to all the other platforms
regardless of where it happens on so
think about the time save there exactly
not just that you're interconnected I
mean we like to say it again and again
because it's just a revolutionary thing
to have but I know you have something
else in mind because you have so much
new features here and we're only in
Alpha here so again we're just talking
about all the main things that's
happening right now exactly and you know
so that that's the first one for me
unlocking new functional it's fantastic
saves me a lot of time the fact that
whatever I unlock on one platform I find
on the other platforms the second one
for me that I think uh really is just
super cool and also is very player
friendly which is one of the things
super super important to us is shared
battle pass so let's say I've leveled up
the battle pass on one platform same
plan on mobile you know had an awesome
session with my friends the next day all
that progress again carries over so the
stuff I've unlocked and my level just
those benefits now kind of really carry
over with me and the final one I just
want to talk about for one sec let's
imagine over the years I've built up a
group of people now some I know in real
life maybe others I've met playing that
friend group so the chats and the larger
social experience now they're going to
carry over across platforms and across
our sessions why are we doing this we're
doing this because we can honestly other
games can't and also because we just
think it makes for a better social
experience
oh that social experience is definitely
console so if you're playing a game you
can literally just call up your buddies
message them and there you go They're
Gonna know you're playing hey what are
you doing I'm playing Wars on mobile
right now no way your Playhouse from
your phone that is just absolutely
revolutionary stuff and so with things
like that I'm really excited to see how
it progresses later on into the game and
really just excited for its launch and
now speaking up we're taking a look at
our doors yet again so we're going back
into the gameplay where we're taking a
look at jokesta and with everything so
far I don't think we've touched up on
vehicles that much anymore so I mean
yeah the ATV you got it right over here
you have the classic classic vehicles
that we got to see in verdance the first
time exactly one thing I love about the
verdance vehicles too a lot of
differences helicopter slow trucks fast
quick ATVs you really have a whole
experience there's nothing better for me
too than a helicopter I don't know about
you but I'm a helicopter person I agree
with that I mean it's the fastest route
to go in there but if you need to be
ready you have to go and drive up right
now especially if there's going to be a
javelin just point it at you you made
sure that you get out of the helicopter
ASAP but again when it comes to finding
those Vehicles you need to know the map
very well I mean you can already
definitely look online where to find
like the Great Moments and the great
spots and for me I feel like that's
going to be airport around airport
you're having a lot of vehicles right
now and so right now for this particular
time now they're slowing things down
just a little bit we've noticed it and
for me like I feel like for this Duo
they prefer just going into the
outskirts just a little bit exactly yeah
I think they're smart that way they loot
they get what they need to do always
staying together then occasionally once
they have what they need they're waiting
for the next Circle to collapse they're
finding those areas on the map where
maybe the auction's a little bit lower
after all you know last last people
alive win exactly I mean it just depends
on what kind of gameplay you really like
are you going to be aggressive are you
going to be dropping down Superstore
Boneyard downtown or do you prefer the
outskirts and Beyond the mountains and
try to see what is going to happen when
you are going to see just a little bit
of a step back but obviously it does
have its wrist you won't have as much
loot going into it and you won't have as
much skills
exactly exactly final thing oh getting
into storage town circles collapsing for
me this is the intensity that I'm
looking for man it's my favorite same I
mean it's really just a strategy that
you can play for me I'm the type of
player that goes outside of the circle
going into the smoke going into the
outside of the zone and try to have like
a better angle there because once you
see the circle zoning in you don't have
basically you don't know that anyone's
gonna stay out there people are just
gonna assume everyone's inside the zone
right exactly 100 those are the real
Savvy players that gas mask slow lagger
behind yeah I die to them all the time I
mean prior to this event I was looking
at the top 200 war zone clips of all
time and I just saw one I hope it gets
to see it here in Warzone mobile where
you get to see so many more highlights
from outside of the Zone repositioning
themselves especially at the outside of
the Zone but hey take a look at that
speaking of another highlight we get to
see it Noah from YouTube tries to go in
there getting all the those kills really
just breaks the armor but doesn't really
quite get the guild just yet but then
obviously has the advantage of the scope
not only that High Ground as well so I
feel like we haven't talked about The
High Ground so much here because it's
just so important to have that kind of
height
exactly the way we think about it
internally is how do we find the right
mix of gameplay experiences so you need
that close quarter combat you need long
range for sure but the way you combine
those two with verticality in certain
dense areas that is special I think for
dance especially the era we have the
area we're in right now in the outskirts
of storage town it has that in spades
and now with that in mind I feel like
you have all that verticality what part
of the map do you think is best when it
comes to having that height advantage
it's a great question so for me it's
actually the area we're in right now I
love the intersection or or or the kind
of Borderlands between storage town and
boneyard I think it has the best of all
the environments so for me when I'm
playing starting Boneyard head up to
storage town and if I'm lucky in the
circle abides stand in this area
I'm just so so so proud to say that
starting today as we've said before you
can pre-register for free on the Google
Play Store
and for players on iOS just stay tuned
we have incredible incredible rewards
coming up and of course we'll be able to
pre-order on on Apple App Store as well
well plus we have a ton of amazing
operator skin for those who sign up and
now with that being said I want the
folks at the desk to see what they think
of the new things today
thank you so much beef bunny what a day
it has been we're almost uh are we
nearly done not even gonna try to guess
that one out now though uh it's time to
take a look at some of our best plays so
far brought to you by hyperx because
that's right guys we've been playing Cod
all day and there's only one Tommy truan
it's a one it's a two and could it be
any more I'm not on the desk here with
Lottie Alley Cat and nameless and
brother we've seen it all man today it's
been nuts it's a bit nuts man we see you
know the poor every gameplay ground war
now we're seeing some of our best
players from the biggest streamers we've
seen Aiden Tommy Crim now Aiden in the
3p mode just running around hip firing
just Brian people it's been a hell of a
day miles we just watched primothy 6
pick up two that was pretty sweet Aiden
again enjoying the hip fire and look at
this it's almost a different game like
yeah yeah this is definitely MW2 but I
mean like this is something totally
different yeah it really is something
completely different and I think you
know you heard the cheers earlier on
when Warzone was kind of put on the
screens we saw the trailer we saw the
action unfolding as well uh but I've got
to say just see our favorite creators
being in game currently trying
everything out testing it I mean it's
absolutely insane so yeah I've been
loving everything so far I mean what's
not to love homage in a chopper with a
sniper for everyone in the streets I
mean what's not to love alley I'm not
I'm literally right there with you
there's like no better point of view at
a better time that we could have gone to
never mind with a sniper in his hand in
a chapter and I would have to say that
the hip fire in this game just this is
like this is a sneak peek like right
this is just our first look into the
alpha what Modern Warfare 2 is going to
be what war zone 2.0 is going to be I've
seen more hip fire today than I think
I've seen in the past like three years
of Call of Duty multiplayer like so I'm
really excited to see how that plays
moving forward and how it plays in
competitive because you know I can't
ever just stop thinking about
competitive Call of Duty oh you're doing
your doing your job are you kidding ass
as well so okay well we're almost ready
to rock and roll we've got a Genie in
Xavier now down on the ground soon but
uh this is Modern Warfare back in a
glorious way uh crazy to see everything
going down so far it's just been amazing
and starting sorry excuse me gameplay
that we got to see here today
um starting tomorrow over the next week
um you're telling me that we're able to
play all of this in the beta as well so
that's two weeks of gameplay we're all
gonna be able to get our hands on across
all the various platforms cannot wait to
see how that goes we're going to take a
quick break in between the gameplay now
take a little bit of a pause I will be
going to be setting up for
um drum roll please Warzone 2.0 that's
right the debut of Warzone 2.0 gameplay
is right around the corner stay tuned
but for now we're going to talk over to
Gina and Xavier down on the floor
foreign
Gina darling here now we got streamers
who've been playing Call of Duty all
morning we got computers running we got
production people running around like
crazy it's time for lunch and it's
coming in this is so cool you never got
a slice of this you're just gonna eat
during the
yeah well I know it's here like I got
all these for myself did you get any of
God half of this is mine no it's not I
don't know what listen we got some pizza
we got some Mountain Dew shout out and
thank you too
um I love pepperoni okay shout out to
Mountain Dew and Little Caesars we love
you now we're gonna take all this pizza
eat it ourselves Mountain Dew drink it
ourselves you guys listen to some words
from our friends at Call of Duty
endowment bye well all right
I need more Xavier
come on
head
foreign
ERS here on site marching down the Green
carpet with one mission in mind to be
the first players to play Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2.
and there is so much in this game there
is almost too much this is like one of
those days where I enter and my hopes
are so high and what are you looking
forward to most when it comes to war
zone two prisoner rescue I'm looking
forward to using that inflatable Soldier
decoy to mess a lot of players
killstreaks I think I'm honestly here
just to learn as much as I can to prep
for alternative optic because those guys
are very old now so maybe some OG Maps
coming back I'm up that everyone can
play honestly give me a broken shotgun
what's your favorite game mode and
Mountain Dew flavor combo Search and
Destroy Code Red to the flag code red if
I'm going hard with the boys on a long
night at s d and I'm trying to get some
nasty in-game comms I'm drinking Baja
Blast all night terminal or high rise
easy terminal oh terminal most people
have terminal Nostalgia terminal
terminal 100 I just replayed that
recently and I realized that spawn
trapping is horrendous easy
strike high rise high-rise terminal
what's your favorite flavor of Mountain
Dew I've grown up on code red so it's
still code red for me honestly I like
the basic one just Mountain Dew itself
dang I was going to pick code red too
can I get a second one all right Baja
Blast
starting October 17th unlock dual Double
XP Cod points and also an exclusive
Mountain Dew skin in Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 when you buy specifically
marked Mountain Dew you think you think
you getting me as you kidding me
[Music]
all right here we go Dan it's been a
while how you doing sir it's great to be
back with you Maven it is it is we've
got a lot to chat through listen you are
here for the Call of Duty endowment tell
me a bit about it sure the Call of Duty
endowment is an organization that helps
us and UK vets find high quality careers
by supporting groups that prepare them
for the job market and by raising
awareness of the value that vets bring
to the workplace through support from
the Call of Duty Community and our
partners the endowment has placed more
than a hundred thousand veterans into
high quality jobs becoming one of the
world's largest funders of Veteran
employment and we couldn't do this
without each and every one of the
members of the Call of Duty Community
uh the endowment does incredible work I
mean it's amazing what you guys have
done over the years tell me why you were
so focused on veteran employment
yeah so at the endiamo we believe that
Quality Employment provides the greatest
benefits for the largest number of
veterans the vet finds a high quality
job upon re-entrying into civilian life
any other challenges become much more
manageable a good job means a roof food
Health Care access social interaction
and probably most importantly purpose
last year the endowment placed more
veterans into jobs than any previous
year and we are excited to continue our
mission to place the next hundred
thousand veterans it is truly terrific I
thank you for all that you do for
veterans I know you have an exciting
announcement tell us more about that
yeah absolutely the Call of Duty
endowment bowl or code ball Returns on
December 16th hell yes I've had a blast
with these
uh um and now some of you may remember
the U.S space force shocked everyone and
took home the last code bull trophy
we're thrilled to be bringing the event
back I can't wait to see who'll take
home this year's title also we're
grateful that USA's support is helping
make code Bowl 3 possible USA has been
serving the military Community for a
hundred years personally I've been a
proud member of USAA for 32 years since
I was a young Navy officer and I'm
thrilled to have their support for code
Bowl 3. yeah this is incredible I've
been a part of these they're an absolute
blast and what an awesome trophy it is
can't wait to see who wins Cod cobolt 3
presented by USAA here's a sneak peek of
what's to come
Call of Duty endowment Bowl presented by
USAA is back on December 16 2022. watch
as U.S and UK military Esports teams
compete to be the code bold 2022
Champion featuring some of your favorite
Call of Duty creators and Call of Duty
new players super proud of the boys here
to represent this year the Call of Duty
endowment reached an amazing Milestone
of placing one hundred thousand veterans
back into high quality jobs after their
service to celebrate this incredible
achievement the code Bowl will be bigger
and better than ever get ready for
thrilling Call of Duty competitive play
alongside some of the top names in the
city be sure to follow Call of Duty
endowment on Instagram and Facebook and
code for vets on Twitter for more code
Bowl announcements and tell us which
team you are rooting for
get ready for Call of Duty endowment
code ball 2022 presented by USAA
we're back again hi we are so excited to
have gotten the opportunity to work with
such a huge name in the sneaker World
working with shoe surgeon yeah we got
two shoes to show you today we got the
neopin brute Neil being brute you're so
excited boot there we go excited feel
free neoprene boot uh in the iconic Call
of Duty green and also we have sneakers
inspired by Al mazara we have parachute
material here parachute silks and in
desert tones and both shoes come with or
Gilly clip-ons as you can see here you
can take it on off because you know
technical reasons yes exactly and you
could possibly win these you could be
one of the six well maybe five or four
depending on yeah if we get a pair uh to
win these but all you have to do is go
and follow at Call of Duty on Twitter
and you get a tweet
codnext and and sweepstakes or go ahead
and scan the QR code below and you could
possibly win these good luck
get a good look
I have to I'm carrying your way better
bring your A game today that's the only
game I got try and keep up
hey what do you think is in it no idea
but it's fine
blind skulls behind us guess you're
behind me again
thank you
adios amigos amigos
you see any more of those
GMC Hummer EV reporting for Call of Duty
uh well Call of Duty fans hopefully that
got you fired up this is a pretty cool
announcement we have here we are excited
to officially announce the all-new GMC
Hummer EV pickup will be a drivable
vehicle in Warzone 2.0 that's right boys
and girls this is awesome the first of
its kind integration for the franchise
bringing one of the baddest cars on the
planet to Cod right let's just get to
the facts all right the Hummer EV is the
first and only fully electric vehicle in
Call of Duty Warzone 2.0 and it doesn't
stop there there are some amazing
features to the vehicle in game two such
as rapid acceleration and a unique sound
seating and for the whole Squad off-road
capability and not to mention the
vehicle's badass look so when Warzone
2.0 launches this fall players should be
on the lookout for the Hummer EV in Al
mazura and actually the hummery V will
make an appearance in mw2's campaign
before his debut in Call of Duty Warzone
2.0 on November 16th this year Clint a
new vehicle for Warzone a whole squad's
gonna be in there we're gonna be road
tripping around I am pumped man and as
we gear up for Warzone 2.0 gameplay and
more Warzone mobile gameplay we want to
emphasize for all the viewers out there
again all that Modern Warfare 2
multiplayer game fit you just saw well
you're going to get to play that in the
Modern Warfare 2 Beta that starts
tomorrow for PlayStation players who
have pre-ordered then goes open for
PlayStation players on Sunday through
Monday and don't worry Xbox and PC
players out there the beta will start
for you next week with an early access
period starting next Thursday and with
the beta going live for all players next
Saturday the beta is going to contain a
ton of content in-game rewards for
playing and oh by the way if you have
pre-ordered the bulk edition of Modern
Warfare 2 you get to use the red team
141 operators and fjx Cinder weapon
vault in the beta there's no excuse to
not pick part in this but to make it
super easy for you guys scan the QR code
below oh and by the way we if we haven't
even mentioned by pre-ordering any
edition of the modern Warfare 2 you get
to play the campaign up to a week early
this has never been done before in Call
of Duty think about it getting to give
campaign your full attention before
diving in on day one into multiplayer
this is awesome
you know what I mean
that's not all that really isn't you've
oh okay been seeing a ton of great
action on the groundbreaking Warzone
mobile but just to remind everyone out
there again that you can pre-register
for your free download of Call of Duty
episode mobile now on the Google Play
Store just in case you needed a reminder
don't forget get your phones ready I
know you're gonna be playing the game on
your phone but check this out
hey guys Burke here and I am thrilled to
be one of the first to pre-register for
Call of Duty Warzone mobile annoy you
can too scan the QR code at the bottom
of the screen to be among the first to
drop
Okay so we've seen
Okay so we've seen Modern Warfare 2
we've seen Warzone on mobile now it's
time for war zone 2.0 November 16th is a
date it's going to be available across
the world but today we all get to see it
in action for the first time this is a
huge moment and we can't wait to see
everyone behind us diving in with that
no need to delay any longer let's get it
going I can't believe I mean I just
looked around and everyone's sort of is
like 200 people
I play so much oh my gosh all right
before we get into it uh I want to give
a a shout out once again to Intel who is
powering all the streaming PCS here
today all of them outstanding can't wait
to see that one goes again Clinton two
PCS on every table one of them
exclusively for streaming listen I
stream on two PCS whenever I travel I
just pray that I'm gonna have something
that somewhat mimics what I have at home
the fact that they have this year it is
one of the coolest things I've ever seen
the support is unreal this event is
effing dope I'm pumped up effing dope
nameless listen this is incredible what
Clint said like having a PC specifically
for gaming because you don't take
anything away from Modern Warfare 2 and
to have one to stream as well you can
see it here like this is a gamer's
Paradise like coming out to play the
game early and also being able to create
content and not have anything taken away
from your graphics is absolutely
phenomenal shout out to Intel and shout
out to everybody that put this together
because I've never been a part of
anything that's special like this yeah
and as we do as a flyover do you see the
size of that thing it's it's on the top
right of our streamers desks like it's
not taking up a lot of space either so
the fact that it has that much power to
be able to run a stream as well run this
many streams it's incredible I need to
get something like
guys you know they say size isn't
everything now though it's time for the
TCL Power Hour there are so many
exciting games there's so much exciting
gameplay moments we can't wait to see
for the next hour we're going to be
tracking along with these we've got our
bingo card ladies and gentlemen this is
it nine challenges this is gonna be
across the entirety of our war Zone
Alpha gameplay and uh basically you've
got to try to manage to nail a couple of
these name us any fun ones yeah I mean
fire damage death Tim's Gonna Get
Timothy 100
uh ledge hang elimination like looking
at some of the CEO guys like look at
that Zuma trying to get one of those
crib it'll be interesting to see uh this
bingo card who can complete it Alec
vehicle elimination we've got so many
vehicles now I'm so excited like one of
my first introductions into Warzone was
with you know the birthdays was with all
the vehicle kills so now with also that
hover being in how dope some of that
action is going to be so tell us what
you at home are most excited to see
tweet at TCL underscore USA day and let
us know what you think don't forget to
include hashtag Cod next and hashtag
tclx codsweepstakes during the next hour
and you'll be entered for a chance to
win a TCL TV I actually think we almost
all have one of those I got one of those
I got one too ever since that thing's
Elite so make sure you answer oh make
sure you do enter indeed well Glenn this
is it we've waited the world has waited
Warzone 2.0
I'm one of the greatest war zone players
on the planet and I'm excited to see
some games no okay I'm not at all but I
have made it there this is the Power
Hour this is when the stream goes off
the rails yeah craziness happens
we've been so excited to see this guys
we haven't seen too much of the war zone
two yet we've seen the map so I can't
wait to see how it plays out I'm getting
my monitor ready so I can enjoy every
single second of this one as you should
be as well we saw DS before they're
getting settings right everyone getting
very for that very first drop and I mean
that the very first ever drop that most
people outside of Infinity Ward would
have ever seen the world will see for
the first time boy am I excited you
could cut glass with these bad boys
prove it no we've talked we've talked a
lot about some of the features that
we're going to see in this you know we
we chat through with the devs about
different thoughts behind stuff like I'm
curious to see they were talking about
loot like you know if you're looking for
a bandage you're gonna be looking in the
bathroom if you're looking for uh ammo
it might be in like a gun cabinet or on
top of a desk like there are some things
that
sound great but I need to see them
like a Hydra I don't know what's going
on I'm gonna say Ali like this is the
change yeah tremendous change and
honestly it gets me so excited I'm not
you know a typical player that loads in
the war zone nearly as much as Maven
does but I love to watch it so now
they're moving towards on 2.0 not only
you know it's a new map it also has
sections that are very nostalgic that
make me as a normal multiplayer player
want to hop in and then the new vehicles
and the new Circle mechanics like all of
this is so exciting and it's so exciting
to hop in is the countdown in we go to
al-mazra for the very first time here in
Modern Warfare 2 the streamers here at
COD next they're getting lit yeah I see
some fist pumps they are ready here we
go these guys look at Isaac smiling bro
he's so he's so happy yeah I think these
guys put the hours in 8 10 12 hour days
so they're ready to see what their
life's gonna be like for the next couple
of years
yeah right and again this is the largest
battle Rail map that uh anyone in the
Call of Duty world has built this bad
boy is absolutely huge al-masra's got it
all going and here we go Clint the first
drops where are we dropping people oh
like I I kind of want to drop your one
like the central hot spots really
surrounded by water it looks like I mean
like Venice or something or I
had like a boat yeah I want a boat I
want to vote in proximity Minds I want
to kill someone with that I think the
thing about Joe he could have a little
team called boats and Joe's that's good
guys I stole that from uh Stephanie
Snowden education's director if anyone
thank you Steph
Clint is foaming at the mouth right now
there's any but Mr Evans is very excited
here we go the first boots of touch
ground and let's find out what exactly
again Everything's changed loot has
changed all new
I mean we saw earlier I was like Loadout
or high loot uh spots it's gonna have ai
around it you have to code I thought
maybe fall damage there that was amazing
I think he did no he did definitely did
so there's still loot crates looks a
little bit different in the UI when you
open it up okay oh you can pick what you
want okay we're all learning here by the
way Frank doesn't pop out when you open
it like it's a list and you just pick it
yes instead I kind of like that because
one of my one of my complaints lately
has been like the the sheer amount of
like clutter that'll be on the floor it
sometimes have like gotten me killed
yeah because there's so much loot on the
ground there's like somebody laying in
there it just drops like my visual line
of sight
[Music]
Wow first one we see that was fantastic
what a uh what a bounty that was uh
again so we are still playing at home
for those with the TCL Power Hour
oh my God you can use the elevator that
stuff do we have elevator music oh wait
wait
no way please keep your arms legs arms
legs and heads inside the elevator at
all times
oh sorry Jordan that that is how TST
first gets into the new map hitch killed
Jorge with an elevator
oh it's gonna be a good a good few years
I didn't even see what's happening his
leg just get chopped off it's a little
too close to the door I just seen him
dead and then yeah he just started dying
laughing that was great oh man
first looks again of al-mazra here in
the war zone World War Zone 2.0 already
with the content nothing but content
Ally I'm not over it I'm still not over
it so guns are still on like just on the
floor okay it seems like it's not as
much like all over there yeah which
which I actually dig I guess I'm just
curious to see how much loot there
actually is because obviously you need I
don't have to lose up in the game I'm
also interested to see what happens when
we kill a player you know we see that
belongings will hit the ground I feel
like that still has to be a thing I just
wonder if there's like a item sorting
into it maybe if it's all over the
ground I don't know yeah really
interesting how that one goes down again
I already liking the you know the
quality of life the user interface
changes there the way plates are laid
out everything is a real item that sort
of sits in the world
cashed out just let me Rob the register
I love that everything has meaning here
you can find it in the spots for you to
expect to ah which is really cool I like
these changes you know it's just like
reimagining what Warzone re is making it
better yeah I think it's one of those
things like it'll probably seem a little
bit slow right now with like players
doing it for the first time
ripped and dropped Iceman Isaac hitting
his shots
I wonder I want to see somebody maybe
try some of the objectives that are
there like the strong hold I want to see
that because I know they mentioned AI
earlier yeah there's gonna be like high
loot spots there so interested to see
what you can grab there is I thought
that was proximity chat for a second the
down guy was screaming at him help me
yeah but that will be a thing though
eventually I mean that's the ledge hop
there's a ladder right there oh nearly
Isaac smooth moves a little bit of
Parkour into the gulag first time here
we go
wait and it's it's now
the ground Min God has apathy there's
weapons on the floor Lou up get into the
fight here we go how big is this map
no so there's there's also AIS in here
too distractions that's not a real
person that's wait actually it doesn't
make him any less dangerous apathy help
him help you help your teammate he's not
really a teammate so not only do you
have a teammate now there's distraction
AI Bots and you have to pick up loot off
the ground this is wild
you can see you can see like question
marks on his face that's the first time
you've been in there sorry so it's two
versus two you can have a different a
random enemy team as a teammate yes then
plus there were I didn't realize there
were AI
spicy it didn't look like you could kill
AI either like as many times as many
shots as he put into it it just kept
pushing at him you gotta earn your way
back for a second life you gotta fight
right back in this one here's the first
first look at the hobby since with the
battery life so this is something we've
been talking about for so so long
players who you know say rely on the on
the heartbeat sensor a little too much
that battery life oh she's dipping okay
I I was actually a very I was very anti
carpet inverted I was it's just it was
like an unlimited UAV what do we call it
the baby monitor yeah but now with the
battery life that's it and we saw the
buy station for a moment there but
didn't get too many looks on it we'll
get a look at that later on but now the
first look in the vehicle we have a fuel
gauge again this is a big deal in the
game your vehicles will run out of fuel
you have to visit a gas station check
out the prices of course before you go
in there you've got cash to be spending
I actually don't know if you actually
have to buy it but and also if you
you're running that GMC Hummer EV I mean
it's a retro station
devices
there's a search the summer
unfortunately just can't feel that the
vehicle kind of dies for a week or two
everyone's on foot it's just so
expensive right now that would surely be
something but yeah I mean I feel like
that's kind of the big takeaway so far I
don't even want to say it uh yeah I
guess you could say a realism thing to a
degree but just more logical I guess is
almost something I would say like it's
more logical loot there's a there's
money in a register yeah exactly I mean
if I open the register and there's like
a you know a shotgun in there surprise
oh howdy and this looks like it could be
a strong so was that an AI that was an
AI yes it looked like it might be but I
don't see it on the map which is oh yeah
oh okay yes we do buy station over there
being marked as well uh also to note the
backpack down on the d-pad down modular
screen see what that looks like if he
presses it pretty much let's go bro
we've got a lot of people to infotain
right now
yeah sure we haven't really seen what
that looks like here's tem uh maybe he
might have already fallen to his death
once or twice not entirely sure but
uh it's him and ninja dynamic duo what a
Duo
is this
Tim's just excited happy to be here
good assessment he's gonna pick stuff up
okay you can't just put the food you
might have to chew it yeah he had to
chew it before you swallow it like yeah
man you gotta pick it up brother he
cannot get through this window oh
is that a bot he shredded that guy that
was the ak-74uf has someone really seen
that played with today uh Tommy cluxy
and Swag like fun team that is they have
activated something on the top side of
the screen I've got no idea what this is
Jack Jeff Joe if you're here we need you
we are excited but we are ignorant yeah
this is one of the uh new objectives and
I just saw your text about assisting you
with your situation I was also
mid-segment it's FYI I wasn't ignoring
you I just saw that thank you I just
took my phone for one second and he
didn't help with travel
that's my guy right there yeah yeah so
look at that so you know honestly I was
thinking about you buddy quick enough we
have actually got assistance here we
might be able to get we might be able to
get some IW Folks up here to give us a
little helping hand with that what
looked like it could have been in a
contract but I am completely making that
up no I mean it must have been some sort
of objective you are a cerebral genius
yeah I'm just really like Mastermind the
circles how they play out very very
smart the skull's up to here
Aiden on the right hand side of the
screen having a good time just uh you
know running around flowing actually
might be in the lobby he's pretty
chatting it up this is pretty dead yeah
I think right now I mean you're seeing
everyone kind of learn and explore and
just there we go splitting soon okay
look at that icon so is this gonna be a
two split you kind of jump the fence go
around the end is literally right there
just please yeah I know I can't jump it
but like just go around I feel like he
should be able to mantle that and maybe
that'll be something maybe test from
this side drain them into it
gotta hit those shots oh yeah it doesn't
have the Hops all the shots apparently
yeah dude you may see me dive into the
bushes
as soon as the trouble hits the
Australian Outback oh but then Clint
he's our deep bushes I'm gonna lose I'm
gonna get absolutely torched from one of
these you know I'm looking at this and
I'm just thinking Molotov
do you think do you think the fire
spreads oh that oh we'd have to ask
about do you think the fire spreads
that'd be a lot of fun that would be
awesome you gotta have like destructible
alignments you're like shooting a
building and it's falling apart
so what we thinking of the map right now
it looks uh some pretty cool points of
interest like it looks clean I mean it
looks great I just kind of want to
wander I mean I feel like a lot of them
are in the mode I would be if I was
playing oh it's a bot yeah so there's a
lot there's quite a bit of bots like
whenever you just like protect loot yeah
that's that's a lot different like yeah
well I think the main thing is just
the audio maybe from the active like
killing one like you're going to loot
you might it might alert somebody that
you're there they wouldn't have
otherwise noticed
coming up
this full squad's not down we have 47
minutes give or take remaining here on
the TCL Power Hour don't forget we've
got a lot to get through in that bingo
card
definitely you can get involved as well
and we have to catch it on the
mainstream wait he got paired with Karim
no way he's got paired with Prim and
they're going up against ocean Ops and
almonds so I mean if they're picking
Warzone players I'm picking them guns up
here we go
I'm gonna do I'll Zoomers up top
watching them
Rock's still being thrown a fave in the
gulag that's right
there's one no
no
oh
players all right
now we have to watch Zuma oh hello
oh the chopper looks clean brother okay
so this is a joke brought this one up
he's like one of my favorite Vehicles is
this like big badass drop of the holes
look at that in there you're gonna
you're gonna be able to load up flares
you've got counter measures to do with
any kind of anti-air yeah Oh Lordy there
we go that's our first three Circle
split we're also seeing here so this is
going to get dicey very quickly that
looks like downtown oh yeah that battery
life is gonna go soon is it do you think
like every time it pings it's like a bat
that's like a percentage of the battery
life it could be that would be a lot
though that'd be you'd get 100 100 pings
well I'll tell you right now that's a
full game when people use the heartbeat
sensor they're spamming it yeah
I see you well let's see what happens
again I wonder if you can go to a gas
station find batteries maybe or if you
set that thing down maybe uh maybe just
sort of steps gets it going or maybe the
sun recharges it we'll find out we've
got a hydro down
socket and a USBC
yeah the UI of the the loot and or
something there looks super clean so
that looks like the backpack as well so
again a different blue different sort of
inventory systems that's the back that's
cool so you can pick up a difference
yeah so you know you can hold on to a
ton of stuff does it affect your
movement speed it's like Ally I don't
know mate you're learning
first job
I'm just asking out loud at this point
hoping that the gods of War Zone will
yeah answer Riles is the all-knowing I
think I've tried I'll do it my best
there's a 72.8 8 reduction in movement
speed unfortunately what kind of
ammunition type is it I don't know I'm
joking I have no idea 0.722s
that's the average weight I think us
included everybody here everybody in
game oh
this person looks we're just trying to
see what the hell's gonna play oh this
is a team wipe yeah they're getting
tucked right here was that Zuma that was
a sniper
don't worry about it yeah
oh Nicholas marks he's in a battle right
now they're in a tough spot
this makes these down okay so so fried
if you look at the top right he has two
different indicators of how many people
are in the lobby exactly it's circles I
imagine
yeah maybe the one that you're closest
to I was actually wondering that because
I would if you were an aggressive player
and you had a circle of less people
would you have an idea that the other
one was more profit and you could make a
play to maybe get to that like I'll tell
you you could like yeah or some kind of
play I was kind of wondering that I'm
assuming that's what it is I could be
wrong that's what makes sense right yeah
that makes sense it must be also he has
an extra plate so let's see and it's
purple looks though uh the other circle
is getting fried so uh
that just dropped so quick like I feel
like half the players just got decimated
yeah they're getting they're getting
destroyed
I wonder if that was the trouble we saw
previously the one that was up in the
air there
yeah a little bit of backpack management
here
I suppose the backpack is just saying
your ammo account
other tools or toys you have and again
so many new I mean between field
upgrades between lethal equipment
there's so much going on here at MW2
yeah but look at that jump look at that
I was talking about that rooftop jump
earlier multiplayer it is actually
insane how far you can jump from rooftop
to really like when I look at the
movement in this game and like even when
you're throwing nades and Sons and stuff
like the depths of it like isn't as far
as you would think like usually when you
throw an aid I mean you can like Chuck
that thing but like I expected the jumps
to be the same way but like they're
actually you can go really far I just
realized I mean a box doesn't oh no
there's three circles so I'm completely
wrong I'm not sure yeah so so that might
be box then oh yeah I'm not sure oh
maybe that's an indicator of the
strongholds but uh okay first with the
parachute from oh one important
have we seen a loadout
this looks like a like a Loadout weapon
right here more on that later
and we don't know
live react
the circle still do it live I want to
see how the circles merge together at
the end of the game
all right let's go Blake he spotted at
least one
a lot of vehicles I didn't realize that
was Blanket first Audi mustache he's got
the mullet the angle hit it oh
a little crack
Isn't it nice it kind of it's kind of
similar familiar yeah it's like weird
enough but seems Seems fresh right like
yeah you don't mess with it too much
like people love it right so it's just
making it well you could just strip it
down and change it entirely yeah but
there'd be chaos yeah chaos what it is
yeah so it's like they changed a lot
though man like it looks a lot different
oh Legend and like the movement's
different too it makes me want to slide
cancel around the entire map now
trying to fill out my bingo card I'm
getting I'm getting like teas with like
a legend and a little bit of swimming
but we don't have the elimination just
yet
yeah I did that
run bike oh oh here they come this is
the one beat oh yeah no it's done I was
gonna say this could have been a 1v3
survival just teams there though oh wait
it's still on and they're frying all
right listen wait a minute the war zone
squad's been taken out that's fine
here he goes
he's self-res and just popped up oh he's
smiling I wondered I wondered what
happened there the self gets off he
makes the play
he's got a streak okay look how much
cash he has okay so it is still on the
ground this reminds me a little bit more
it looks like stuff's divvied up this is
a little bit more like a combination of
war zone and blackout in the sense of
like Warzone you know it had all the
ground blackout you'd have like a
backpack and then you'd open that and
see all the stuff this is like it almost
it has it on the ground but it segments
it off into various things you had your
armor right you had your mask you had
your backpack so it's kind of like a
hyper between Wars on a blackout with
looting I think sometimes round moves
yeah remember the time zone you're
trying to like I just want to pick up
that gas mask and there's a hundred
things on the ground yeah yeah yeah and
you can't find that one thing on the
ground you know it's like trying to lift
Thor's hammer yeah that was like a nice
I want this one thing I'm gonna grab
that I'm gonna look at this item on the
ground pick it up done I could tell you
how many times I just run over loot I
grab everything I'm like oh no I left my
sub let me go back yeah so it's like
it's clean you just like can't make any
mistakes there three circles almost
coming to a close here
spicy one he's got paper 15 grand in his
pocket so I'm gonna buy station see what
he can get we hit a buy I mean firstly
you have to buy teammate back I think
everybody here wants to get that first
win so bad we are 40 minutes into the
TCL Power Hour
we're 40 minutes anyway 40 man's left
40 minutes left okay trust me oh no no
you said that I was like dude time is
fly I I was really into this because we
have teleported in time I have Doctor
Who
this has been my favorite area of the
map so far that building was dope
can you go on that mountain over there
I'm more interested in this Giant
mountain you have to be able to it looks
like it looks like it's part of that I
love High ground it's my favorite
that bed's very dirty oh hello oh God is
that a zombie
hey I've always thought about it man
imagine like a real horde of zombies on
a warzone map
I'm talking like I'm talking full-blown
you know World War Z um yeah yeah a
little bit in Fortune's keep a little
bit in blackout at times but not like a
yeah not like a daisy
so you saw the buy station was there was
a section that said buy weapons so you
can buy a specific weapon in the buy
station that was interesting oh here
comes the circle move well that makes me
think Loadout might not be as much of
anything yeah because it said by armor
buy weapons and then I think it was by
Emma or something oh come on hit it
don't get run over he's getting ripped
his teammate just got it just dropped
and eating like an enchilada I might be
hungry because I oh Precision that's
right
one I need I need more Little Caesars
though I need like two whole pepperoni
pizzas within my mouth this is the best
lamp I have ever been to there's Pizza
everywhere oh it was Isaac I mean we we
told chat this is off the rails now oh
wow he got hyper beamed with the vinegar
range there guys my
my Killers is it the aim or the AR no
I'm kidding Nick it's definitely they
are you're the best don't hurt me hurt
him
dude this is closing swag versus this is
actually a lit right
wait for it jail key drop wait cover the
key and Escape get the key
get the kill
here oh oh he sent it and swag just shot
him in the forehead now down to a one
versus one
is the key wait 25 seconds
so I guess that's kind of like how in
normal God you'd get to that flag or
whatever when you went like OT maybe the
keys kind of like there it is freedom oh
to hear step curious there was a door at
the back walked out
that was great he picked up a kid just
ran for it I'm out of here okay so that
sucks pretty cool I would lose full
though nah yeah somebody did that to me
I'd be so mad can you imagine that like
you just lose 2V1 you're like where is
he he's got the key
it's not a cool little area of the map
again it's a big old map yeah it is old
Mazda
bring comfortable shoes
word to the shooter well there's a lot
of vehicles on the map I've been seeing
them on the moon map I just haven't seen
many people hop in them
oh we saw a Seal Team Crim six yeah we
saw that pull up and absolutely but I
want to see the the Big Bertha see what
it looks like well there's different
kinds of vehicles so there's like little
sedans family wagons whatnot you know
they're all gonna have different
properties which is really fun to think
of if you have like a military class
vehicle get in the hatchback Jack I feel
like there's somebody close you can see
like buy weapons and you can upgrade
your weapons so the clock jumping is
Papa's teammates back yeah I'm intrigued
to see how that works though it's like
what do you like buy a weapon with some
of your attachments then upgrade it to
the attachments that you have or is it
attached to the game sets for you so
we'll see oh so many questions yeah I
have so many I've seen a lot of Highways
as well this is a lot of fun we're going
to see I think there's a little bit more
of a lean towards vehicular combat which
I'm very very excited about given the
fact that like there's 19 ways to battle
each other with cars now well the one
thing I'm kind of digging like yeah
there's going to be some new versions of
combat but like at least what we're
seeing so far
it doesn't look like you have and that's
might be the loadout change too but I
think it's with five attachments like
you can't beam someone with an AR 400
meters like it's going to force closer
range combat you're not gonna be
terrified across any open gap which I I
think AR has been too easy to shoot like
this that I mean that has more recoil
than I've seen in three years yep
was like I'm gonna rethink this way I
think in general like it's better if
it's a little bit more difficult to
shoot at long ranges it just needs to be
this is what I wanted to see how
powerful is it can you finally shoot
them it's running I guess this is greed
so one of our streamers or content is
coming from Japan that's awesome
also though man shoot them tires I'm
just thinking out I mean my mind's going
forward solo yellow is gonna look real
different when everyone's driving around
with vehicles with no tires and like
yeah running that gas in the end it's
like there's one person at the end
that's got this like super high-tech
military vehicle or who has the Hummer
it's like I don't need gas here oh my
God that's the matter dude
eco-friendly vehicle
go green for the green this is a Duo
wait what is this key about wait you see
the key on his head I'm not sure Bobby's
got a key he's got a key to my heart but
that could be uh that could be one of
the sort of special loot locations
there's some Subterranean spots dude
these are the guys I hate Warzone I am
in a staircase
Fenix yeah I need that proximity chat I
need like me like I know you're in that
staircase the way he's playing I feel
like Bob's AFK and he's protecting Bob
that's what I'm getting from them at
least Bob has not moved
because I the symphony I note is not run
up and down staircases 400 times this
guy has to be in fights over and he
literally has to hold forward so I mean
I figure something's going on this is a
really important map like whoever wins
this like they hold the record for most
women
like the stream title right here
just get it up there right away world
record holder
there's a lot of those in Warzone
getting a very sort of strong I'm liking
the different areas we've seen so far
this is the most sort of urban area
we've seen like Heist like I mean
there's a parking lot here we've seen
some high tower we've seen some
stairwells again what was that
[Music]
it's simply just aims yeah oh my God the
internet is already like sus he sucks
shout out Ricochet stand behind him
day one coming for you I always wonder
about like length of games and I always
think you I mean I prefer when it's
around like 20 minutes I'm wondering
like how long a map is right now yeah
we're like did we start 30 minutes in
yeah
yeah so this is well we're we're also
hopping in and out of I think maybe two
different games I think it's or it's
delayed I think it's elite I think it's
three because I think we've seen solos
this is trios no it's all the same game
so there's solo people oh wow okay so
what I'm wondering like is just length
of game this might be a little bit
longer than it's been in the past seems
like it yeah probably because people are
just figuring stuff out to be honest I'm
probably part of it but I think just
from a circle to size of the circle I
think it's a bit longer like these might
be run about I don't know five ten
minutes longer
well these guys are fighting I'm like oh
look the gas station's a POI on your
minimum
I'm dead serious though if I pull up in
my Harmony V is there going to be a
charge station for me no it's unlimited
dude no way that's too op I mean don't
get me wrong I'm down on a map though
like do you think there's just one like
there's the one golden Hummer EV I don't
know or maybe I'm excited I'm sorry I'm
just talking out loud I know it seems
like I'm asking miles like you have all
the answers I've got a piece of paper in
front of me that just it's the bingo
card but again we haven't seen a vehicle
ledgehang elimination Most Wanted cup we
haven't seen any of these just yet here
we go fall off died so this is still
there right the bright spot of this for
me with Jorge oh
there's 20 people left so this is about
to get this is about to get insane oh
the National Bank of Adele I wonder if
you can go in there and get some cash I
am very much behind Wild all these
little dive in for the res but I'm very
much behind like crazy end games I love
the Leaning coming out of it it's like
he's in game actively moving yeah he is
look at look how leaned up he is oh here
we go
Decked Out
they've got different color armor Most
Wanted Target eliminated uh well that
team didn't um hit the Bingo yeah
I think that was a claymore approx mine
right to The Shins as he went through
the door but this there is a different
kind of plate three plate purple I have
questions yeah something mercs have that
earlier so I think it's maybe you hit
the shop you just buy armor oh maybe
it's yeah maybe it's uh okay Swanky
expensive armor branded yeah I've always
wondered if we'd have something where
it's like a helmeting game uh you know
where you don't get knocked by one snipe
or something I'm not sure if that's the
case but
oh that looks like crims I mean we've
only seen one M16 in the game so far is
that Crimson is he dead
Observatory ahead of us one of the
higher points on the map
um as we've seen so far so this is I
mean look at how muzzle she is she's
gorgeous
see you Jack oh Jack is dead dead
absolutely oh that's horror hey so they
got out of that situation they were and
I think they were able to get the
killers they crept through the water
here look how small the circle is we're
gonna see who ends up taking this one
but it looks like it's just hit she's
trying to save the squad Blake's down
and there's a thermite sitting on
holding them back with a thermite yeah
the fire looks they got to rotate though
so we have to be careful here
I've been sniping
here comes the Bingo This is Love and
Trust right here
oh I got him that's the Bingo but he was
definitely one of the extra combination
here
oh no they're not dead yet
oh hey I mean we're looking at no place
stick him here like this is gonna be
tough they're gonna have to leave this
rooftop as well because the gas is going
to push it they need to just gonna kill
ads
the Blake is down and out I really like
that new looting out of the backpack
I think it's just one of those things I
like once I get used to it it's gonna
take a little time oh here we go he's
only got one of the clips I was hoping
maybe it was the fall damage there but
Jorge he's gonna drop I didn't see how
he got the kills but yeah it looked like
he was able to knock two seven it looks
like seven
as a handsome man blocking the view
there but over to Nick marks
Final Four
oh they're in a great spot rotation
coming in here in a second
this looks dope
I mean this would be nice so it looks
like you can only plate up I see you can
only plate up the two you have to get
something to go to the full plate it's a
big fight Oh I thought maybe like a
helmet or something like that but I see
your time Nick's chilling still has
place to go with I didn't realize it was
limited to two at first let's see uh the
gas mask how that operates
reload just
there you go
three teams remaining six players Dave
got what two left up so might be like a
2v2b2 he has the inflatable decoy to
play with as well that could get really
funny Oh no you're in trouble
this is a good decoy time just pop it
I love mixy endings this ending is done
it's so sweet
coming out the gas still across the
bridge
here they come oh
[Music]
oh
so 1v1 want me two 1v2 right you're
right it's one player UPS because his
teammate's still up 1v1 where are they
are bingo
oh there it is the first time
your first ever Warzone 2.0 winner oh my
God
get in oh my God all right it was lit
we're in for a good few years that
wasn't it I really enjoyed it I think
the map was really cool played a little
bit slower but I think it's just people
figuring it out and then towards the
enemy yeah I I wasn't even sure was that
was that like a
a 2v3v1 or a 2v2b2
1v3 survival
Bingo baby
who is the solo on that I was trying to
like figure out the situation at the end
like Nick was just popping off he's just
frying yeah 100 oh too tense see what's
going on there but I mean wait that was
fun well here we go
1v3 check we saw uh airstrike
eliminations as well
um I believe on that little roof I think
we got Bingo though we didn't care but
we got that at the very least oh no one
got multiple grenade kills okay two down
unless we missed it please tell me
someone fell today I gotta see a decoy
elimination that would just be so funny
to me if somebody gets smoked by a decoy
I'm gonna be in tears I did true tears
GG's once again congrats Nick Merks the
first ever Warzone 2.0 winner world
record holder world record holder yeah
no unbelievable of course it's Nick now
yeah well we were watching earlier like
in the 3p game mode he was looking
disgusting like he looks like the best
player we're watching the 3p has a lot
of experience there now just hop right
into war zone making plays
guys I'd love to see it guys we fix the
Beast we've seen Warzone 2.0 initial
Impressions I mean again like there's no
one here from IW we're just fans yeah
I'm having a blaster it's just to me it
seems uh right now like a bit slower
Pace but I can't tell if that's
a circle thing or people learning and
kind of exploring the map uh I imagine
it's a little bit of both like it's new
I it's gonna play a little bit slower at
first but it's it's neat yeah I think my
favorite thing about it right now is
like the way the Looting is where the
loot is at like it's on tables it's in
cabinets the backpack down like there's
less stuff obscuring your view like you
pick up your loot you keep it going
you're looking for the enemies right it
feels nice it feels smooth the AI part
of it I don't know that I would get yet
in the sense of like you'd like go into
like Luda place or be like one Ai and I
don't know it's like do you get do you
get extra points from that do you get
extra money from that they jump stuff I
I can think about like you know it's
people are gonna hear that obviously
it's not as quiet as looting but that
was that was the one thing I won't
understand more of what's going on there
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah any sort of
takeaways from you first game of war
zone 2.0 I'm excited to load in like I
said I don't really play Wars on them
often but this new 2.0 ozone I'm very
very excited to load in when it drops
well now we get a quick look at that
first uh win we're gonna see the POV of
network once again as he goes up yeah
thanks to the guys at Elgato here we go
where's the W bun on that Big Bad Boy
Bang
this was the final play on that bridge
Clinton so he killed two people yeah
yeah so it was 1v3
good teammate call out good calm dude he
is just I I was worried like if storm
wasn't as close to him as it was like he
was gonna get on that heady and just
smoke him but he was so weak he got like
one bullet and just fried him and then I
think the guy he Chad like laying down
the bridge he like got all head shots he
smoked him too like yeah I thought he
was gonna lose that all right the more
eagle-eyed of you will see that Jess
Brohard is now ready to rock and roll
right in the middle of the stage here at
COD next just take it away
miles that's right I am ready to rock
and roll here with P90 princess the
princess of almazara I mean what are
your first impressions of Warzone 2.0 uh
so far I'm really liking it I used to
play Pub G so this is really exciting
because it does have that tactical feel
to it but what I'm most excited that
I've discovered is the vehicle
enhancements you can get on the roof uh
you I mean you can jump out at any
moment you can switch your seats which
is exciting that kind of has the vehicle
uh you know tactical play style that you
can throw in there with every match and
kind of mix things up a little bit so
I'm really excited about that and
everything feels pretty good it's very
new so it's going to take some time
getting used to but so far so good I'm
having a lot of fun and what do you
think about those Circle reworks the
circles are interesting I you know you
got to pick the right Circle you know
you're not sure uh I don't know I'm
gonna have to try it out I haven't made
it to the circle Zone yet so
well then finally you know we're here at
COD next among 200 of your fellow
content creators what has been the
highlight of this event for you so far
honestly the highlights being able to
sit next to Huskers my partner and and
play games and we have a lot of fun but
I did just kill him in the brand new
Gulag for the very first time so that
was really rewarding and really exciting
but it's been a lot of fun seeing
everybody and uh you know just seeing
all the gamers out and about again after
everything we've been through so it's
nice that's awesome to get to share this
with your IRL Duo but uh for now that is
Enough from me as well as P90 princess
back on over
thank you very much Jess uh well we're
back at the desk Jack O'Hara joining us
once again mate we could we could have
done with you a minute ago
yeah very very fun though super excited
to see more of that later on but first
if you are just joining us Jack Links
have an incredible giveaway here are all
the details each Jack Link's supply drop
includes a brand new copy of Modern
Warfare on the platform of your choice
delicious Jack Link's limited edition
products epic in-game items and check
this out on how to enter
looking for an epic way to celebrate the
launch of Modern Warfare 2 Jack Links
has got you covered giving you the
chance to win the ultimate Modern
Warfare 2 supply drop keep an eye out
during the broadcast for the Jack Link
Sasquatch to appear on screen if you see
it grab your phone and scan the QR code
following the prompts to qualify for
entries tune in to Call of Duty next
Squad up with Sasquatch and level up for
the ultimate viewing experience courtesy
of Jack Links terms and conditions apply
all right folks there you go keep your
eyes peeled and spot the Sasquatch on
the screen throughout the show no I'm
not the Sasquatch I know what you're
saying right now Chad scan the QR code
and enter all your information for a
chance absolutely what are you talking
about me you've been doing that quite a
lot today yeah I don't know I these
accents come out of me but all right I
do have some questions okay
uh first the one thing I I was really
curious about like uh at the top right
with the player number there's like two
different columns what were the
different player numbers so so that one
is explaining to you the different
numbers of people that are in each
circle okay so that's what my first
guess was okay and and the old
information right like who's in who's
you know alive um so the top bar I think
was like your normal numbers and then
the next one I play a lot of Warzone so
I'm gonna get a little bit nerdy I have
questions uh other thing we didn't see a
Loadout is Loadout in or not in or did
anyone buy one or what's the deal there
so right now in the build the loadout
drops are not in and you okay using um
you're going to buy stations and you're
going to strongholds to acquire the rest
of your Loadout so you can go in you can
select have weapon setups Etc that you
then find the buy station and and inside
the uh the strongholds as well that
that's one of the big questions I had I
was certainly wondering about uh because
yeah we saw like you could buy it was
like a weapons tab you had uh when you
went to the bar we didn't get to really
look at it much because we would we're
hopping around we didn't get to see a
whole lot of it yeah um what with with
the AI that were in different buildings
like when people were going to look
something there'd be a random AI in
there well I guess I want to know what
is the impact on game because obviously
if you have to fight that someone might
hear the shots right you're not like
looting silently but what is the impact
on the game within that like
I guess system so we have obviously the
ad that's concentrated around the
strongholds Etc and then we do have some
smattering of AI so the buildings that
are there as you know an extra Target
that you can kill you can get that
weapon you can get some ammo except the
low extra loot yeah and then uh they can
also serve as a warning that there is
another player there
um so right now we're experimenting with
having them in various different place
spaces and and seeing where uh they're
the most effective and of course
entertaining basically objective as far
as armor plates go like a little you are
a UI thing here there's a a full-plated
character has a purple
colored armor Place versus the blue ones
what's going on there so there's there's
two sides of armor plate carriers
essentially so you're picking up the
three plate carrier and that means you
can go to two plates essentially okay
that's a lot of fun
um okay all right all right now I also
noticed that within the backpack we saw
Nick marks carrying C4 while also having
you know a frag grenade and a smoke
grenade so if I've got a backpack is
that a separate pickup on the ground as
well or is that something that your
character comes equipped with because
they're already a badass so so what you
have is you have the strip at the bottom
which is your Loadout and then your
backpack you have a starting backpack
um that is a certain size and then in
that you can put extra items and you can
hold
um duplicates of things that do you want
to keep that's a lot of fun yeah because
we saw him run a C4 and one point he's
like yeah I don't feel like C4 right now
this is very useful you could he's able
to swap that out in real time and
excellent oh my God so I know in a lot
of ways um I mean blackout was the first
iteration of this and you have Warzone
come out which improved on a ton of
things from a quality of life standpoint
but it feels like there's like
at least from a looting standpoint some
similarities here because you used to
have like the backpack where you could
carry multiple items then we shifted
like everything on the ground this seems
to be like a middle ground to kind of
meet both qualities life would I would
find pretty dope yeah we want to let
players to be able to accumulate kind of
the Arsenal that they're going to carry
through the match with them and kind of
be able to uh equip some items some that
in other game modes might be persistent
Etc
um that they might want to keep inside
their backpack and then carry out of the
match with them Etc
so is the backpack that you start with
that's just that's your backpack for the
whole game or is there an opportunity to
ever expand your backpack and if you can
does that affect the movement speed on
the character if you pick up that's
America probably you're right I can't
carry my many things on a day-to-day
basis miles you should see me try to
bring my groceries into my apartment
building it takes a very very long time
so I was just wondering if that was one
of the realistic things that was
implemented so there are different size
backpacks okay don't offend me with the
speed that's the question I had oh also
in the gulag it seemed like there was an
AI that had popped up at one of the
points that we were watching it didn't
seem like it was a killable AI though it
seemed like he put a bunch of shots into
it and it never went down are they even
killable or he is killable okay so maybe
the person we were watching was just bad
yes it takes some coordination to kill
them okay and that's not his final
iteration but he uh essentially is is
definitely killable if you're getting up
with him with two teams of two you can
essentially take him down and get a
reward and get out okay cool yeah and if
both teams take him out there so can
everyone get out yes
for those of you looking on screen right
now phone's out it's time to uh scan
that QR code Jack Link Sasquatch she's
on screen I know you remember the video
scan away friends Sprat now making a
quick drop any uh particular hot spots
you've got there Jack that you like
um well Hydra is always going to be fun
in my heart which is the one we're
looking at right now because that was
one of the first ones we made it was one
of the first ones to incorporate the
water and have the river running through
it and having a little bit of current
that can drag you along
um and obviously a ton of fun boat
chases through it Etc it's a good place
to find a boat so this one's always
going to be have some fondness in my
heart and I'm sure that the rest of the
development team as well just because it
was the first one it's pretty sweet it's
kind of like the it's like the heart of
our where it all kind of began exactly
are there any sort of fun Easter eggs
that you guys as a development team or
the art team have maybe put in the game
that we can find as players
um so there's definitely a few locations
that you might recognize maybe some some
in downtown some in the airport and some
in the quote
um and then as you start playing the
game yeah you'll discover little
locations that are kind of little
secrets and places to explore yeah I
check out off the coast there's a
there's some racks that are underwater
and places to swim wow so I mean
depending on how you know if you hit
sorry Mavis just I don't know whether it
is I I listen I came in with a question
I I need the body back in time to the
gulag but I nearly choked on a piece of
pizza but now I'm okay while you guys
were talking I put down three of those
very very impressive thank you Little
Caesars but oh my God I'm okay now I'm
outside
no no it was amazing I I was eating way
too fast though but I want to go back to
the gulag real quick can you kind of
take me through
I guess the
the various ways you can get out like
what what are the combinations of it
because you were kind of saying both
teams can get out
is there how does that work I guess I
want to give a little bit more
understanding of how the whole ecosystem
of the gulag Works can I pause that is
this a stronghold Jack we'll get back to
the globe this one's in there this looks
I saw Flags I've seen sort of markings
and there you know there is an assault
now Thames down I don't know okay so at
the same time this looks like a
stronghold there's the icon on the top
side of the map is that telling you
what's going on there correct exactly
what does a little skull mean to the
right of that that was his teammate that
just went down to the sorry to the right
of the stronghold icon in the sort of
top center of the screen just underneath
his Compass Oh there's uh just
underneath his campus that's indicating
the uh uh that you can go to a black
side essentially oh okay and this is one
of the more sort of Secret locations
high level loot okay okay do you need a
key for that or is that sort of first
company once you've accomplished a uh uh
once you've taken down a fortress a
stronghold then you will be able to get
a key to the black side yeah I mean one
of the problems I suppose is you've
created this game you've all created
this game with a million things inside
it's so fun you've got three sort of
excited children here gonna be
constantly pestering you for the
duration of this game that's okay I mean
we we want a very old child but yes we
all are inside yeah
um we just we wanted to make this thing
where as you keep playing there's just
more and more things to do right so
we're just always looking to put some
depth in there to some things that once
you've played 50 100 matches that
there's new things for you to go and
explore and try out Etc
I think this is
well you can already see the pace pick
up a little bit I don't think we saw
anyone more than one or two kills Aiden
on seven and I think these people get
more comfortable the pace of play will
obviously pick up but oh I do want to
say
okay I'm just gonna say it the first
iteration of heartbeats pissed me off
because he just like eyeless every time
I would die in spectate just heartbeat
over and over and over again 400 times
in a row just heartbeat heartbeat
harpies little rodents crawling crawling
around just doing it over and over and I
was just like listen it lasts for a
second UAV you have forever the the
battery life almost made me sing for Joy
so thank you it literally almost made me
sing for Joy how does it work though
like what like how long basically is
like the timing of the heartbeat
Center's battery does it have a timing
is it by the times it pulses it's it's
how long it's been out essentially so
the batches is going out the longer
you're holding it so it was 100 like 100
seconds or is it
um I forget the exact time okay
um but it's it's somewhere around there
got it Ali Works in true specifics yeah
sorry
it's on the desk is like you are not
alone my friend might change is there a
solar panel on itself I'm outside does
it last long and once about the battery
is one of those ones that you can't take
out so once you're done you're done it's
a one and done a very important question
around the fuel in the cars though so
are they tied to real life market prices
so if there is a surge in gas prices is
it going to be more difficult to get gas
in game I mean we don't rule out making
a game mode
for now the gas prices are consistent
throughout I'm seeing in the future like
Mad Max tie-ins and vehicles only and
fuel is the most important resource on
Earth and oh my goodness uh when it does
come to the gas station though do you
have to pay for the gas no it's all free
oh that'd be great fun though everyone
like cash up we need to get gas gas and
you know some Jack Link's jerky all the
homies in the wagon just bumping music
to the gas station oh look at this oh
that's a good parking job that was
actually impressive stuff Ming got his
uh she's sort of sneaking around
I also I'm really enjoying the uh the
sort of you know the layout of blue on
the ground it feels a lot more organic
it feels almost sort of you know we're
leaning more towards realism than you
know sort of floating colorful guns in
the ground see I don't know if I say
realism as much as like because
sometimes I think technically things
being too realistic for me I sometimes
don't like like I want to be Arcadian in
a video game it just seems more logical
to me like it's just like yeah this is
where you would expect this type of
thing to be a cash register has cash
yeah and like I'm sure there's realistic
ties but to me it's just like more
logical yeah it's where things make
sense right yeah it's just you go into a
store like you're going to go in this
gas station you're gonna find cash the
cash register and do it on the shelves
and that is another one of our vehicles
this looks like it's all armored
personnel carrier open turret kind of
scary but still a lot of fun clearly yep
and you just sort of keep rolling after
the person got out so I'm sure he will
make some fun videos with that
eventually I do have something for like
a limited but we're in the desert like
some sort of Oasis that can spawn in a
certain place and pops up there is an
oasis on the top north of the map
actually it's very very pretty and
sometimes I don't think I've seen it yet
this time around yeah like top left-hand
side of the map Oasis we'll see if
anyone goes there but uh we're still
pumping on through the TCL Power Hour
we might have seen a vehicle elimination
in that game we'll wait for the full
word there from our referees meanwhile
in another game I forgot it was on the
map I was thinking about like
Oasis like spawning up like The Mirage
of it there's a there's a Locale
directly on the map
there's somebody flying the big giant
Chopper over there yeah that looks
insane
Gulag okay back to the Google like
questions oh yeah I guess oh here we go
yep can you give me a breakdown of like
objectively how this works so we're
experimenting with different versions in
there okay so right now we have uh to
play you know in each version basically
two players get put together if your
teammate happened to die at the same
time have you odds are that you'll end
up with them okay if not you're gonna
end up with whoever else is that guy is
thick yeah like that AI is that the
Jailer okay and the Jailer has the key
correct and you kill him yeah you can
sort of buy a freedom all right
Hitchcock oh he's gone he's gone I don't
think he's realizing that's one of those
things you need to group up on like if
you're going to do it it's almost like
will proximity chat work in there or not
it does so that's what I'm kind of
wondering if there's a process
everyone's like all right guys let's be
friendly and you know
but then you'll lie and then you kill
them see that I like however don't team
up with Maven obviously yeah I'm gonna
be dark and twisted less than 10 minutes
remaining in the TCL Power Hour for all
sorts of fun stuff still happens you
have to see a ledge hang elimination or
a multiple player grenade England that's
a two-piece I think we like to call it
in the in the CDL business with a with a
single greniche we don't call them
grenicious which is cool what's the
metal usually popcorn oh something that
was aggressive about a nade oh wait a
minute Precision airstrike I think it's
Precision yeah that was a Precision
airstrike and that looked like a sort of
Side Lane
so how many different uh
like models of vehicles are there
because we're so used to you know you
had what you had the buggy the Jeep the
ATV and the Bertha base we had those
four and they were big set skins how
many like different variations you have
now it seems like a
so there's more variation it seems like
it right we have the the 4x4 which you
just saw we have the uh the
colloquially I'm trying to find the
right web maybe I can't say it on stream
no that's okay that's the guy the
vehicle the four variations for sure a
little older and a little bit more
beating up yeah yeah so you have the
little car you have the uh the 4x4 we
have the armored four by four
um we have the big helicopter little
helicopter ATV tack Rover which is like
a four okay four person like UTV kind of
off-roader
um there is also a crop top uh uh 4x4 as
well so that one's fun you know I have
to watch now is there a car showroom
where we can still see all of these
vehicles in a series about the neighbor
you should put them in yeah this turns
into like a Gran Turismo like showcase
room where you have all your vehicles
you're decking them out I see them I see
potential there that would be honestly
like a little pit my ride type thing
yeah we've seen uh we know vehicle skins
will be in the game they're in the menu
right now so it's gonna be a lot of fun
I have to I mean maybe you can't answer
this one yeah check but of course the
GMC Hummer EV different skins right yeah
eventually of course why wouldn't we
it's gonna be a lot fun though to see
that go down and also do we know how the
refill refueling situation there so the
uh the Eevee situation is that they're
all about like electrical power stations
at the gas stations as well that's right
I'm very relieved yeah because I was
thinking you know surely get to the gas
station there's a little a socket I
wonder how good that like parking jobs
have to be like do they have do you just
have to be in like the vicinity or like
you've got to be right up next to it
properly pretty close you can't be like
you know 10 feet away yeah and if you
haven't Chopper if you have a chopper
you have to come down and close some
like either you know be landing very
precariously between them or probably
just oh wow wow foreign friends
Ninja on your right hand side of the
screen here still rock and roll into the
TCL Power Hour
how many kills zika and has he checked
his private messages
[Laughter]
I'm sure somebody had walked up to him
today and been like what what was that
about hey man we got beef yeah what are
you talking about
super Heaven on the left-hand side of
your screen one of the uh more lethal
war zone players especially bad boy he's
a dangerous animal isn't he he's also
very tall surprisingly large he's like
six five look like you just popped his
DDOS
so any and all electrical equipment in
the nearby Claymores you name it
everything just got sort of tickled in
the in the worst possible way
also affect players can they
if you as a player have been DDOS are
you able to use any sort of equipment at
that moment of time or uh no because
things are already in play in the world
well things that didn't play in the
world disabled um Vehicles can also get
disabled so it's a pretty powerful uh
experience against that too
yeah that's good because sometimes
Vehicles there's a lot of them it can be
frustrating you need a good way to deal
with them that sounds uh
sounds like it can be for sure say
that's the circle all right so
so this might seem familiar to people
too
we're all like locked in this is
familiar wait a minute yeah I was trying
to think of which part it's just an
empty enough oh
it's funny I can like picture them all
in my head and Lord knows I can't like
name them places Mason Brian are getting
fried uh but look at his face he's doing
fine Jack the safe cracker there what
was that is that another sort of a
contract yeah so it's a new contract
where you uh you pick up the contract
and you have three staves you have to uh
uh you know kind of crack the safe and
play some explosive under when you walk
up to it and then they explode there's
some rewards inside each one
individually and then you get an overall
world as well excellent so there's a
time limit as well so you're gonna press
to go do them as quickly as possible hey
one thing we still really enjoyed again
Clinton did the the variety of contracts
in Warzone has been so fun I mean
wherever it may be okay okay Ocean's
Eleven right now starring Iceman Isaac
oh she's one not as exciting still sexy
though I thought it was like a booby
trap at first but no just taking the
actual what have we got in here and
force instead of cheese
and that kind of makes sense like it's
it's a safe right you might have some
rare loot some extra money goodies oh
there's a train okay that one's secret
Jack that's right there that's right get
that real quiet mate that looks great
fun okay is that a sort of similar
situation what we had of the dance a lot
of toys on it yeah and you're actually
gonna see some more things that are
trained related to launch
um the the fun one for me is being able
to jump up on the roof of a car and then
jump to the movie oh we're talking like
wild west style like all right
is absolutely lit ladies and gentlemen
it said so far he's watching them kind
of learn here to talk to her stuff
Bobby's voice
found the key to a stronghold though
doesn't mean you have to kill these
players kill the uh combats around it
and then get inside get it hit it that's
key and then go to the next one what is
the key do the key helps you get into
the black side oh wow okay all right
that's the channel
so the second number is not the teams
like in a different Circle outside of
the one you're currently occupying
correct there's the knock no you're in
okay so it's the one that you're in that
makes sense okay oh amazing oh nice
shots oh God now there's tank bullets
giant bullets from this vehicle oh
they're pushing this is if that counts
as a vehicular elimination if they get
the killer there it is
and it's on the TV well done
uh he got the knock on the water I don't
think he was ready for the second to
swap right into it
though
I love the idea of getting a key and
just sort of like you know I'm not gonna
fight this one out I'm just going to hit
the door wherever I may be
Symphony Nick merch versus pointing off
him in God so what were you aiming for
like time wise I was curious like game
are they a little bit longer right now
it feels like the matches yeah
um we right now because we're playing
around with the lengths of like how long
each circle lives before they collapse
um you know it might feel a little bit
longer yeah Philly was like closer to 30
minutes like 25 somewhere just probably
a little bit longer the the circles do
something interestingly sometimes you
get a little bit more of a pause in the
middle as each circle kind of resolves
itself okay collapsing
um so it can lead to some like different
flows interesting that's kind of cool a
little variety
I've got a question Jack a specific one
can we uh can we sort of like um
perform a takedown on the jailer
not right now okay it's a good idea
we'll hold on to that imagine you're
going to take him down then I get behind
you and go take you down and then we get
a take down conga line and he gets real
quick yeah yeah and meanwhile our other
teammates are just sort of staring at us
in party chat like hey did we go to
college together I'm like oh maybe
how many kids you got that might help me
Brock's Shadow help me Brock's chat is
gonna be something
show me something special
we're back at the tents name of stuff oh
dear God hey you know what hello
they hit the other Roof oh look at them
that shadow look it looks so badass he's
like fine over the top bro right
well there we go TCR power out still
rolling friends actually we should be
nearly finished with that one but we've
definitely had uh Hey we've been having
a couple of bingoes we'll get back to
those yeah sorry for the bombardment I'm
not going to answer questions no sorry
for that moment it was great peace well
done mate I do believe that we are ready
uh possibly
to toss to Gina Gina what's going on
down on the floor hi how y'all doing up
there look I'm here with a very good
friend of mine diesel what's up dude
it's been a while it has it has been a
bit yeah look the energy here is
palpable everything has been going so
crazy how does it feel to be here today
it feels good I mean we've been talking
I've been playing Warzone since it came
out so it's good to finally get your
hands on Warzone 2 uh which feels
incredible everybody will get to play it
eventually it's a little bit different
than uh I was expecting but all in all
in a good way so you are definitely no
stranger to Call of Duty so many things
were announced today what are you
looking forward to the most
probably just playing the beta with uh
ultimate of optic just just us getting
together and playing again it's been a
bit since we played uh regular
multiplayer so the beta tomorrow will be
a lot of fun so looking forward to that
so there are tons of streamers here
today all around the world who is
someone out there that you're hoping to
get into a friendly
with probably May yeah for well who's my
girlfriend she's playing back there so
running up that would be a fun car ride
home I think yeah I think it'd be good
I'm gonna tell her you said that we're
going to be looking out for that
specifically shout out to May uh that's
all from me here y'all let's go back to
your desk and see what's going on over
there
thank you so much Gina uh guys once
again we're gonna get into another drop
before that though each Jack Link's
supply drop includes a brand new copy of
Modern Warfare on the platform of your
choice epic Jack Link's limited edition
products and check this out on how to
enter once again
looking for an epic way to celebrate the
launch of Modern Warfare 2 Jack Links
has got you covered giving you the
chance to win the ultimate Modern
Warfare 2 supply drop keep an eye out
during the broadcast for the Jack Link
Sasquatch to appear on screen if you see
it grab your phone and scan the QR code
following the prompts to qualify for
entries tune in to Call of Duty next
Squad up with Sasquatch and level up for
the ultimate viewing experience courtesy
of Jack Links terms and conditions apply
all right so this is your last chance
keep
them throughout the show
QR code enter all your information for a
chance to win you saw the goodies you
won all the goodies platform of your
choice and all the yum yums can't wait
guys one more drop one more big and
we're gonna roll onwards through the
show it's been a sensational day Call of
Duty next I mean good God I'm pumped for
tomorrow listen man we've seen
everything that's a lot dude it's a lot
to take in like I was looking at that
war zone game that we just watched I was
like man Warzone 2.0 looks sick but then
we got mobile MP the new game modes new
weapons new gunsmith like it's gonna
take a while to get through I'll listen
when we get to the beta telling me mate
well again we want to say massive thanks
once again to TCL the Power Hour comes
to a close TCL Power hours a lot of fun
and hey while we were waiting I do
believe we got another one that's right
the vehicle elimination went down and uh
we may have some footage ladies and
Gentlemen let's see let's have a little
a cheeky peek at how that one went down
again there's plenty of vehicles whether
you get run over dropped on explode and
taken care of
I we saw it on camera didn't we what am
I saying it was Hunter we screamed his
name aloud here oh where do you got
Mason I'm sorry they got they got
Symphony that's right but there we go
the TCR power you had me excited I
thought someone got smashed by a truck
or something I I was ready
crazy crazy but also don't forget to
share your favorite moments um from
across the TCL Power Hour uh you saw the
hashtags can't I mean we want to see
your favorite moments all these teams
200 of them clip them send them to us uh
you know at TCL underscore USA we want
to see those clips can't wait
Twitter's gonna be popping I mean I've
already seen some crazy games dirty got
like the first quad feed he tweeted that
one out he got a couple already they're
spamming the timeline I'm sure right now
you're seeing clips left and right it's
gonna be good one more drop guys here as
you can see the Timothy the tap Mount I
do believe this is it the last drop here
in Warzone 2.0 before we uh we will say
a due until November 16th when you get
to play this for free at home oh looky
looky Sasquatch phones out scan the code
what if I said no Ali that's just rude
I'm sorry I was kidding I didn't mean it
my phone's literally out you can see it
in my hand right now
listen I have a question for you guys
because I was on standby with no audio
next to the stage yeah ready to come
back up did you get an answer about the
loadouts you got a lot of answers I
think of the current build right now now
no but they plan to be to upgrade your
weapon yeah all sorts dude I mean what
we are seeing now is still Alpha
gameplay yeah a lot of this is likely to
change Stephanie silver talks up here
earlier saying the gulags likely to
change they've gone through different
iterations who knows what the buy
station you saw might not be the same
one November really like strip this down
what do you think of the maps and stuff
like that how the Looting system works
like they're gonna change some stuff oh
that was cool speed they change
everything like that that's why I really
want to pick his brain while he's up
here I mean as much as it's fun to get
hype about the big moments have a blast
with it but all these guys are streaming
too well we had a Dev up here
we had to say like I want to pick his
brand and he had a lot of great answers
for us I'm gonna do what I kind of get
Jack's number and just uh yeah on a
regular basis bless that man putting in
the hard work and answering our
questions as ridiculous as they may seem
you know this map reminds you of almaza
reminds me a little bit like for dancing
Caldera mixed into one because like if
you have these areas like this reminds
me of airport from verdansk and then you
jump out you're walking around you're in
the desert I I don't see a ton of
skyscrapers so I'm happy yeah there are
too many tall buildings but this there's
like I don't know two to three story
there's a couple bigger ones but nothing
nothing too wild so we haven't actually
seen this I think there are two major
city locations yeah we haven't been
there too much I haven't seen how tall
those are you're right there could be
some calories there could be some
Biggins
again I'm loving this yeah I was
literally gonna say that I love the
first aid kit on the wall again it's the
logic used to be brought us up clintus
it's not necessarily that you know the
loose is crazy or anything but the idea
that I can visit a location that I know
is there yeah and go all right I'm
looking for this I need armor I need
ammunition I'm looking for money right
now the idea of like regain we talk
about that when like let's say your
whole team's been wiped you're the only
one who survived the gulag now you've
got a game plan almost
100 I mean I feel like you have to I I
no I don't know if there's anything like
with the AI if there's like rechargeable
loot or anything like that like that
became a thing like rechargeable chess
in regular war zone I find myself it's
so dude I got so used to like ballooning
everywhere that it's like weird for me
not to even see diamonds like it's just
a big change this comes
you drop into the map like oh no yeah I
will destroy you I will I I definitely
aim straighter than you you might have a
better aren't you like you just never
said to put that on Broadway you were
never very talented oh wow and the
goalie it's uh we've got we've got
methods alongside somebody gonna get
hanky and this is the last one we're
gonna see
one down it's a 2V1
come on Jenny show me something special
[Applause]
anymore
crushed you know ah cut the gameplay cut
it I've seen enough zinny is the reason
the broadcasters don't know
right um focus up team once more we go
now it's time to take a look at some
more epic best plays brought to you by
hyperx check this out
seeing Tim here we didn't see too much
of him Tim got killed by that Chopper
does he I think I think so
so
yeah guy knows what he's doing yes this
is uh another Gulag clip
oh oh Zuma
it froze like a perfect time
that was crazy
crib six
flying around kills with him
oh this is the fennec as well he's about
to shred someone three two one stems in
jiggle people
I think we should rip him off that heady
for a second nice shot my Biff was
disgusting that hip fire looks really
good there it does
it doesn't even like people was looking
at his mono
yeah they were surviving men five each
other back this is friendship and trust
and love though that's brother we love
TST AKA
all right there we go that was our
highlight plays presented by hyperx and
guys I hate to say it
thank you for those of you doing this
the whole day thank you so much um guys
final thoughts Clinton uh listen
hey it's so much I can't wait to break
it down more uh it was so cool to hear
the devs thoughts on stuff this was yeah
this was like perfect to me because not
only did we have
the streamers here doing their thing
getting the game play we had the devs to
break down and give us some of the more
nerdy stuff we want to talk about we got
to you know cast a little bit ask some
questions like yeah this was just a very
good like balance of everything Cod and
it filled my heart with goddamn Joy oh
man Ali how are you gonna top that I
don't think I really can't
I'm gonna be honest uh I will just say
you know I mean I just I'm gonna echo in
my own wording I mean it was a lot of
questions answered right it was so many
what's going to be happening with the
upcoming year and we got all of it in
just this mosh pit of Call of Duty I
mean it was just half a day of just cod
cod cod cod cod and like it was an
absolute pleasure and honestly I have to
say I'm so excited for Warzone I never
thought I'd say that out of my mouth it
was one thing about Warzone that it kind
of turned me away because it was so
chaotic right I couldn't predict things
I couldn't really break down a whole lot
circles were chaotic loot was chaotic
and it seems like they've taken that
refined it and now there's a little bit
more stability you know where loot's
going to be there's three circles so
it's not like if I'm across the map I'm
screwed you know like there's so many
different elements now so I just can't
wait for November 16th Jeff Joe you hear
that you got him you got another one
right there and what about you brother
it's amazing and there's still so much
more to come right like we heard a
little bit about DMZ like what is that
tell me more yeah we're gonna learn in
the future spec ops as well they talk
about a little bit we even heard earlier
rank play coming in the future so we got
so much Call of Duty duty if today
wasn't enough for you like there's gonna
be more oh so so so much more uh we do
want to remind everyone though one more
time that Modern Warfare 2 it launches
October 28th but it's available to
pre-order right now pre-order and get
early access to the open Beta that
starts tomorrow on PlayStation and next
week on Xbox and PC uh don't forget the
pre-order Vault edition if you get that
one you're gonna get those amazing
looking red team one for one skins uh
you saw today but not only at the launch
you get those in the beta as well so
that's lit uh also the fjx cinder weapon
Vault you guys have seen that in action
today that's the fully Decked Out M4
weapon platform uh and that's certainly
something you're not going to want to
miss out on insane oh and also don't
forget uh pre-order any edition of
Modern Warfare 2 and play the campaign
up to a week early I'm a campaign guy
absolutely love to do that you all saw
this Warzone mobile action live today as
well and don't forget you can also go
right now to the Google Play Store and
pre-register for your free download of
Call of Duty Warzone mobile while I mean
frankly guys there's a lot whatever
platform you're on it's all yours but
that is it for us guys on behalf of
myself Maven Alley Cat nameless all the
other Talent here everyone behind the
scenes thank you so much we'll see you
on the beta
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign